AND FISCAL SUBCOMMITTEE THREE
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HE
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
CENTER MELENDEZ IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF IF YOU'RE HERE NOW. I
YEAH I AM HERE THERE YOU GO ALL
RIGHT AND DO YOU HAVE STAFF
WITH EVEN IF YOU DO CAN YOU
IDENTIFY THEM. I DO AMANDA
FISHER IS HERE WITH ME IN THE
OTHER AROUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PERCENT PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONES AND
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. PASS IT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED AND
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO AND MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT THE ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL PUT
YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE
DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN. YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE ACCESS WE WOULD BE MEMBERS
OF THE- TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OR PRESS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. FOUR
ONE. EIGHT FIVE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE THREE. EIGHT ZERO
FOUR SIX FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY INTO A AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. PLEASE MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING FROM PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING ROOM
AND OR HAVE YOUR CONNECTION
MUTED. WELL EVERY F. HAS MADE
HISTORY THE HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE BANNER AS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE.
INTERESTED TO ALL PARTIES CAN
HERE. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM DR BOOK IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN HERE. EGGMAN HERE
MELENDEZ. YOUR MELENDEZ OF HERE
PAN HERE PAN IS HERE. OKAY WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A CORE. IN TWO
DAYS HERE WE WILL BE DISCUSSING
PROPOSALS FROM THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
IN PART A AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN PART BE
WILL BEGIN DISCUSSING OTHER
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT THE
SENATE IS CONSIDERING FOR
INCLUSION IN THE BUDGET. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE ITEM AND ITEMS IN
BOTH PART A AND PART B. BEFORE
TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AND
VOTING. ONCE WE'VE HEARD OF ALL
THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT
ON ANY AGENDA ITEM. A
SUBSEQUENT TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD WE WILL VOTE ON
THE AGENDA ITEMS WE WILL EITHER
TAKE ONE VOTE TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS LISTED ON
THE AGENDA OR TO TWO SEPARATE
VOTES IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHICH TO PULL. FOUR
SEPARATE VOTES- BEGINNING WITH
PART EIGHT AND OUR GENDER WE
HAVE THE HEALTH OF HUMANS THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. AND WE WOULD WELCOME
THE ADMINISTRATION. I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE WITH US A
FIRST ASCENT THE TRUE TRUTH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. MADERA.
STRUCTURE YOUR VIDEOS OFF. MY
APOLOGIES THIS IS CYNTHIA
TUCKER AND WITH THE- OFFICE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION TRAVEL FOR
JUST SERVICES AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER THAT- I'VE BEEN
REQUESTED TO PROVIDE A HIGH
LEVELOVERVIEW I LOOKED AT THE
AGENDA AND THE INFORMATION ON
THAT WAS VERY WELL WRITTEN SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO I'M JUST
GOING TO PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL
AND WE CAN SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR. SO
THIS BE C. PAPER. WHY HUNDRED
AND EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TOTAL FUNDS. WITH SIXTY EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND FOR STATE AND COUNTY
STAFF. CONSULTANT AND VENDOR
RESOURCES. TO CONTINUE
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATION RESPONSE AND
ENGAGEMENT SYSTEM. ALSO KNOWN
AS CARES. ROGIC IS A
PARTNERSHIP. OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION AND THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE FIFTY
EIGHT CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES.
THIS IS TO REPLACE THE EXISTING
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. THE EXISTING
SYSTEM WHICH WAS IMPLEMENTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IS USED
BY COUNTY AND STATE STAFF TO
SERVE A PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND NO
LONGER SUPPORTS CURRENT FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS REGULATIONS OR
POLICIES. THE CARRIAGE PROJECT
ORIGINALLY FOCUSED ON A CUSTOM
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT SAYS UPDATED
APPROACH DUE TO THE LENGTH OF
TIME I WAS CHECKING THE BILL
THE SYSTEM. THE PROJECT UPDATED
TO CONFIGURE AN EMPLOYEE. USING
WHAT IS CALLED THE- ASISTIR
WHICH IS. A VENDOR MANAGED
PLATFORM ON USING- AN EXISTING
VENDORS. REAL MANAGEMENT. AND
DEVELOP TOOLS TO BUILD THE CORK
SPUN. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
PROJECT TO FOCUS MORE ON THE
CORE BUSINESS NEEDS RATHER THAN
MAINTAINING. AND DEVELOPING A
CUSTOM PLATFORM. I'M WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY THE
PROJECT IS EXECUTED THE PRIMARY
SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT VENDOR
CONTRACTS AND HAS BEGUN THE
DESIGN THE END DESIGN
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
STATES. THIS BASICALLY REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL COUNTY AND
VENDOR RESOURCES WELL THAT
OCCURS PROJECT TO CONTINUE
THESE DEMAND I ACTIVITIES.
REPLACE THE EXISTING SYSTEM. SO
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. OR IF YOU'D LIKE ME
TO GET INTO FURTHER DETAIL IN
SOME AREAS- WELL I GUESS JUST
WITH NY IT PROJECT WE'RE
TAKING ON IT AS A AS A MEANS OF
STREAMLINING AND IMPROVING-
WHAT KIND OF CHECKS AND
REPORTING BACK TO LEGISLATURE
WILL YOU HAVE. ON THE PROGRESS
OF THIS. THIS NEW VENDOR
DEPUTATION SO WE DID I'M SORRY
WE DO HAVE A MONTHLY REPORT
THAT GOES. TO LEGISLATURE AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE A QUARTERLY
UPDATES- WITH AT STAFFERS IN
ORDER O KEEP THEM APPRISED OF
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
PROJECT- TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF US HAVE THE SAME
UNDERSTANDING AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AS WELL AS OUR-
REPORTING RESPONSIBILITIES TO
SENIOR TEAM WITH REGARDS TO
THEIR OVERSIGHT OF OUR PROJECT.
DOCUMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE RIGHT UP I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT- THIS IS A-
REQUEST FOR A HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT. RIGHT FIVE MILLION- FOOT
SIXTY EIGHT IS GENERAL FUND SO
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A- SOME
CERTAINLY AWESOME SOMEWHAT
SUBSTANTIVE REQUEST- SO JUST A
FEW THE FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT I KNOW THAT
FASTER. AND FOR LAST YEAR WITH
COACH AND WERE NOT ABLE TO DO
THE LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT OVER-
THAT- IT PROJECTS- THAT- WE
WERE ABLE TO DO IN THE PAST
AND- BUT- OKAY I JUST WANT I
GUESS ONE QUESTION IS THAT- SO
IS THIS PART OF THE- LARGER- I.
T. PROJECT WE'RE DOING WITH.
THE VARIOUS STATE. THAT VARIOUS
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH IS THIS
AN AERATION OF THIS. WE WERE
DOING WE GET THIS SORT OF LARGE
INTEGRATIVE PROCESS PROJECT
THAT WAS YOU KNOW INVOLVING
COUNTY INS NO D. S. YACHT THE
PARCEL SERVICE AND SO FORTH
THAT. I BELIEVE AT LEAST THE
LAST TIME WE HEARD THE TIMELINE
WAS TO TRY TO COMPLETE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IS THIS A IS
THIS A PIECE OF THAT PROJECT OR
IS THIS THAT PROJECT WE'RE
TALKING. IT IS THAT PROJECTS
THAT PROJECT OKAY ALL RIGHT IN
NINETEEN YOU TO SPEAK TO THE
ROLE OF SALES FORCE I KNOW YOU
SAID DOES THE PLATFORM AS A
SERVICE- AND EXACTLY WHAT IS
THE ON GOING COSTS TO THE STATE
OF USING SALES FORCE- SO IT. SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE THE BUILDING ON
THEIR PLATFORM AND THAT THAT'S
FINE IT'S GREAT TO BE A
LEVERAGE BUT WHAT EXACTLY IS
THE EXPECT I MEAN WHAT'S THE
CONTRACT. SALES FORCE INVOLVED.
ARAMBULA CONTRACTORS THERE'S-
FORCES AND THEN- THERE. SUPPORT
TO ASSIST US WE DEVELOPING ON
THEIR CLASS. THEY MADE. THAT
THAT. WILL USING FOR COURT- SO
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN SOME THAT'S
TO GET IT STAGES AS TO. HOW
MUCH OF THE TIME. WILL BE USING
WAS FORCE. AND SO WE DO. WITH
G. ON- ON. A WORK CELLS
ACCORDING TO LICENSE WHAT'S UP
KNOW WITH WHAT'S THE PRO.
NUMBER IN THAT WE BUILD OUT AND
OUT. AND- AS- LEARN BIT MORE.
SPECIFIC FONG SPECIFIC- WHICH
**** FUNCTION- IN CELLS FLAP.
THEN WILL BE A TO HAVE BETTER.
OUR. LONGER TERM WITH YOUR TO
THE NUMBER USERS. OKAY PUT IS
THERE A ROUGH ESTIMATE IS TO
THE CENTRAL BUILDING THIS ON
THIS FIVE AND AGAIN AND THAT'S
THAT'S OF YOU KNOW BAD I. BUT
WHAT WHAT IS THE GOING BECAUSE
THEM. I REALIZE MEDIA THE
NUMBER LIE SO BUT REALIZED
CERTAINLY THAT ROUGH ESTIMATE
OR RAIN OF. WELL IT YOU KNOW
SERVING THIS. PROJECT GOES TO
COMES OF. AND DOES THE THINGS
YOU TO WHAT IS THE ON WHAT WAS
THE ON BACK- LIFE BECAUSE TO
THIS. FOR BUILDING ON THIS
FORCE. I DON'T WOULD NEED TO
CHECK THAT BACK AND- I DO NOT
HAVE A SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNT
FUNDED ME. UNLESS ONE OF MY-
HAS ADDED TO FINGER JEFF. YEAH
I MEAN I'M NOT EXPECTING. ON
AMOUNT THAT SCALE WE'RE TALKING
TENS MILLIONS HUNDREDS OF. I'M
GOT I REALLY DON'T WANT TO MISS
I DON'T THINK IT'S A KNOW IT'S
NOT OF NO. ALL RIGHT. WELL AND
GET BACK TO A ON THAT- AND THE
OTHER QUESTION IS- HE'S ALSO-
INTO SO I JUST WANT A SENSE OF
THAT PART OF IT AND THEN- IN
THEN AGAIN THAT'S- FOR THE- RAJ
ACT- SO YOU SAID THAT IT'S FOLK
ON A YOU KNOW- SAID THE- THAT
SO OKAY I GUESS. CAN I- WELL
CAN WE CAN WE HAVE L. A. O.
PERHAPS COME ON THIS- PER THE
MAN CARE INDIA SOME QUESTIONS
FOLLOWING A. AS COMMON I MIGHT
MY QUESTION WE IS GOING TO BE A-
ONE WE WHEN WE- ABOUT THIS
ABOUT DAY. AND DATA SECURITY OF
THE OF OUR OF OUR FOLKS IN THE
SYSTEM. OF M. I'M SURE THAT'S
WAS PART OF THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL. YES ABSOLUTELY IN FACT-
WITH THE SALES FORCE AND HOW
WE'RE BUILDING WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING SECURITY TESTING
THROUGHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT-
INCLUDING BRINGING-
INDEPENDENT- REVIEW. TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE THE SAFEKEEPING OF.
OF OUR HANDS. THE DATA
PROGRAMMATIC DATA. OKAY THE END
AND IF YOU BUY ON CELLS FOR
SOME THEY'LL DRAW DATA BUT IT
TO DO WHAT DEGREE WHAT SORT OF
FOLLOW. DID HAVE WORK THINGS
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT MEASURES TO
HAVE IN PLACE TO ENSURE- THAT
IF THERE'S A DATA BREACH THAT
THAT. BECAUSE OF SOME FAULT OF
THERE SO YOU KNOW HOW HOUSE
HELD UP THE HANDLE. SO HAVE
FOR. IN THIS- CLOUD COMPUTING
GRID. AS WELL AS THE- SASS
PROVISIONS. THAT DISCUSSED
EIGHT IF THERE WERE TO BE A
BREACH THAT SALES FORCE OR THAT
THE AND- THE VENDORS WOULD BE
ASSISTING US- WITH REGARDS- AND-
EMILY READING. THE PROBLEM AS
WELL AS- ASSISTING IN ANY
NOTIFICATION XCERRA ALSO IN ONE
OF OUR VENDOR CONTRACTS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A- THE OVER ARCHING
SYSTEMS. INTEGRATOR CONTRACT WE
HAVE- SERVICE LEVEL AGREEMENTS
IN THERE WITH REGARDS TO-
SECURITY AND XCERRA- THAT THEY-
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR TO ENSURE.
THAT THE OVERALL SYSTEM. IT'S
OUR NEED S. OKAY AND- A SIM HAS
THE APPROVAL OF APPROPRIATE
LIKE- PART OF TECH. AND I DON'T
KNOW THERE ARE I THINK OUR-
NATIONAL GUARD ALSO DOES SOME
CYBER SECURITY WORK HAVE DAVE
DONE OF THAT HAVE THEY DREADED
THE AS THE PLATFORM TO ENSURE
THAT- MEETS OUR STANDARDS FOR
SECURITY. I WOULD NEED TO DEFER
TO CDG ON THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IS THIS PLATFORM IS USED
IN OTHER CONTRACTS- AND SO I
WOULD SAY. YES BUT I WOULD NEED
AS FAR AS SPECIFIC SECURITY
REVIEWS ETCETERA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY I'M I'M I
WOULD DIFFER IT AS IS SO YOU'RE
SAYING THIS PLATFORM'S BEEN
USED BY THE STATE FOR OTHER
SENSITIVE INFORMATION EQUALLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION. I KNOW
THERE IS BEING USED ACROSS. I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS IT'S IN USE FOR OKAY
SO I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL
PERHAPS- AND WE'VE DONE THIS
PREVIOUSLY OF THE PSYCHE
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WELL WHEN
WE DO OVERSIGHT. BUT I WAS
HOPING WE CAN HEAR ALSO SOME
OVERSIGHT FROM L. A. L. TWO
SUGGESTIONS MILLENNIAL BUT YET
BUT I SEE CITY T. IS ALSO ALSO
HERE NOW. OKAY. BANK- THIS IS
FOR CONTRACT WE HAD A LEGAL
REVIEW BUT THIS AND PROVISION
SIDE OF THE AND WE CHAU THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR BY
FOR THIS YEAR ADVANTAGE AND THE
INCLUDED A DATA AND THIS YEAR
FIRST OKAY THEN I GUESS ONE OF
QUESTION IN TERMS OF AGAIN AND
NOW I'VE IT. BUT WE DESIGNED
THE SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT. FOR
LET'S SAY FIVE OR YEARS FROM
NOW- WE THIS THAT. SELLS FOR
ISN'T THE PARTNER WANT TO USE
WE WATCH FOR. THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO THAT OR- SIGN IN
A WAY THAT SORT OF LOCKS US. A
WHERE- YOU KNOW THAT'S THE POOL.
WE HAVE TO USE. THE GOAL IS TO
HAVE OUR BUSINESS RULES AND OUR
DATA- AND EIGHT WHAT'S CALLED A
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SEPARATE APART FROM SALES FORCE
TO ALLOW THE STATE TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUTURE WE
HAVE THE OWNERSHIP OF THAT CORE
INFORMATION AND SO IN THE
FUTURE SHOULD WE WANT TO CHANGE
PLATFORMS OR DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. WE WOULD NOT BE
LOCKED IN. OKAY THAT'S GOING TO
BE I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE OWN THE DATA
THAT WE CONTROL THE DATA THAT
WE'RE NOT IN THAT SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE LOCKED INTO A
PARTICULAR VENDOR BECAUSE OUT
OF DESIGN. WE WOULD BE IN
AGREEMENT WITH THAT. HELLO.
PRIME MINISTER LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE RAISE NO
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS BUT
WOULD RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUOUS OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROJECT THROUGH THE MONTHLY
REPORTS AND QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS
THAT WERE ALREADY MENTIONED-
THE ESTIMATED TOTAL COST OF
THIS PROJECT HAS INCREASED FROM
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO NINE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN MILLION WITH AROUND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN SPENT- THE ESTIMATED TOTAL
PROJECT COST COULD CHANGE
HOWEVER AS THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROCUREMENTS THAT ARE STILL
UNDER WAY AND CDC IS REQUIRING
A MORE PRECISE COST ESTIMATION
BE PROVIDED BY THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR- THE PROJECT IS
ALSO ANTICIPATING A PILOT. FOR
A SINGLE MODULE FROM THE
PROJECT IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
TEST WHETHER THIS NEW APPROACH
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DESCRIBED
AS WORKING AND TO ESTABLISH KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS TO SHOW
WITH DATA WHETHER NEW SYSTEM
FUNCTIONALITIES ARE IMPROVING-
THE SYSTEM THE STATE'S-
BUSINESS PROCESS SEES AND SO
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
PARTICULAR PILOT MODULE IN THE
CREATION OF THOSE- KPIS OR KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS I'M WILL
BE CRITICAL TO SEE WHETHER THE.
PROJECT WILL BE SUCCESSFUL
GOING FORWARD. YEAH I WOULD I
THINK A STEP THIS LIKE THIS IN
HAVE A STEP YET MUCH WEEK THOSE
A- THAT WE BE ABLE TO CHECK THE-
IN- AND AGAIN JUST CONTINUE TO
BACK WITH THE WITH THE PROCESS.
ALRP DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING ON THIS. JUST RAISED-
FINANCE I'M COMMENT THAT THERE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE BECAUSE-
THIS IS JUST ONE COMPONENT. OF
THE PROPOSAL YOU'LL SEE THE-
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
COMPONENT INCLUDING THE MAY
REVISION SO- I DIDN'T JUST I
CAN SAY THAT OUR SERVER.
THEY'LL BE SOME. TIME TO ANSWER
SOME OF YOUR QUESTION. OKAY
WELL I GUESS I'D SAY IT JUST IS
THAT. EVERY THAT AND
RECOGNIZING HERE WE'LL JUST
LOOK AT ONE P. OF THAT- AT IN
APPRECIATE WE'RE DOING THE-
REPORTS ON THE COR THE REPORT.
BY I THINK AT LEAST FOR US IS
LEGISLATORS- WE PROBABLY SHOULD
AT LEAST ANNUALLY- HAVE A YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S A HEARING
WITHIN THE BUDGETS OF THREE
FIVE ELECTED TO SPEND A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL. AND DEPTH TIME.
GOING OVER- JUST THAT THE
PROJECT AYE YOU'LL MAKE NOTE
AGAIN AS LA- MENTIONED THEY'LL
THE PRICE OF THE PROJECT HAS
GONE UP FOR. CLOSING IN ON A
BILLION- SELLER NINE HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION- AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S- GOING ON HI.
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
THING I ALSO WOULD JUST WANNA
PUT A PEN ON IS THAT AND I'VE
ASKED THIS QUESTION USUALLY
WITH IT PROJECTS IN THE PAST.
IS THAT- YES OFTENTIMES YEAH
AND IT PROJECTS SHOULD ALSO
IMPROVE OUR EFFICIENCY. SO SO
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO BE
INVESTING- THAT THIS POINT OVER
NINE HUNDRED MILLION IN THIS
PROJECT- IT- SO IT'S GOOD TO
KNOW WHAT METRICS WERE HAVING
IN TERMS OF INCREASED
PRODUCTIVITY. OF- STATE AND
COUNTY. NO ALSO. BETTER
IMPROVEMENTS AND- OF SERVICE
AND SPLIT ENDS. WHETHER TO. OR
ARE. NOW AND FORTH. FOR OUR
CLIENT HEALTH KLEIN. TO ARE
BEING SERVED. SO WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME OF THOSE METRICS
IDENTIFIED AND MEASURED SO THAT
WE KNOW THAT THIS INVESTMENT
THAT WE'RE MAKING OF ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WHAT WE'RE
GETTING BACK IN RETURN FOR
THAT- SO. OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE
SAY OH YEAH WE NEED A NEW I. T.
PROJECT AND WILL HAVE ALL
THESE. THINGS WILL BE BETTER
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BETTER
QUANTIFY THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING. FOUR
INVESTMENT WITH THESE IT
PROJECTS ESPECIALLY AGAINST YOU
KNOW WE HAVE. THE SPECIAL
RESPONDING THIS MUCH MONEY ON
THEM. FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
INDICATORS ARE AND THEN FIGURE
OF FOR ME TO THEM AND IF AND
HOW DO WE GET IF WE'RE- IN. THE
PROTECT IN PLACE FOR. SOME A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS GOES WRONG.
JUST LIKE. APARTMENT OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT WE ALL HEAR ABOUT
IT AND IT. THAT WE DON'T WE
DON'T WANT ANYTHING LIKE THIS
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE. IN THE
CHILD WELFARE. SERVICES TO BE
ALL OVER THE FRONT PAGE AND
HAVING MULTIPLE PEOPLE AT RISK.
OKAY- CENTER MELINDA'S ANY
QUESTIONS. WARS ARE SORRY NO
QUESTIONS ELIGIBLE TO WORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY. ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT MOVING ON THEN.
SO THEN WE ARE GOING TO. AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ON
DISTRICT JUST DID THAT ONE WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES THE CWS CARES
PROJECT STAFF RESOURCES. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS-
JENNIFER TROIA IN THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
GOOD TO BE HERE WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT ARE ARE AND
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS OR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS FOR.
THE OPERATION STAFFING- THIS
FIRST ONE IS FAMILIAR AS IT'S A
CONTINUATION OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU WERE JUST
HAVING FOR EACH OF THESE- OUR
PROGRAM LEADS AND DEPUTY
DIRECTORS WILL- ANSWER YOUR
MORE DETAILED QUESTIONS- I JUST
WANTED TO KIND OF GIVE THIS
OVERALL OPENING REMARK AND AT
OF THE PRIORITY OF THESE- ITEMS
FOR OUR OVERALL OPERATIONS AND-
INDICATE THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. AS THE MAY
REVISION IS RELEASED LATER THIS
WEEK SO FOR THIS ITEM- I'LL
INVITE AND YOU SORTS ARE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION TO
ANSWER YOUR MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WELCOME A
SHORT. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
FIRST ISSUE IS THAT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON U. S. CARE
FOR PRICE BACK REPORT THE
REQUESTED FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND PER
YEAR FOR FIVE YEAR EXTENSION OF
EACH EXISTING LIMITED TERM
POSITION TRICKS. ON JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WOULD
EXTEND THE POSITION THREE TWO
THIRD OF TWENTY THANK- IN I
NEED TO SUPPORT AND DEVELOP AND
THEN. IF YOU ARE CARRIED IN THE
CONTINUED PLAN DESIGN AND
DEVELOPMENT I'M TO TRANSITION
INTO THE MAIN NOT OF THE SYSTEM
AND IN REVIEWING THE QUESTION
FROM THE A JOHN I REQUEST OF
WHETHER THE OVERALL PLAN THE
PLAY OF THE MY AND ANTI FOR THE
COMPLETE. IDEA PLAN TO DEPLOY
THE PER OF THE W. I CARRIED IN
OVER THE NEXT YEARS I'M MORE
BEGIN WITH THE OF IMPLEMENT OF
AGREE FIELD AND THAT SCHEDULED
TO BE IN JUST A COUPLE MONTHS
JUNE TWENTY. WITH PROJECTED
COUNTY AMPLE BY MAR TWENTY
TWENTY KILLED THE NEXT PHASE
ABOUT OF THE GIVE YOU A CARE
ACT VERSION ONE POINT IS
PROJECTED TO BE AND OF. I'M
THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
IN COUNTY I MAY TWENTY TWENTY
AND ALLOW WILL BE FINE BY W. I.
JERRY PERSON. WHICH ONE EXTEND
FUNCTION OF THE SYSTEM. AND THE
DECOMMISSIONED OF THE P. W.
YEAH MY PLAY GET THE SEPTEMBER
AFTER. OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
THE OTHER QUESTION PRESENTED-
IN THE AGENDA WAS WILL
PERMANENT POSITION BEING NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN AND UPDATE. HE
DEBBIE I SCARED THE FUTURE. BUT
WE DO INTO THAT OF THE LIMB
TERM FUNDED TO. MADE AT REQUIRE
SUPPORT AFTER WE'VE- YOU HAVE
YET I'M NOT BUT THE NUMBER AND
TYPE OF STOCK REPORT THAT THAT
WILL REQUIRED. I IF I AT THE.
THE INTERNATIONAL. OKAY
DEPARTMENT FINE. JUST READ
BARBARA FINANCED NO NATIONAL
COMMENTS THE START HELLO. BRIAN
MAY OF A. O. NO ADDITIONAL.
THANK THANK YOU AN- SO I GUESS
QUESTION FOR DEPA SOCIAL SAID
THE STAFF POSITION- ARE THEY
PEOPLE WHO WERE SO KNOW WE JUST
SAW FOR ON THE TO SET ASIDE WE
HAVE A NOW WITH THIS ON SIDE
AND YOUR AGE SIDE IS THEIR ROLE
WHEN HE SAID- USER REESE THIS I
THAT AND- ARE- DIS IT ARE THESE
PEOPLE WERE ON THE I U. ERROR-
SO HE HE'S VERY SPEAK. WELL
SPEAK A GUESS A GOOD BUTTON TO
THRUST MY QUESTION IS THAT
OFTEN TELL ARE I. T. PROJECT
FAIL NOT NOT SO BECAUSE THE
ITSELF- DOESN'T WORK A DOESN'T
WORK IN A WAY THAT WORKS WITH.
WHO HAVE USE WHICH MEANS IT
DOESN'T WORK AND THAT WAY IT'S
NOT THE IT'S- THAT PROGRAM IT'S-
IT IS. SO IT SO HE'S TO. HOW
ORANGE. THAT THIS NEW CARE
SYSTEM. IS ONE THEY'LL BE. BY
THE U. AND IS THE USER. TO THE
USER SINCE. AND NOW JUST THIS
THIS THAT SOMEONE. SIX ON THE
COMPUTER NOW IT'S YOUR TURN YOU
HAVE TO USING. AND A BRIDGE. IT
WORK AFTER THE WORK AROUNDS AND
SO FORTH SO IS THAT THE ROLE OF
THESE. EIGHT PEOPLE YEAH. THESE
ARE NOT- I DIVISION BIGGER.
PROJECT MATTER ACT- HOPEFULLY.
WITH THE- IF I STOPPED OKAY
THANK YOU I'M I'M GLAD TO KNOW
THAT BECAUSE- THAT'S PLACE
WHERE OFTEN. OUR IT. ARE QUOTE
LES SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT AS
THE COOL MOVE ON. STATE VERY
GOOD VERIFICATION HUB RESOURCES.
SHE TO. AND WE HAVE THANK YOU
BACK ON MYSTERY A IMPENDING OUT
IN THE PROCESS OKAY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON NUMBERS I THE TOP
GLAD CHIEF DATA STRATEGIST AT
THE OF SO SERVICES IN DEPTH
DIRECTOR OVER THE RE OUT OF AND
THEY DIVISION. ASKING FOR NOW
POINT FIVE POSITIONS OF THE ON
WERE ON THE STATE WHERE YOUR
HOW THAT INCLUDES THE OF THREE
LIMITED TO POSITION. AND
REQUEST FOR SIX POINT FIVE
ADDITION CAUSES FOR OF ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION THE STOCK
WAS A THE ON GOING WAR ON BOTH
PROGRAM AND THE T.'S. TO ENSURE
THAT CONTINUE WORK ON STATE IN
AND ADDS IS DEVELOP AND CROSS
PLAN DOC. THAT CENTER YOU CAN
USE MOVE LEE AND IS MADE
PUBLICLY. I AS IT IS COMPLETE.
THIS WILL MEET OUR REQUIRE
FIRST M. S. AS WELL AS THAT OF
THIS WORK FOR CD. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
THINKER MUCH OIL. BRINAVESS L.
A. WE HAVE NO WERE THIS FOR.
THE FINANCE. I GINNY DR WITH
THE OF FINE WE HAVE NO DIGITAL
CAN AT THE TIME OUR EITHER ON
THIS ONE FOR YES NO PRECEDED I
AT THE HELP AND- IF IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE SOME VETERAN-
I'M TO OF HOW THIS IS A SITE
THAT WE'RE TO MAKE IT MORE FOR-
HOPE THIS A AIRPLANE SHOULD
MAKE THINGS EASIER
VERIFICATIONS WITH GREAT TO
HAVE SOME METRICS ON- THAT ARE
VERY. IS DONE MORE QUICKLY MORE
WHATEVER HOW THAT IT GOT OF
THIS HOUSE THANK. THANK VERY
MUCH. OKAY- THEN I FOR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO AGING. AND
THAT IS THE MISTER ROCAF.
THIRTY ONE PROCEED WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
WERE ASK TO READ ISSUE WHICH IN
AND OF- BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
WITHIN THE SENATE DEMOCRATS BUT
BUDGET PLAN. I'LL START WITH
THE FIRST BULLET ONE- PROVIDE A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS. FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD AFFORD
OPERATING SUBSIDIES TO ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY THAT SERVE
RESIDENTS RECEIVE STATE
SUPPLEMENTARY PROGRAM PAYMENTS.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL SUPPORT SB
SIX FOUR EIGHT AUTHORED BY
SENATOR HER TADO. THIS BULLET
IS TO. CURRENT I JUST AS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
MECHANISMS THE PROPOSAL WOULD
MAINTAIN TO FUNDING MECHANISMS
DISCUSSED BELOW IN THE AGENDA.
THAT WILL HELP TO MAKE PROGRESS
ON I JUST AS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THIS REFLECTS A
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY SEIU
CALIFORNIA U. D. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS URGE DURING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S MARCH SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING. MORE
DETAIL ON THIS PROPOSAL PLEASE
REFER TO THE MARCH SECOND
HEARING AGENDA THE LAST BULLET
IS FOR I FISCAL PENALTY FOR
RIGHTEOUSNESS COUNTIES. FAILING
TO BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. THIS
PROPOSAL THIS REFLECTS A
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY U. D.
W. ASKED ME THIRTY NINE THIRTY
AND S. CI YOU HEARD DURING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S MARCH SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING. MORE
DETAIL ON THIS PROPOSAL PLEASE
REFER TO THE MARCH SECOND
HEARING. AGENDA THANK YOU. FOR
THE YOU VERY MUCH- AND NOW THE
STATUS NO FOR THE RECORD IT
PEOPLE ARE WONDERING THAT THE
BILL THAT THIS IS INTO EFFECT
SUPPORT- WILL ALLOW H. AS WERE
TO GO INTO ADULTHOOD FACILITIES
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING. WITH
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT QUITE
ENOUGH RESOURCES IN THAT SYSTEM
SOUGHT I'VE JUST ALWAYS LIKE TO
GIVE MY VOICE TO WE NEED EVEN
MORE RESOURCES IN THIS AREA. TO
CARE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AND IN HOUSING AND SAFETY AS AS
PEOPLE AGE AND ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITH PERSISTENT. AND SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- OKAY.
WOULD YOU WANT TO MISS ANYTHING
WHEN THIS. NO BUDGET PLEASE
WE'RE CONSIDERING THESE YES
THESE ARE GREAT THINGS TO
CONSIDER RAISING BOTH BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE HELP IN
FACILITIES FOR PEOPLE- AND
MAKING SURE OUR WORKERS. ARE
TAKEN CARE OF IN THE PROCESS
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
IT'S A GREAT LONG HISTORY. OF
FINANCE DO YOU. NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME AND I'M CONFIRMING
OPINIONS OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE-
STAKEHOLDERS WITH US TODAY. AND
WE HAVE AND WE SEE A- PLEASE IT
COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE A
BUDGET ASSOCIATION JUSTIN
GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
BEVERLY USE STATE OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FROM U. D. W.
AND ASKS ME THREE NINETY
WELCOME. CAN YOU PLEASE EACH
BEEN ASKED TO ANSWER A QUESTION
RELATED TO THESE PROPOSALS SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU. SO I'M ASSUMING THAT I'M
JUST GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE PAZ'S OKAY
MY NAME IS LISA COLEMAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION. AND I
WAS ASKED TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL TO RESOURCE- THE SS I
SS P. FACILITIES. THAT PROVIDE
CARE TO RESIDENCY. OUR CITIES
AND I DON'T RISK ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE FACING
CRITICAL HOUSING SHORTAGES AND
IT'S NOT JUST HOUSING FOR THESE
VULNERABLE ADULTS IT'S HOUSING
WITH RESOURCE IT'S HOUSING WITH.
MANAGEMENT IT'S MORE THAN JUST
SHELTER AND FOOD THESE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED TO THEM
THROUGH A RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES AND ASK- AND OURS.
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A HIGHER
QUALITY OF LIFE THAN THEY WOULD
FIND LIVING INDEPENDENTLY-
LIVING WITH FAMILY FOR.
ULTIMATELY HAVING TO MOVE INTO
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OVER
UTILIZING OUR MEDIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND YET THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
RESIDENTS OF FOUR FACILITIES
THAT PROVIDE CARE TO RESIDENTS
IN THE SSI ASSISTED PROGRAMS IS
JUST OVER A THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
A DAY. IN COMPARISON THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE FOR AN
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY. IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY SO WE'RE ASKING
THESE FACILITIES TO PRIVATE
PROVIDE ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
SERVICES PER FRACTION OF THE
SUPPORT. AND SO IT'S NOT A
SURPRISE THAT THESE BUSINESSES
ARE GOING OUT OF BUSINESS IT'S
NOT A SURPRISE THAT OF THE
BUILDINGS THEMSELVES ARE
FALLING DOWN AROUND RESIDENTS
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST NO EXTRA
MONEY TO FIX THE ROOF. TO FIX A
WATER HEATER. SO THIS PROPOSAL
ALLOWS. A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE
OF DIGNITY FOR THESE VERY
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS. IT
WOULD AMOUNT TO A THIRTY TWO
DOLLAR A DAY INVESTMENT. WHICH
ALMOST DOUBLES THE DAILY RATE
AND ALLOWS THESE BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT ARE SO DEDICATED.
TO TWO FIVE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO KEEP THESE
BUILDINGS UP AND- NO THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN STATE THEY
ARE AMAZING ADVOCATES. AND THEY
DO INCREDIBLE ACTS OF SERVICE
ACTIVITIES FOR THESE RESIDENTS
BUT THEY'RE NOT MAGICIANS AND
THEY CANNOT FIND IT EMPTY BED
WHEN ONE OF THESE FACILITIES
THAT PROVIDES FOR THIS LOWEST
OF THE LOW INCOME WHEN THOSE
FACILITIES BECAUSE- THOMPSON'S
DESK. BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY
DON'T HAVE MAGIC WANDS SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THESE RESIDENTS MOVE
AWAY FROM THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS THEY HAVE. THEY BECOME
HOME. THEY BECOME. FREQUENT
FLYER AND ARM ROOM. THANK THIS.
I ENCOURAGE. THE LETTUCE TO
INCLUDE THIS IN THE BUDGET IS
THE TRUTH IS WE ARE GOING TO
PAY FOR THESE. INDIVIDUALS ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER AND THIS IS A
WAY TO PROVIDE SOMEONE CARE AND
DIGNITY. OUT MORE THAN JUST
SHELTER IT PROVIDES THEM WITH
THE WHOLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE I STILL THINK IT'S
QUITE ENOUGH BECAUSE IT'S USING-
IT'S ONE SOLUTION- ONE
INTERVENTION I THINK TO TAKE
CARE OF A- BIGGER ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP WORKING ON.
OKAY NEXT WE'RE GONNA HAVE THAT
JUSTIN WITH THE ADJUSTING GEAR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. HI
IT'S SAD YEAH. CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO THANK. I CHAIR EGGMAN
MEMBERS FOR APARTHEID IN THIS
PROPOSAL FOR INCLUSION ON THE
AGENDA. FEDERATION WITHIN THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN. THE FACT IS
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER COUNTY ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATION AND I THINK ABOUT
UNIONS ON THIS COALITION BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THAT WILL PROVIDE.
CONTINUITY FOR THE CURRENT ICE
OF COLLECTIVE. FUNDING BACK. AS
A DETAILED IN THE AGENDA OF THE
PROPOSAL ON THE MANY. AND LAW
THAT IF THAT TO TAKE BACK ON
JAN FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
BUT INSTEAD THAT TOOLS BE
MAINTAIN AT THE CURRENT DOCTOR.
BECAUSE THE HISTORIC RATIO WITH
ACCOUNT PAYS FIVE FOR. IN THE
STATE 65% OF THE NON SHARE. THE
LOCAL WAGE. THE TO THE STATE TO
STATE CAP. AS WELL AS THE- NOT
AT THE CAMPUS OVER THREE TO
THAT. THE COUNTY TO STATE
STATION BUT THE K. WITHIN A
DEFINED. IF THIS PROPOSAL TO.
IT WILL HELP ME THE- PROGRESS
WE HAD SEEN IN YEARS WHEN
YOU'RE IS BETWEEN. AND I
THOUGHT. INSTINCT WAGES
BENEFITS FOR I PROVIDED. SO.
TWENTY SEVEN. AND FORTY SIX
COUNTY. WHICH FOR MORE THAN 90%
I PROVIDER. IF PERMANENTLY IN.
WAGES AND INVEST HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS IN TOWN FUNDING FOR
WAITING FOR THOSE TWELVE REMAIN.
COUNTY WE ARE CURRENTLY TO GO.
SIX WAITING FOR THE UNIONS
CONTACT THE COUNTY RESPOND OUT
REACH. IN ONLY THREE HAVE GONE
CRACKED ON YOU KNOW MEDIA. THE
PHARMACY STARTING CHECK OF THIS
TOOL IN TWENTY THREE. AND COLOR
WITH THE LOW COUNTY- IN
NINETEEN. WITH TWENTY SIX
COUNTY NOW REACHING. THAT NEW
WILL BE WITH ACTIVELY IS CAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS WOULD
ALSO THEN IMPACT FUNDING FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN
REALIGNMENT PUTTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROGRAMS. AND THE REASON IT HAS
BEEN AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
ISIS AGREEMENT IS BECAUSE OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE ICE
THAT'S FUNNY MACINNES. AND THE
MORSE. COUNTY AND LEADER WITHIN.
TWENTY NINETEEN NOT THE THREAT
MANY SORT OF CUT THE BAR
PENALTY. WHICH IN TURN AND
SUPPORT FUTURE. TO COALITION BY
BELOW PROVIDE A POSITIVE FISCAL
AND- RATHER THAN ANY SORT OF.
PAIN APPROACH WHICH WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE REASON THAT MY
AT THE PRE. HEARING ON TOPICS.
THE OPTION OF I DO BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH A STAINLESS. AND
THEN I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MS
YOU FROM- TED TAPS ME. D. D. W.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
START REALLY WANT BEHALF UW I
WILL BE ADDRESSING HOW AN ACT
OF FISCAL COUNTY ON COUNTIES
WILL CREATE PROGRESS ON
REACHING COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
CONTRACTS. WE ARE SO 10% FISCAL
COUNTY ON COUNTY STUDENT
BARGAIN ISIS CONTRACTS IN GOOD
FAITH BE INCLUDE IN THE BUDGET
OR SPECIFY PROCESS EASTERN SURE
THE PENALTY WOULD ONLY TARGET
BAD ACTORS AND BE USED AS A
LAST RESORT. 1% ESTABLISH IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. FIRE IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR NOT US
ENOUGH TO THE WORST ACT. YOU
CAN EXPECT. COUNTY SAN
BARGAINED FAITH FOR YOU TO
CHANGE OVERNIGHT UNLESS A
STRONG TWILL AND- MORNING GOOD
FAITH IS NOT JUST. MORE AND DO
A- OR TO SOME FOR. THE OF
COUNTY ARE HONEST. LET ME
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE QUICKEST.
OF THE KIND WAS FIFTY ON THE
TO. AND THE UNION ASKING FOR
CENTS THAT IS. GOOD THE PARTIES
ARE JUST CLOSE AND- THAT BARRED
PUTTING IS ZERO PROPOSED ON
TABLE. REGRESA BURNING. AND
DRAGGING OUT. FOR YEARS.
ELECTRIFY KERN COUNTY HAS NOT
RE ACROSS FOR OVER THREE AND A
HALF YEARS. YOU COUNTY FOR SIX
A HALF YEAR. THE LAST COUNTY
AND S. C. H. FIFTEEN
JURISDICTION DESPITE. THE 1%
HOW ASSESSOR NEVER REACHED A
CALL. I JUST PROVIDERS ARE
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES BY LINE OLDER
ADULTS INDIVIDUALS DISABILITIES.
AVOID INSTITUTIONAL CARE GET
THE AND POVERTY WAGES. TRULY
DISGRACE THEY CONTINUE TO BE
DISRESPECTED AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE. BUT THE TURNOVER RATE
NEARLY 40% THESE RECALCITRANT
COUNTIES ARE DECIMATING OUR
CARE WORKFORCE ENDANGERING
THOUSANDS OF LIVES. WE BELIEVE
THEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE COUNTY'S
PROPOSAL TO PREVENT A SIXTY
FIVE THREE FIVE COST FLIP AND
TEMPERS I HAVE OVER THREE YEARS
AS THE SEARCH TOOLS TO HELP
BARGAINING. BUT SOME COUNTIES
HAVE SHOWN IS THAT ALONG WITH
CARROTS WE NEED TO STICK. SOME
HAVE THE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND I JUST
PROVIDERS WE REPRESENT. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DIFFERENT
FINANCE. OKAY THE WELL I THINK
THESE ARE ALL PLANS WE'RE
GETTING WORKERS AND WE'RE
MAKING SURE WORKERS ARE TAKING
CARE OF IN THE- WHICH WOULD
ATTRACT. A YOU- ACTUALLY AT THE
FOR MAKERS OF TO- TO JUST AND
FROM C. YEAH HAPPENED IN
QUESTIONS YEAH SO- SO CERTAINLY
HEARD YOUR TEST YUP- IN SUPPORT
OF COURSE OF FOR THE THAT
PERCENTAGE BUT THEN SAID THAT
THE SEX A PER TO. S. SO WE FROM
THEM FROM NIGHT YOU NEED AND OF
ALL HEARD FROM PEOPLE FROM. S.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO WHAT SHOULD
WE DO AS A STATE AND WHAT
SHOULD WE DO HAVE A COW DOESN'T-
GET A CUT WITH THEIR- I JUST US
WORKERS I MEAN WE HEARD FROM-
SEVERAL YEARS THAT THERE'S ONE
COUNTY THAT'S NEVER DONE IT
ANOTHER ONE SIX YEARS OUT. OF
THE ONCE THREE YEARS OUT AND I
KNOW IN YOU YOU'VE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO THEIR PROPOSAL DO
YOU HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND YOU
KNOW PLEASE ACTON COUNTY WE
ABSOLUTELY SHARED INTERESTS IN
ENSURING. OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AND WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE COUNTY HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND UNDERSTANDING TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I ONE THING I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IS YOU KNOW IN THE
THREE COUNTIES THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH MEDIATION OR FACT.
FINDING THEY ALL I WANT IN THE
PROCESS OFFERED A LEADING OF
EXAMPLE OF. EITHER COUNTY ARE
OFFERED ZERO AND DRAGGING GO
SHE OUT. YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
POINT IN THE PROCESS WHERE I
THESE CAN HAVE OFFERED INCREASE.
FOR AN AMOUNT WOULD COST MORE
THAN THE 1% PENALTY-
ALTERNATELY THAT WAS AGREED
WITH UNION AND THEY- TO GO SHE
DIDN'T GOT THE WHERE THEY WERE.
ANY SO YOU KNOW WE REALLY THINK-
POTS FISCAL. YEAH I CAN TO
POSSIBLE. SO YOU SO WHAT WAS
WHAT WE YOU DO WHAT SHOULD HAVE
IF THERE NO IF THEY CAN'T TO A.
YOU KNOW I THINK- YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO LOOK AT- BEING ABLE TO
CAN IT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO-
WELL KNOW AGAIN THE POWER
OFFERED NOW WAIT INCREASE THAT
MONTH WHAT I GUESS THE QUESTION
I FOR YOU IS THAT HAVE A WE
CERTAINLY HAVE PROPOSED THAT
YOU DON'T THAT. THAT SEE SAID
TO YOU BUT HE SAID IT DOESN'T
LIE BUT YET WE COUNTY SO DON'T
HAVE A SO. IS THERE. TO THAT
YOU DO YOU THINK. TO THAT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE THE KIND IT'S I
EVERY THAT SOME OF COUNTIES
MADE OFFER. BUT THERE'S NO
AGREEMENT. AND SOME OF. SOME OF
ITS AWHILE SO. DO YOU HAVE AN-
TEND TO WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
TO ADD GET THEM AGREE. YEAH
CERTAINLY I MEAN WE KNOW THE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. AN HAS COME.
ALL BOB FOR WAY TO LOOK
COLLECTED BY WHETHER IT'S THE
STATE- TAKING OVER COLLECTOR
BARGAINING INVEST MORE-
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE COUNTY TO.
CONTINUE TO GO. TO CAN YOU CAN
TO PUT- ADDITION OFFERS ON
TABLE I THEY'VE DONE I'M A IT'S
ALSO REALLY. TO LOOK. ALL COULD
BE FOR OF THE OTHER. WHO HAVE
DONE. EXACTLY AS LEGISLATURE.
HAS THAT OF THEM AND AGAIN
THESE KIND OF BEEN BARRED IN
BAD THEY JUST FAILED REACH AN
AGREEMENT FROM WHAT PUT OUT A-
OFFER. WELL I'M BY NATURE THAT
CONTINUE TO THE DATA INTO THE
PANEL BY TEMPLE FOR YOU KNOW
THE OTHER CAN THAT. TO DO.
RIGHT WOULD THINK IN THE PRO. I
WOULDN'T GET YOU KNOW REALLY-
KIND OF LEVERAGES THE LOCAL BAR
AWAY THAT THAT THE. SO SO
WHATEVER INCENTIVES WE HAVE IN
PLACE AN EFFECTIVE PENALTIES
ONLY APPLY IF THERE ISN'T. AN
AGREEMENT SO YOU KNOW I DAY AS
YOUR TO CONCERN ABOUT THE
PENALTY BUT IF THERE'S- IS ALL
THEY CAN COME TO AN AGREEMENT
WERE FINE. SO IN WITH THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO BE SO- I I'D
LIKE TO HEAR SOME MORE
SUGGESTIONS AS TO WHAT TO DO
FOR YEARS. AND IN SITUATIONS
WHERE. THERE IS NO AGREEMENT
AND- FOR A PROLONGED PERIOD OF
TIME. AND I THINK THE- I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT WAS THAT-
THAT SITUATION FORTUNATE EXIST
IN SOME COUNTIES BUT- AND- I
pOF THE PARTIES ARE FREE AT
EARLY SUGGESTING SOME SOLUTIONS
TO TRY TO. TO PUSH TO TORONTO
TO GET TO AN AGREEMENT- BUT I
THINK IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
US- ULTIMATELY I THINK WE ARE
ALL BETTER OFF IF THERE
ACTUALLY IS AN AGREEMENT SO.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE COUNTIES
NOT IN AGREEMENT IS PROBLEMATIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY YES MISTER GARRETT SOUNDS
LIKE. DOCTOR PASSED YOU FOR
SOME MORE SOLUTIONS AND- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CONTINUE LIKE ON
LIKE IT'S GOING BUT THERE SEEMS
TO BE A PROBLEM WITH THE
CURRENT SYSTEM SO. THAT WE WILL
MOVE ON FOR NOW- AND- GO TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOR. FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT. LEVEL
RESOURCES. YOU BACK WITH US
MCGEORGE. THANK YOU. AND IF YOU
POOREST FAMILY FIRST A LITTLE
RESTORED FIFTY DFS IS
REQUESTING THREE POINT TWO
MILLION TWO POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND THEN TWO
POINT SIX MILLION ONE POINT
NINE GENERAL FUND DANIEL EITHER
AFTER BIRTH SEVEN PERMANENT
POSITIONS CONTRACT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT OUR COMPLIANCE AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION APARTMENT THE
BASKET YEAH AND CIVICALLY I'M
IMPLEMENTING THE PREVENTION
SERVICES PROGRAM AUTHORIZED BY
PART ONE OF THAT ACT. THE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT COMPLIANCE WITH ALL THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT THE FIFTH
SEEDED WITH THE FAMILY FIRST
ACT ALLOWED TO DEVELOP TRAINING
CURRICULUM PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT QUALITY ASSURANCE
MEASURES SUCH AS THE FRAMEWORK
TO ENSURE MODEL FIDELITY FOR
THE ACCIDENT EIGHT THE BETTER
IMPLEMENTED AS WELL TO CONTINUE
A QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EVALUATIONS. THAT ARE REQUIRED
BY THE FEDERAL LAW. THERE WAS
ADEQUATE IN THE HOW WILL THE
STATE. WELL OUT PLAN IF I
COUNTY THAT PREVIEW HAD. FUTURE
FOR YOU PREVENT SERVICES AND
WILL THEY BE TO MAKE A LOT OF
URBAN JERRY. THAT THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE PAST. THE
PREVENTION OF THE RECRUITMENT
BAILABLE. TO AT THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION PURPOSES DR
AREN'T LIMITED AS COMPARED TO
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT COUNTY
PROUD AND THEREFORE YOU LABOR
DEMONSTRATION. FAMILY FIRST
ONLY ALLOWED FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR PREVENTION SERVICES IN
THREE CATEGORIES. REDUCE
TREATMENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND IN HOME PARENTING
SKILLS BASED PROGRAM. ANY
FURTHER AND ANY SERVICE OFFERED
WITHIN ONE OF THOSE THREE
CATEGORIES HAVE TO BE APPROVED
AND BE INCLUDED WITHIN THE
FEDERAL TITLE FOR YOU CLEARING
HOUSE. BUT BEING ESTABLISH AND
MEETING AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE THAT HAS TO BE
EVALUATED. ARE WELL SUPPORTED
DEPORTED OR PROMISING PRACTICE.
AND FINALLY THE SERVICES-
FUNDED THROUGH FAMILY FIRST ARE
ONLY ALLOWED TO BE PROVIDED TO
A CHILD ONCE THEY'VE BEEN
DETERMINED TO BE A CANDIDATE
FOR FOSTER CARE- ENOUGH TO FIND
IN THE FEDERAL LAW AND CHILDREN
AT IMMINENT. RISK OF ENTERING
FOSTER CARE. SO ALL OF THEM.
REQUIREMENTS ARE FROM TO THAN
WHAT AVAILABLE TO YOU CHINESE
ARE OPERATE THE WAY TWENTY
MINUTES RICK. EXISTED
LIMITATION. THAT MEANS THAT WE
ARE ABLE OFFER FAR FEWER-
BECAUSE THEY ARE PART FEWER
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE AND THE
PREVENTION CARE WITH THIS
CLEARING HOUSE AT THE MOMENT I
THINK THERE'S TWENTY FIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE PREVENTION
SERVICES CLEARING HOUSE TEN OF
THEM ARE RATED AT FAULT THE
PART AT THE MOMENT. IT IS WORTH
NOTING THAT WE DID RECEIVE SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE
FAMILY FIRST TRANSITION BACK TO
HELP WITH THE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM THE WAVERED. THE FAMILY
FIRST TRANSITION ACT INCLUDED
ONE TIME BOND WHICH WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF DISTRIBUTING TO ALL
THE COUNTY TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES.
RELATED TO FAMILY FIRST. AND IT
ALSO PROVIDED CERTAINTY GRANTS
WHICH ARE PROVIDED TO OUR
WAIVER COUNTY AND INTENDED TO
MITIGATE THAT SHORTFALL
EXPERIENCED AS A RESULT OF THE
WAY FOR A LOT. FOR FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT REGARD
TO THE SECOND QUESTION HOW
WE'RE APPROACHING THE ROLE OF
THE FAMILY FIRST- THAT
PREVENTION PLAN OF CURRENTLY
OUT FOR STAKEHOLDER REVIEW
PROPOSES THAT EIGHT THEN
APPROACH. IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE PROPOSE
STARTING WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF
WELL SUPPORTED EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES. I WAS JUST
MENTIONING THE NUMBER NUMEROUS
REQUIREMENTS AS STATED WITH THE
FEDERAL LAW FOR IMPLEMENTING
FAMILY FOR. AND STARTING WITH A
FEW PROGRAMS THAT ARE WELL
SUPPORTED IN THE FIRST YEAR
WILL ALLOW IT TO. THE PROPERTY
WHAT'S COUNTY TO ESTABLISH THE
DATA COLLECTION THAT'S
REQUIRED. THE PER CHILD FISCAL
REPORTING THAT TRACKING AND
OVERSIGHT ENSURING MODEL
FACILITY TO EVERY EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAM THAT WE
IMPLEMENT. AUTOMATION THAT WILL
BE REQUIRED TO FALL TO CONTINUE
A QUALITY IMPROVEMENT.
PROPERTIES READING STARTING
WITH A SMALL NUMBER PROGRAMS
WILL ALLOW US TO HAVE ALSO
ALLOWED TO HAVE ANY TIME TO
DEVELOP READY NOT FOR OPTING
AND I'M A FAST THERE AT LEVEL
OF PREVENTION NEEDS. ESTABLISH
CONTRACTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
ENTRY APPROPRIATE STAFF THAT
WANT THESE PROPERTIES ARE ALL
STOP LIST. WE'RE HOPING WE CAN
RAPIDLY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS. THE
STATE AND THAT A YEAR. MEETING
INTERNATIONAL CLASS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SHORT. THANK YOU
ANALYSTS ARE WITH ALL ITS
ANALYST- WE JUST WANTED TO SAY
WE DON'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
CONCERNS- WITH THE REQUEST FOR
STAFFING RESOURCES- BUT WE DID
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO FLAG THAT WE DO
YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
BROADER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
STATE'S OVERALL PLAN FOR
PREVENTION SERVICES- INCLUDING
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE RAISED
IN RESPONSE THE GOVERNOR'S
GENERAL BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS THE- FIRST DRAFT OF TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR ACCESS PSA
IMPLEMENTATION- AND IN
PARTICULAR A KEY QUESTION WE
HAVE. IS WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE GENERAL FUND RESOURCES
TO COUNTIES- FOR PREVENTION
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT
ELIGIBLE YOUTH AND FAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE
ACCESS TO PREVENTION SERVICES-
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT G.
SENATE- SENATE DEMOCRATS
INCLUDED AS PART OF THEIR-
BUDGET PRIORITIES PLAN WHICH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT- IN A IN A
LATER AGENDA ITEM- AND SO
ULTIMATELY DEPENDING ON THE
SCOPE OF STATE LEVEL FUNDING
FOR PREVENTION SERVICES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO
PROVIDE- THAT MAY IMPACT THE
LEVEL OF CENTRAL RESOURCES
pSERVICES- SO. WE AGREE WITH A
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN- TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE ITS
OVERALL APPROACH TO PREVENTION
SERVICES AND ACCESS PSA PART
ONE IMPLEMENTATION- BEFORE
APPROVING THOSE STAFFING
RESOURCES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS PART
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
OKAY YEAH- MISH WORST YOU HAVE
DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THE
SHORTS. THAT WE JUST NEED MORE
WE NEED MORE GENERAL FUNDING
FOR THAT. THE TO BE ABLE TO
TRULY MEET THE NEEDS. OF EVERY
KID. AND FAMILY WE DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME AND I
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY
THANK YOU YEAH I JUST I MEAN I
WOULD NOTED MY OWN TO COUNTIES-
THAT CHILD WELFARE SERVICES-
AND CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AN
INCIDENT MANY OF MY- FORMER
STUDENTS AND COLLEAGUES ARE
FRONTLINE. CAL WILL FOR WORKERS
I JUST KNOW THAT THE STRUGGLE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES-
CASELOADS ARE STILL WAIT I
MEAN. IT'S HARD TO DO
PREVENTION WHEN YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO PUT OUT FIRES
CONSTANTLY ALL DAY LONG
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
PANDEMIC TIME SO- AND I AND I
GUESS I WOULD ASK THE-
MAJORITY. WITH TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW PLAN I MEAN
HOW MANY KIDS THEN DO WE DO WE
LEAVE BEHIND A FOR YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT WE
GET THOSE THAT WE CAN. ADD THAT
FALL WITHIN THESE CATEGORIES
FOR TITLE FOR YOU BUT WHAT HOW
ABOUT THE ALL THE REST OF THEM
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR. ADJUSTED
TO THE GENERAL POPULATION THAT
MAY NOT QUALIFY FOR FAMILY FOR
SERVICES. I DON'T. REMEMBER IF
I MEAN I KNOW THAT THIS WAS
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE. M. AS PART
OF THE FEDERAL LONG WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO FULLY
OPERATIONALIZED. FAMILY FIRST-
RECOGNIZING THAT. APPROACH THAT
ALLOWS US TO REALLY BUILD A
STRONG FOUNDATION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO NEED IN ORDER TO DO.
I'M REALLY COMPLY WITH ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS OF
FEDERAL LAW. OKAY YEAH AND I
KNOW I MEAN I KNOW WE ALL WE
ALL KEEP IN IN THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR MINDS THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
TRYING TO COMPLY WITH. FEDERAL
LAWS BUT TO KEEP KIDS AND
FAMILY SAFE. THE DEFENSE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN I
THINK WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT IN A BUDGET ITEM
STRENGTHENING THE SAFETY NET
CHILD WELFARE FOSTER CARE. IT.
THANK YOU MISS SHORT ARGENIS
ONE FOR US OKAY YES OKAY THANK
YOU- YES OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
ASKED TO PRESENT COMPONENTS OF
THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN- AND FOR
CHILD WELFARE I WILL READ SEE
ASK FOR PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN
YOUR AGENDA. THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATE DO NOT RELATED TO CHILD
WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS.
ONE PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PLACEMENTS FOR HIGH NEEDS YOUTH
ACROSS THE STATE. TO PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR COUNTY
ADMINISTERED CHILD WELFARE
PREVENTION SERVICES THIS
REFLECTS A PROPOSAL PUT FORTH
BY THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND HER DURING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING. THREE FUNDS A PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE A UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD FUND
S. B. AT SEVEN THIRTY NINE
AUTHORED BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE-
AND FINALLY APPROVED FUNDS TO
PROVIDE COVERT RELIEF FOR SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS. THIS REFLECTS A
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND HEARD
DURING THE COMMITTEE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEES FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER PANEL ON
FOR THIS- AND WE HAVE REQUESTED
JENNIFER RODRIGUEZ EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF YOUTH LAWCENTER-
CHICLET DISCUSSED SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS THE STATE CAN MAKE
AND THEN WE HAVE- VERONICA. THE
AREA FOR FOSTER FORMER SHE'S A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND SHE CAN
HELP ME WITH THE PLANTATION
NUMBER LAST NAME. THAT
AFTERNOON. THE PAST YEAR HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING FOR
ALL BUT FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. IT'S
BEEN DEVASTATING THE PAST YEAR
HAS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED FOR THE
PUBLIC AND FOR POLICYMAKERS HOW
CHILD WELFARE IS PARTICULARLY
FAILING TO CARE FOR THOSE WHO
WE HAVE THE GREATEST
RESPONSIBILITY TO CARE FOR
PROTECT AND SUPPORT. THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS FAILURE
FALL DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
BLACK AND INDIGENOUS CHILDREN
WITH LIFE ALTERING IMPACTS. OUR
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HAS STRAINED
TO CARE FOR CHILDREN REMOVED
FROM THEIR FAMILIES FOR DECADES
SINCE THE TIME I GREW UP IN
FOSTER CARE. YOUTH AND FAMILIES
HAVE GUIDED US TO NEEDED
REFORMS WE NEED THE KIND OF
PREVENTION SERVICES TO ENSURE
WE CAN DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE.
TO AVOID SEPARATING CHILDREN
FROM FAMILIES THAT ARE ABLE AND
WILLING TO CARE FOR THEM
INCLUDING PROVIDING BASIC NEEDS
SUCH AS HOUSING CHILD CARE
MENTAL HEALTH. SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FOR BOTH FAMILIES AND
TEENAGERS SUPPORTS FOR
EXPECTANT AND PARENTING
PASTILLAS. AND INTERVENTIONS TO
PREVENT YOU FROM JUVENILE
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT. FAMILIES
FIRST FUNDING IS A START BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE INVESTMENTS
THAT FAMILIES TELL US THEY
NED. WE CAN BUY IT WE SHOULD
DO IT WE SHOULD NEVER SEPARATE
A CHILD FROM THEIR FAMILY
UNLESS THERE IS NO OTHER OPTION
FOR SAFETY. AND WHEN WE DO
REMOVE CALIFORNIA HAS TO
GUARANTEE THE MOST BASIC AND
CRITICAL RIGHT THAT THEY'LL
RECEIVE EXCELLENT QUALITY.
PARENTING AND AN ALTERNATE
FAMILY. WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO TO GET TO THE SCHOOL.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE NATIONAL
NEWS MEDIA HAS GIVEN EXTENSIVE
IN DEPTH COVERAGE TO
CALIFORNIA'S PRACTICE OF
PLACING YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE.
AN OUT OF STATE FACILITIES THAT
NOT ONLY DID NOT MEET
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS. BUT
ALSO SUBJECTED YOUNG PEOPLE TO.
UNTHINKABLE ABUSE AND NEGLECT
OF PORTABLE CONDITIONS- AND-
THOSE INCLUDED WITNESSING STAFF
MURDER YOUTH WITH EXTENDED
RESTRAINTS AT. LAKESIDE ACADEMY
IN MICHIGAN. AND ALSO STAFF
BEING CHARGED WITH SEXUAL
ASSAULTS FOR RAPING A RESIDENT
OF CLARINDA ACADEMY IN IOWA.
ALONG WITH DOZENS OF ADDITIONAL
VIOLATIONS OF STATE LAW AND
REGULATIONS OVER JUST THE PAST
FEW YEARS. THOSE FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN CHARACTERIZED BY
NATIONAL NEWS SOURCES AS
PROFITABLE DEATH TRAPS. THAT
COLLECT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
GOVERNMENT DOLLARS WHILE
ABUSING AND NEGLECTING CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. AND AS IS TRUE
FOR MOST BAD PRACTICE IN FOSTER
CARE BLACKEYED HAVE BEEN
DESPERATELY IMPACTED. IN A ONE
ONE STOP SHOP OF PLACEMENTS
FROM JULY. BLACK CHILDREN
REPRESENTED ABOUT 33% OF THOSE
SENT OUT OF STATE DESPITE
MAKING UP ONLY 20% OF LAST YEAR
AND ROUGHLY 5% OF ALL CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA. THIS ISN'T A NEW
PROBLEM. FOR DECADES
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH ABOUT A
STATE FACILITIES HAS RESULTED
IN CHILDREN BEING HARMED BY
ABUSIVE PRACTICES BY PARK
CONDITIONS AND BY AN ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. IN DECEMBER
CALIFORNIA DECERTIFIED THE OUT
OF STATE FACILITIES COUNTIES
REPLACING CHILDREN AND FOR
FAILURE TO MEET OUR VERY BASIC
STANDARDS. BUT THIS ISN'T A
PERMANENT SOLUTION. TO BE CLEAR
CALIFORNIA'S DECERTIFICATION OF
THESE FACILITIES DOES NOTHING
TO PREVENT CALIFORNIA FROM
APPROVING THE SAME OR NEW OUT
OF STATE FACILITIES. TO TAKE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN TODAY. WE
NEED POLICY ACTION TO PLACE A
PERMANENT MORATORIUM AND
PLACEMENT ON OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. AND WE HAVE TO
EXPAND AND STRENGTHEN THE
RESOURCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NEW STATE INVESTMENTS COULD
FIND EXPERT REVIEWS OF EACH OF
THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
INDIVIDUAL CASES OF YOU THOUGHT
REQUEST OUT OF STATE. HI.
JENNIFER I WHAT THEY NEEDED
THAT WASN'T A BILL LOCAL AND
STATE AND WHY IT WAS NOT AND
AVAIL AND HOW TO. USE THAT AND
CAL. I'M GOING STATE INTENSIVE
TA WITH EXPERTS TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES ON SPECIFIC CASES. AND
TO ASSIST THEM IN ACCESSING THE
EXISTING ENTITLEMENTS THAT FIND
MANY OF THE INTERVENTIONS THAT
ARE NEEDED FOR YET. CDSS SEED
FUNDING FOR PILOTS TO ADDRESS
PARTICULAR GAPS IN POPULATIONS.
YOU CAN FAMILY PEER SUPPORT AND
MENTORING ADDITIONAL STATE%
FUNDING FOR SUPPORTIVE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR
MINORS. AND DEEPENING THE
STATE'S QUALITY CONTROL
RESPONSE IN ORDER TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY. MOST
IMPORTANTLY AND TALKING WITH
YOU FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION WHO EXPERIENCE NOT
BEING SERVED WELL BY FOSTER
CARE. IDENTIFIED WHEN
INVESTMENT AS THE MOST
POTENTIALLY POWERFUL.
DESIGNATING STATE FUNDING TO
PAY FOR ANYTHING NEEDED BY YES
UNFUNDED OR UNAVAILABLE WHO
HAVE SPECIALIZED NEEDS SUCH AS
PARTICIPATION IN ORGANIZED
SPORTS TRADE APPRENTICESHIPS
ARE TO ME THAT COUNTS DURING
SCHOOL BREAKS. COMMUNITY BASED
MENTORING COST TO ALLOW
REUNIFICATION WITH FAMILIES.
THAT IS HOUSING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT COVERED
BY MEDICARE ALL. PARENT
TRAINING BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS RESPITE CARE
AND. OCCASIONAL JOB IN
TRANSITION CLASS. WE WERE LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY THAT ARE
EXTENDED FOR NEW SERVICES OR
NEW PILOTS DO YOU INCLUDE ANY
EVALUATION OF OUTCOMES FOR THE
CHILD TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN INTERVENTIONS THAT
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
SPECIFIC POPULATION. WHAT THE
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
IT IS WELL PAST TIME THAT WE
ACT ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISS VERONICA.
YES. WELCOME TO HELP ME WITH
YOUR LAST NAME HOW DO I SET
YEAH YEAH I KNOW IT'S A V.
EIGHT AT THE ADA OKAY ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT OFF ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND WELCOME. THANKS OKAY NO
YOU'RE GONNA TALK TO US ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF HAVING A BASIC
INCOME EXITING FROM THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOING A U. B. I.
OR UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME FOR
KIDS TRANSITIONING OUT KENTUCKY
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THE IMPACT
OF THAT. YES CRYSTAL I MENTION
THIS MYSELF MY NAME IS VERONICA
AND I'M OPPOSED TO USE AND TEND
TO BE GRADUATED FROM SOUNDS OF
STATE WITH A BACHELORS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH- I AM
PARTICIPATING AND THEN
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME PILOT
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S A LONG NAME
BUT DO FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
THANK- WHAT ABOUT A MONTH NOW.
AS A PARTICIPANT I RECEIVED AN
UNCONDITIONAL. PAYMENT OF ONE
THOUSAND PER MONTH. HAPPENED A
MINK. THEIR BY THE ENDING MY
RECENT PAY INTERNSHIP MIND.
WHAT'S AND THEY'LL EVERITT
EARLIER THAN USUAL- AND AGES IT
WAS A STRUGGLE FOR ME HAS TO
FIND A JOB THAT COULD
ACCUMULATE WITH MY SCHOOL- AND
JUST TIME TO VISIT ALSO MY
YOUNGER SIS. IS THEM WHICH WAS.
EXACTLY A MONTH AFTER THAT
PANDEMIC. I'M ONLY INCOME HAS
BEEN A GREAT HELP TO PAY FOR MY
IMPORTANT BILLS LIKE RENT CAR
PHONE INSURANCE. AND HE HAS
KEPT ME ON MY FEET WILL BE IN A
FULL TIME STUDENT. THE INCOME-
THE INCOME THAT'S ME PAY MY
BILLS FOR AT LEAST ONE MONTH
AHEAD. IT'S AN AND THEY HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY LEFT OVER FOR FOOD
AND HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF INCOME
LEFT FOR SAVINGS WHICH THANKS
TO THE SAVINGS I WAS ABLE TO
AFFORD A NEW LAPTOP FOR SCHOOL
WHEN MY LAST ONE STOP WORKING.
IF THIS BENEFIT WHAT TO STOP
TOMORROW IT WILL MAKE SUCH A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON MY LIFE. AS
A MOMENT I'M NOT WORKING DUE TO
COPING MOST JOBS ARE ONLY
HIRING FULL TIME AND NOT PART
TIME. IF THEY WANT FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAM APPERLEY WE
STRUGGLING TO HAVE A MEAL EVERY
DAY I PROBABLY BE HOMELESS ALL
HAVE DROP OFF FROM SCHOOL ON MY
LAST SEMESTER. I BELIEVE THIS
IS MORE IMPORTANT. I BELIEVE
IT'S MORE THAN BORN TO INVEST
IN FOR THREE YEARS BECAUSE LIKE
MYSELF. TO SOME THE PILOT
PROGRAM IS LIKE A HERO READY TO
SEE FAR LACKS WHEN WE HAD JUST
EXITED THE SYSTEM WITH NO CLUE
ON WHAT TO DO NEXT. MANY USERS
LIKE MYSELF EXIT THE SYSTEM
WOULD ONLY A FULL DAY FOR ALL
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION OPEN
AND WE KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
AND BE INDEPENDENT WITHOUT ANY
RESOURCES. MANY USERS ARE
LOOKING TO BE ADOPTED THE NEXT
STEPS ARE BECOMING FULLY
INDEPENDENT. AND THAT IS WHY I
BELIEVE THE UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME FOR TRANSITION AGE
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. ACT IS
WHAT BEEN INVESTED ON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
UPCOMING GRADUATION HIS SITES
VERY PROUD OF YOU. HOPE TO SEE
IF MAYBE YOU KNOW. IN THE HALLS
OF THE CAPITOL- YEAH I. AND I
WOULD JUST IMAGINE AND I WOULD
ASK YOU I MEAN JUST I NOTICE
STRESSFUL BEING A STUDENT I
NOTICED STRESSFUL JUST BEING A
YOUNG PERSON DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND I WONDER WHAT IT
BEEN LIKE FOR YOU F YOU TO
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. YOUR NEXT
MEAL OR A PLACE TO LIVE WORK
MONEY FOR TRANSPORTATION. THE
AMOUNT OF STRESS I MEAN CAN YOU
EVEN BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT THE-
THE BLAST STRESS YOU HAD
BECAUSE YOU'VE HAD THAT
INCREASING YOUR- THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. WHERE YOUR
NEXT PAYCHECK WAS COMING FROM.
YES OF COURSE IS SUCH BIG HELP.
SINCE I FEEL LIKE I HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN FOCUSING ON SCHOOL FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME AND I'M JUST
ON MY LAST SEMESTER. I FEEL
LIKE IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
PROGRAM WITH A JUST DROP
EXACTLY ON THE LAST ONE AND BE
LIKE WELL I GOT TO WORK I'M
GOING TO MAKE SOME MONEY LIKE
ANY. BILLS TO PAY AND THAT
NEEDS SOME FOOD TO EAT. AND I
FEEL LIKE THIS IS JUST A GREAT
HELP AND I REALLY SURE I'M NOT
THE ONLY ONE THE OTHER PEOPLE.
THE OTHER PUTS USER GETTING AS
WELL SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S SUCH A
BIG INVESTMENT. AND I FEEL LIKE
IT'S TOTALLY WORTH IT. I THINK
ANY TIME WE CAN INVEST IN SOME
FANTASTIC AND PEOPLE LIKE YOU.
IT IS WELL WORTH STATE MONEY.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND CONGRATULATIONS.
I HAPPEN TO LIVE IN THE FUTURE.
YEAH I HAVE TO LIVE IN THE CITY
OF STOCKTON AND WE DID A- A U.
B. I. PILOT AS WELL. WE JUST
GOT THE RESULTS AFTER A YEAR
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY FOUND IT
JUST DECREASES PEOPLE STRESS.
IT ALLOWS PEOPLE EVEN TO GET.
BETTER JOBS MORE JOBS SOMETIMES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THE FIRST ONE
THAT'S OFFERED TO THEM. AND
THEY HAVE MORE TIME TO. TO
REFLECT SO. WE'RE EXCITED FOR
YOU. GOING FORWARD AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS. THIS BUDGET
ITEMS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY AND I
THINK WE'RE HOLDING THAT OPEN
AND MOVING ON. OKAY THE NEXT US
IN A BUDGET OPTION
STRENGTHENING THE SAFETY NET
THIS OUR FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. DID YOU MISTER
ANDERSON YOU GONNA READ FOR US.
BUT YOUR MUTUAL SIR. THERE WE
GO THERE WE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON
RYAN ANDERSON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU'VE BEEN ASKED TO READ- THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS FROM THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUSES
BUDGET PROPOSAL. OF FIRST JUST
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR FOOD BANKS TO MEET
INCREASED NEEDS DUE TO THE
CONTINUED IMPACTS OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS
REFLECTS PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PUT FORTH. BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
HEARD DURING THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
FEBRUARY NINTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. THE SECOND IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. OR C.
FAB TO SERVICE CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THIS PROPOSAL SUPPORTS
SB FOUR SIXTY FOUR FROM SENATOR
PER TACO AND WAS HEARD DURING
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S FEBRUARY
NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
MISTER JERRY CALL HERE OUR
SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR NOURISH
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
TOPIC. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO RECALL
SENIOR ADVOCATE NURSE
CALIFORNIA. I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR PUTTING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THE AARMING RATES
OF FOOD INSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO WANT TO DO A LEVEL
SAID AND EMPHASIZED THAT BEFORE
THE CALL THE CRISIS WE HAVE
REALLY HIGH RATES OF HUNGER AND
POVERTY WE HAVE THE HIGHEST.
CHILD POVERTY RATE IN THE
NATION SO THESE ARE OUR
LONGSTANDING PROBLEMS THAT ONLY
WORSENED OVER THE PAST YEAR.
LAST FALL OUR ORGANIZATION
PARTNERED WITH RESEARCH FIRM TO
CONDUCT A STATEWIDE STUDY TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCES OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DURING. DURING THECALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY WE'VE GOT A
SURVEY OF A THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AS WELL AS SIX
FOCUS GROUPS. WITH HOUSEHOLDS
ACROSS THE STATE ALL EARNING
LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. AND THOSE
FINDINGS SHOW CLEARLY IN AND
VERSION NEED TO PROVIDE RELIEF
TO HOUSEHOLDS WHO COULDN'T MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS ESPECIALLY
FOOD. I'LL SHARE SOME OF THOSE
TOP LINE FINDINGS TODAY BUT I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
FULL REPORT AND OTHER RESOURCES
IF THE COMMITTEES INTERESTED IN
IN TAKING IN MORE DETAIL. THE
MORE THAN THREE IN FIVE. SURVEY
RESPONDENTS WORRIED ABOUT
RUNNING OUT OF FOOD IN THE
PRIOR TWELVE MONTHS. AND MORE
THAN HALF. OF ALL SURVEY
RESPONDENTS HAD RUN OUT OF FOOD
WITHOUT MONEY TO GET MORE. HALF
OVERALL 80% EXPRESSED SOME
LEVEL OF NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
MONEY TO BUY FOOD. BLACK AND
LYFT NEXT CALIFORNIANS WERE
MORE LIKELY TO RUN OUT OF FOOD
AND OTHER RESPONDENTS IN
PARENTS WERE MORE LIKELY TO RUN
REPORT RUNNING OUT OF FOOD AND
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN.
FEDERAL AND STATE RELIEF
EFFORTS WERE LARGELY SEEN AS
HELPFUL BUT NOT SUFFICIENT.
DURING THE. PANDEMIC CALFRESH
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL BENEFITS OF.
HIRELING OF CALFRESH AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE ENTIRELY NOT THAT'S
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. TODAY
THE CALIFORNIA BHAJAN POLICY
CENTER RELEASED AN ANALYSIS
SHOWING THAT AMONG CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN IN FAMILIES WHERE ALL
MEMBERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED OVER
HALF LIVED IN POVERTY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AN ESTIMATED ONE
THREE UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS AS
A PARENT AND 90% LIVE WITH U.
S. BORN CITIZEN CHILDREN A
CURRENT CALFRESH POLICY TREATS
THOSE PARENTS AS INVISIBLE. A
POLICY DENIES THESE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THE POSITIVE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
CALFRESH IT'S A POLICY THAT
DEEPENS DISPARITIES BASED ON
SINA PHOBIA AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. A WIDE BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IN ADDITION
TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCING HUNGER
ACCESS TO CALFRESH IMPROVES
OVERALL HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. IT ALSO
REDUCES HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
IMPROVE ECONOMIC OUTPUT OVER
PARTICIPANTS LIFETIME. SO WE
WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS
FOOD FOR ALL PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD EXPAND ELIGIBILITY IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
BEYOND A VERY NARROW SET OF
QUALIFIED IMMIGRANTS IT'S
SERVICE NOW. TO ALL CALIFORNIA
HOW CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA SO WE
DO COULD HAVE IMMIGRATION
STATUS MAKING THAT CHANGE WOULD
PERMANENTLY ADDRESS THE
IMMIGRANT EXCLUSION IN THE
STATE'S NUTRITION SAFETY NET
CAN BE A MAJOR STEP FORWARD.
TOWARD A FUTURE WHERE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE FOOD THEY
NEED- ADDED OF COURSE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FOOD BANK
SPENDING REQUEST AS WELL AS
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS CENTER
STILL FACE THEY SEEM VERY.
ELEVATED DEMANDS- THANKS IN AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE EVERYTHING IN. JUST
RAISED BERMAN FINANCE NOTICED
ALL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU YEAH- CAMINO THIS
FOOD IS OF PARTICULAR INTEREST
OF FOR ME. ON THAT YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
ON HOUSING FOR ALL. BUT FOR
GOODNESS SAKES WE CAN CERTAINLY
START WITH FOOD FOR ALL. OF
THAT SEEMS LIKE A BASIC THING
THAT WE CAN DO IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE GROW MORE
THAN ANY PLACE ELSE- AND THEN
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THE- THE
PANDEMIC HAS HIT OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE EVE EVEN THE HARDEST
INCLUDING THOSE WHO MAY BE HERE
WITHOUT DOCUMENTATION BUT THEY
LIVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THEY
WORK IN OUR FIELDS THEY WORK IN
OUR FACTORIES AND RESTAURANTS.
AND GO AND GET AND THEIR KIDS
GO TO SCHOOL WITH OUR KIDS SO.
UP NOTHING STOPS AT ANYBODY'S
BORDER AND HAS A- AS YOU SAID
MR CALL. EVERY EVERY STUDY
SHOWS THAT NUTRITION HAS WAY
MORE IMPACTS THAN JUST FILLING
UP A BELLY IT HELPS THE MIND IT
HELPS. PEOPLE FEEL MORE SECURE.
IT HELPS ACADEMIC OUTCOMES AND
IT CERTAINLY HELPS OUTCOMES
BOTH RIGHT AWAY AND LATER IN
LIFE THAT THE SYSTEM WOULD END
UP PAYING FOR ANYWAY. WE KNOW
THAT PARENTS CAN FEED THEIR
CHILDREN THEY FELT LESS STRESS
AND OF PARENTS FOR LESS STRESS.
THEIR CHILDREN DEVELOPING GROW
BETTER SO. WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS I'M PARTICULARLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS AND I'LL ASK
DR PANE IF HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS TOPIC. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOOD IS
GOOD. A RIGHT. WHO DOES GOOD. A
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO THE
NEXT SENATE BUDGET OPTIONS
STRENGTHENING THE SAFETY NET
CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
FIVE RYAN ANDERSON HELLO AGAIN-
WE ARE AGAIN PRESENTING-
SEVERAL BUDGET OPTIONS FROM THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THE
FIRST INVOLVES CAL WORKS IN MY
ITEMS TO INCREASE COWARDS
GRANTS TO TAKE THE FINAL STEP
IN A LONG TIME SENATE PRIORITY
OF NO CHILD IN DEEP POVERTY
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE
CAL WORDS GRANTS 250% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL FOR A
FAMILY THAT IS ONE PERSON
LARGER THE ASSISTANCE UNIT.
SIZE NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A ONE POINT 5%
INCREASE TO CAL ARTS GRANTS THE
PROPOSAL THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING. AS WELL WHAT IS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE SECOND ITEM
INVOLVES THE SS I SS P.
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD RESTORE THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT OR
COLA AND PASSED CUTS TO THE S.
S. P. PROGRAM. THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I DON'T AND I
JUST THINK THIS IS A PRETTY
PRETTY COMMON SENSE AND DON'T
HAVE ANY PARTICULAR COMMENTS ON
THIS DOCTOR PAN YOU HAVE. I
JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE- OUR OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE- CENTER NOW-
AWAY SUPERVISOR HOLLY MITCHELL
FOR HER. CAMPAIGN IS AND I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HALF OF THE PART
NUMBER. AND IT AND JUST TRYING
TO GET THERE WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT POPULAR TALK ABOUT PASS
SO I HOPE WE CAN CERTAINLY AT
LEAST HIT THAT VERY LOW BAR-
AND I KNOW HOW HARD- CENTER
MITCHELL- WORK TO TRY TO GET US
ON THAT PATH IN THIS PROUD TO
TRY TO WORK WITH HER TO. DO
THAT AND I HOPE WE CAN
CERTAINLY REACH IT THIS YEAR AT
LEAST GET TO HALF OF THE PARTY
LEVEL THANK YOU. YEAH WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW HE THINK
ABOUT IT AS A LADDER AND- AMBER
THAT WERE. YET AND TO BE A
POVERTY AND THEN TO THINK THAT
WE'RE JUST GOING TO GET FOLKS
UP TO HALF OF THAT- IN THE
STATE WITHOUT. WITHOUT MUCH
DEBATE AS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
COST OF LIVING- IS DISTRESSING.
AND EIGHT THEN I SHOULD HAVE
SAID THAT THE LAST ONE TO WE
THINK SENATOR CORTESE FOR AS
YOU B. I. A PILOT HE DID IN ST
CLAIR COUNTY THAT WERE ABLE TO
PULL NOW OVER TO THE WHOLE
STATE SO. YES WE THINK A
SUPERVISOR MITCHELL FOR ALL OF
HER FOR YEARS AND YEARS OF WORK
IN ADVOCACY. ARM FOR THIS- AND
THEN OF COURSE. RESTORING THE
COST OF LIVING COLA. FOR S. S.
P. ALSO. DESERVE DESERVE
DESERVE VERY POOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE BARELY MAKING IT WITH A LOT
OF OTHER ISSUES- AND WE ALSO
HAVE MIKE HERALD PRESENTING ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AND HAPPY TO
PRESENT THIS AFTERNOON TO THE-
SUBCOMMITTEE- AND YES DOCTOR
PAN- YOU ARE RIGHT THIS ONE.
SENATOR MITCHELL IN JEANS
HERE'S- CHAIRED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND CHAIRMAN
OVERALL BUT MAYBE. REALLY MADE
THIS A PRIORITY- WHEN WE BEGAN
pRANGE OF ABOUT 38% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL THEY WERE
REALLY FAST. COMING OUT OF
SYRIA HEARINGS OVER SEVERAL
YEARS. WHERE WE BROUGHT IN
RESEARCHERS SHOWED AND
DEMONSTRATED WHAT'S WHAT IMPACT
WILL BE ON CHILDREN GREW UP AND
ACTIVISTS REST HE- WARNED NON
MISSION. ON I THINK THIS KIND
OF RESEARCH REALLY HELPED DRIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE AND EVENTUALLY
THE GOVERNOR YOU ARE DOCTORS
THREE STEP APPROACH TO GETTING
THE GRANT UP ABOVE THE-
MIDPOINT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. YEAH YES IT'S NOT THE
PLACE THAT WE NEED TO STOP YOU
NEED TO GO HIGHER BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT MEASUREMENT AND
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE YOU KNOW
OF A SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE-
SHOW ROOM THE LEVELS. ARE SO
YOU. KNOW WE TOOK TWO STEPS.
WORST FEARS. THE LAST ONE IN
GOVERNOR BROWN'S LAST YEAR'S
AND THE ONE WOULD GOVERNOR
NEEDS. FOLLOW THROUGH WHICH TO
AND OUT OF IN THE FIRST IT'S
GOT YEAH GREAT REVIEWS SHAPE
THE- LAST YEAR WE OBVIOUSLY
BOND IN THE ROAD. IT SHOULD THE
INSURMOUNTABLE- YOU CAN FALL
OFF ON THE PHONE NOW THEN MAKE
SOME STOCK RECORDS FROM. BUT
THIS YEAR WE HAVE A TO THAT WE
HAVE A LOS QUE LOADS SYSTEM HAS
MANY YEARS. WE CAN CLEARLY
AFFORD. FRANK AREN'T NEED AND
MANY YOU ARE MEMBERS LET'S.
RECRUIT THIS BRING BUDGET I'M
NOT YES- OVER THAT PERCENT
LEVEL THAT ON THE ONLY OF ON.
SO I THINK THIS IS A MAJOR PART
THAT WERE HOPING TO GET. ON
CROSS AND- I DO WANT TALK JUST
VERY BRIEFLY ALSO ABOUT YES
IT'S- I'M DOCTOR. AND STORY
VERY WELL LIKED THE FIVE FIVE
BUT IT WAS SOMETHING. ABOUT.
UNDER GOVERNOR SHE NO PARKING
THREE GOVERNOR YOU KNOW. I'M
GONNA PREVIOUS. ON WE HAVE BEEN
GRANT TO STAY. THE GRANTS OF
FEDERAL MINIMUM SS. IT WAS A
SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR NEEDS IN THE S. ON. ABOUT A
YEAR NOW ALSO POINTS OUT OF THE
OVER YOU SEEN THAT RAN BALLOT
USE THAT THE GRANT WORTH MORE
THAN A HUNDRED SOME OF POVERTY
LEVEL IT'S AN HELLO PERCENT OF
THE FEDERAL LEVEL IT IS
CONTINUING FIND YOUR NOT OF
PROVIDE THE POSSIBILITY THAT.
OR GRAND WE ARE THERE SUPPORT
OF THIS. YOU CAN FIND STORE
SOME THAT WAS HI TWELVE YEARS
AGO FROM LINE EIGHT THIS PEOPLE
IN BY DEFINITION READ CAN'T
WORK YEAH OPEN SO WITH EXPENSE
NEEDS JUST ONE POINT WALLS. THE
VALUE OF THOSE. IS WORK ONE
BILL DOLLARS IN. SO WHY ONE BY.
WE HAVE TO GET OVER A BILLION
BY A YEAR AWAY FROM LOW INCOME.
YES SIGN. SAME TIME WE DON'T
NOW BUT SIR. RAINY DAY FOR AND
NOW WE OBVIOUSLY- ABOUT THE ARE.
IN THE MORNING ONE ONE BUDGET.
IT HAS FINE PLEASE. WOULD BE
RESTORED AND WE'RE-
APPRECIATIVE OF THE OF THE
SENATE INCLUDING THIS NEW
PACKAGE AND WE'RE HOPEFUL. WHEN
THE DUST SO ONCE. KING THAT
THESE KIND OF WILL FIND USE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
I WE WOULD AGREE THE NEW SAY
THAT WOULD AGREE. OKAY NOTHING
ELSE ON THIS ONE KATIE OKAY SO
LET'S ON TO THE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX THE C. P. COMMUNITY CARE X.
PRO. HELLO HI CORINNE BUCHANAN
HERE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
HOUSING AND HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THE WELCOME. I'LL
JUST GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT SO IS
CSS IS REQUESTING A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES MINISTER
THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM WOULD FIND
THE ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION ADULT AND SENIOR
FOR DELIVERY. AS WE HAVE
ALREADY DISCUSSED TODAY IN
HEARING THESE RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS. ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF HOUSING. HERE'S ABILITY.
LOOTING FOR EXAMPLE INDIVIDUALS
OF YOU KNOW HOW CHEN YOU HAVE
NO ALL HOW OPTIONS TO MEET
THEIR LEVEL OF CARE NEEDS ARE
LIKELY TO COME HOME. ONCE AT
THE SETTINGS ARE NO LONGER
AVAILABLE AT THE FUNDS PROPOSED
HERE WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
COUNTY TRIED. THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM RESOURCE SO I
COULD MENTION COMMITTEE HERE
EXPANSION PROGRAM I. AT ONE
POINT CORD CHEN FUND IN TWENTY
ONE YOU AND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND. JUNE TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR THIS
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN CONTRACT FUNDING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION SERVICES SUPPORT THE
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION.
YLIDES THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WHICH SUPPORT CAN'T EVEN TRY TO
DEVELOP GAP ANALYSES AND
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFUL CAPITAL
FUND DISBURSEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE. TO
CLOCK BURKE EVALUATION FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT MONITORING THAT
FACILITY CREATION AND
PRESERVATION EFFORT- THE GOAL
OF COURSE THE- FUNDING. I'M
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN THE PROGRAM WE BELIEVE THAT
ADEQUATE PROGRAM STATUS OF WORK.
THE WORK IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THE- YEAH. ALL ALSO SHARE- BUT
IN ADDITION BE COMMITTED
EXPENSE REQUIRE YES ALSO
REQUEST ONE THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM POSITION FOR THE CONTINUED
OPERATION OF THE STATE PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND RE HOUSING
STRATEGY I'M SO GLAD YOU KNOW
HOW TO GREET YOU WAS
ESTABLISHED IN RESPONSE. YOU
RIGHT NANKANA SHELTERING JUST.
AND MOTELS BURKE. IN THIS
PARTICULAR POSITION IS NEEDED I
TOOK FURTHER LEAD OUR DATA
COLLECTION EFFORTS WHICH NOW
INCLUDES NINETY THAT DATA
RECORDING ON ARE WE HOUSING
EFFORTS AND THAT'S ALL ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE HOWELLS. AGENCY RESPONSE
PROJECT GREEN KEEP PAYING. ARE
ARE ABLE TO TRANSITION TO
STABLE HOUSING UPON EXIT RATHER
THAN RETURNING. IN ADDITION THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
STATE. TO ALL OF THE FIFTY FIVE
COUNTIES AND THREE TRIBES ARE
OPERATING PROJECT ROOM KEY-
WOULD BE A PART OF THIS
PARTICULAR WALL AS WELL. AND TO
ADD THAT STAFF WOULD ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS AND
LEVERAGING REIMBURSEMENT WHICH
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF
THE WAY IN WHICH HE'S NOT
CONGREGATE SHELTERING. I THINK
THAT AND BY CONTINUING TO WORK
TO DO YOU LIKE COLLABORATION TO
SHARE BEST PRACTICES AND
EMERGING GUIDANCE WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS AS WE MOVE OUT OF THE
CAN. WHILE MAINTAINING THAT
HOUSING STABILITY OF MANY
INDIVIDUALS OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND I IN FACT HAVE BEEN
SERVED THROUGH THIS PROGRAM. I
DURING DURING. AND ALSO. HE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO HAVE
ANYTHING ON THE- AT. YES THEY
ACTUALLY STARTED AGAIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DON'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
CONCERNS WITH THE REQUESTED
STAFFING RESOURCES- BUT WE DO
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME BROADER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE- COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM
PROPOSAL. IN PARTICULAR-
WITHOUT DETAILED IMPLEMENTING
LEGISLATION FOR THE PROGRAM-
EXACTLY HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED AND OVERSEEN
REMAINS UNCLEAR AT THIS TIME.
SO IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO
ASSESS WHETHER IT'S THE
REQUESTED RESOURCE SAYS- WHAT
INDEED BE SUFFICIENT FOR THE
PROGRAM HOWEVER WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND-
DETAILED IMPLEMENTATION PLANS
AS THOSE ARE DEVELOPED. IN
ADDITION- WE WOULD NOTE THAT AS
WE HEARD EARLIER DURING THIS
HEARING AS PART OF THE SENATE
BUDGET OPTIONS FOR AGING ISSUES
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO
CONSIDERING FUNDING FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES FOR ADULT AND SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES- SERVING
RESIDENTS RECEIVE SS I SS P.
PAYMENTS. AND WE THINK THAT
THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM LIKELY
WOULD HAVE MANY SIMILARITIES TO
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. SO DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES
TO MOVE FORWARD- WITH ONE OR
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS THERE
COULD BE A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
STAFFING RESOURCES NEEDED-
THEREFORE WE AGREE WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION AT THIS
TIME TO HOLD OPEN THE ISSUE
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION- CONTINUE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT TYPE OF STATE LEVEL
SUPPORT WILL BE PROVIDED FOR
ADULTS. AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES AND THEN BASED ON
THAT PLAN WHAT STAFFING
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED AT THE
STATE LEVEL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS BECAME OFFICIAL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE MORE FOR
SOME IS HELPING PEOPLE TO GET
THINGS UP TO. REINVESTMENT IN
THE STRUCTURE OF THEM HOW MANY
BEDS THOUGH DO WE ARE WE ARE WE
JUST TRYING TO MAINTAIN THE
BEDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THESE FACILITIES ARE WE TRYING
TO ADD TO THE NUMBER OF BEDS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
WHAT'S THE GOAL WITH THIS AND I
THINK THAT CAN BETTER. HELP US
SEE HOW IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF STAFF IF WE KNOW WHAT
THE ACTUAL THE ACTUAL GOAL FOR
GETTING MORE PEOPLE IN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL HOUSING LET
ME SAY YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO THE
GOAL IS BOTH ATTITUDE IT'S TO
COLD IT'S BOTH EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES IN
PARTICULAR FACILITIES ACCEPT.
SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS ACROSS
THE STATE WHILE ALSO PRESERVING
THOSE SETTINGS ARE CURRENTLY
OPERATIONAL- BUT MAY HAVE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND OTHER
WE HAD NEEDS. THAT WITHOUT THIS
FUNDING MAYBE I'M JUST. A LUCKY
CLOSURE. OKAY BUT WE DON'T HAVE
A NUMBER OF MANY HOW MANY MORE
BEDS THAT WERE TO ABOUT HOW
MANY MORE ROOMS MUCH MARKET.
THAT WE WANT TO BUILD INTO THE
SYSTEM. WHAT DOES THAT WILL BE
BASED ON NOT REALLY THE
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN. THOSE THAT
DON'T THAT OF COURSE TO CREATE
A NEW BAND IS MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN PRESERVING THOSE ARMS WILL
BE BASED ON- BASED ON THAT
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN THOSE TO USE
THOSE. AND PART OF THE WORK
WILL BE ABOUT YOU ON A
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS. IT'S A PART
OF THE PROPOSAL. TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW COUNTIES ARE
WORKING WITH THESE FACILITIES
AND- AND HOW TO BEST GET THE
MOST BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN TERMS
OF STATE INVESTMENT- THIS
RESOURCE FOR PEOPLE. RIGHT HE-
AND DO YOU KNOW IS A PLAN AT
SOME POINT TO TAKE SOME OF THE
HOTELS AND MOTELS WITH PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND TURN THEM INTO.
MORE LONGER TURN. OUR OF CAESAR
AFC'S YEAH ABSOLUTELY HOTELS
AND MOTELS WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
A LIKELY REAL ESTATE TYPE THAT
COULD BE TRANSIT TRANSITION
INTO ADULT AND SENIOR THE
LADIES- AND OF COURSE A LOT HAS
HAPPENED ALREADY THROUGH HOME
CHIEF WHICH IS CURRENT. HELLO
RIGHT HOUSING- YOU BRING UP
OKAY WEIGHT THAT ANOTHER
HOUSING TYPOLOGY ARE ASSISTED
LIVING SETTINGS I'M COULD ALSO
BE A GOOD. FOR THAT TYPE OF
REAL ESTATE. OKAY BUT THANK YOU
HI TECH VENTURA THINGS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE IT M. AND NOW- ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN THE SENATE BUDGET
OPTIONS ARE ON HOUSING. SHORT
THANK YOU AGAIN HERE WE GO YES
THAT'S ME AGAIN. THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
A FLEXIBLE FUNDING POOL TO BE
USED FOR COUNTY ADMINISTERED
HOUSING PROGRAMS. THIS REFLECTS
A PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS%
ASSOCIATION HEARD IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S FEBRUARY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING. HEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I THINK
WE HAVE- ELLEN- BAND SKI THE
DIRECTOR OF BUDGET AND FISCAL
POLICY FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE- TO
DESCRIBE THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THAT AFTERNOON THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS EILEEN KAMINSKY
AND THE WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
TODAY. THE HOUSING CRISIS
AFFECTS EVERY PROGRAM OUR
MEMBERS RUN AND IT AFFECTS
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE.
HOUSING INSECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS WERE ALREADY AT
CRISIS LEVELS FOR OUR CLIENTS
NOT SURPRISINGLY WE HAVE SEEN
AN EVEN GREATER NEED FOR
HOUSING SUPPORT AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC. AND THE HEALTH
RISKS OF HOMELESSNESS ALREADY
GREAT BECAME EVEN MORE LIFE OR
DEATH WITH THE POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE TO COPE AT NINETEEN.
ALSO WITH THE PANDEMIC CAME
BOTH UNCERTAINTY AND CONSTANT
CHANGE DOWNEY'S HAVE PIVOTED
NUMEROUS TIMES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF VARIOUS ONE TIME
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE VERY WELCOME
BUT ALSO MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
PLAN OR BEST FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BLEND TOGETHER SERVICES FOR THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS WE OPERATE IN
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE. WHILE WE
APPLAUD THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
AND THE TALKS TO CONTINUE IT.
IT HAS COMPOUNDED THE
DIFFICULTIES WE ALREADY HAVE TO
HELP OUR CLIENTS FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS.
LACK OF HOUSING STOCK IN
AFFORDABLE RENTALS ARE REAL
BARRIERS TO SECURING HOUSING.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DESPERATE IMPACTS OF ONGOING
HOUSING DIFFICULTIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC EXAMPLES OF THIS
INCLUDE THOSE LIVING AND
NONTRADITIONAL ARRANGEMENTS
WITHOUT A FORMAL LEASE LIKE
FAMILY MEMBERS CONVERTED
GARAGES OR SHARING A HOME. THEY
DO NOT HAVE THE PROTECTIONS
THAT SOMEONE WITH A FORMAL
LEASE THE LANDLORD TO. AND THEN
THERE ARE THOSE WHO CAN STILL
BE EFFECTIVE FOR NON PANDEMIC
RELATED CAUSES AND THOSE
EVICTIONS ARE ALREADY A PROBLEM
WITHOUT THE ADDED LAYER OF THE
PANDEMIC ON TOP OF IT. FAMILIES
IN THESE SITUATIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM MANY
OF THE EXISTING PANDEMIC
RELATED HOUSING ASSISTANCE
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED SO FAR.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CRISIS THAT
ADDICTION CREATES ALSO FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR. IN EVIDENCE STRONGLY
INDICATES THAT ADDICTION IS NOT
JUST A CONDITION OF POVERTY IT
IS A BECAUSE OF THAT- OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS COUNTIES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE STIRRED UP
A NUMBER OF HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS TIED DIRECTLY TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE. OUR PROPOSAL AS
OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA IS FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO BE SPENT OVER
TWO YEARS. TO BOOST THE
SERVICES IN THOSE HOUSING
PROGRAMS ARE MEMBERS ALREADY
OPERATE FOR A CLIENT'S.
COUNTIES CAN USE THESE PLANS
LACKS A LEAD TO FILL GAPS IN
FUNDING AND HOUSING ASSISTANCE
ALTERNATIVES FOR OUR CLIENTS.
INCLUDING PREVENTION AGAINST
HOUSING LOSS WHICH OUR CURRENT
HOUSING PROGRAMS DO NOT ALL
SUPPORT AS WELL AS WE'D LIKE.
STABLE HOUSING IS CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF ALL THE OTHER
SUPPORTS WERE TRYING TO PROVIDE
YOUR HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS.
WE CAN'T REUNIFY CHILDREN OF
PARENTS WHO LACK SHELTER. OR
COUCH PERSON PARTICIPANTS CAN'T
HOLD DOWN A JOB IF THEY'RE
SLEEPING IN A CAR. ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ADULT WHO NEED HELP
FOR ABUSE AND NEGLECT ISSUES
INCLUDING THE GROWING PROBLEM
OF FINANCIAL ABUSE. ARE MORE
LIKELY TO FALL INTO ILL HEALTH
AND EVEN DIE IF THEY LOSE THEIR
HOMES. COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STAFF KNOW OUR CLIENTS AND
UNDERSTAND WHEN SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE NEEDED. BOTH TO
SECURE HOUSING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY HOMELESS. AND TO
HELP PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR HOMES
AND AVOID HOMELESSNESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. HAVING RESOURCES
AT THE READY TO ENSURE WE CAN
QUICKLY PROVIDE THOSE SUPPORTS
WITHIN OUR EXISTING HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR PROPOSAL
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. I
GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION BE EVEN
IF. WE HAVE MORE MONEY HOW'S
YOUR SUPPLY. THAT'S A GREAT-
AND THAT'S WHY PREVENTION
REALLY IS KEY AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION IS WORTH A- POUND OF
CURE SO TO SPEAK- IF WE CAN.
THROUGH A LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND BACK THOSE UP A
LITTLE BIT AND CHEAP FOLKS FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS FIRST PLACE-
THAT WILL THAT WILL GO A LONG
WAY. BUT IN ADDITION OUR
PROPOSAL WOULD ENABLE COUNTIES.
TO SECURE- EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
SHELTER AS NEEDED- AS WELL AS
SOME SHORTER TERM- HOUSING
OPTIONS SO WE DO HAVE ON THE
ABILITY. TO EXPAND THE WAY WE
USE OUR FUNDS ARE THESE FUNDS
AND OUR LEVERAGE OUR PROGRAMS
TO TRY TO BUILD A LITTLE BIT
MORE HOUSING STOCK AT LEAST ON
A TEMPORARY BASIS FOR THE
CLIENTS WE SERVE. GOOD IN AT
LEAST TO CONTINUE ON IF PEOPLE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING VERY
TEMPORARY THERE'S A PLAN TO NOT
LEAVE THEM THERE. WHERE SITE
AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEM AS THEY TRANSITION INTO
SOMETHING MORE PERMANENT AS
WELL AS THAT IS A PART OF IT.
ALSO OKAY BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
POVERTY COMES WITH ALL KINDS A
CORRESPONDING ISSUES THAT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE NEED EXTRA
HELP TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
HOUSING AND TO MAKE THOSE
TRANSITIONS. VERY MUCH YEAH.
OKAY THE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT- DESIRE FOR
FLEXIBILITY AND SO FORTH WHAT-
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD BE
REASONABLE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND IN THAT AFTER
IT'S DONE I MEAN I THINK WE'D
LIKE TO KNOW IN THE END YOU
KNOW HOW WE ENDED UP SPENDING
THE MONEY- AND- HOPEFULLY THAT
GIVES US SOME LESSONS GOING TO
THE FUTURE IS TO MAKING FUTURE
INVESTMENTS SO. I CAN JUST
SPEAK TO WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AND- THE STATE WILL
BE GETTING FOR ITS INVESTMENT
SO WE ARE WE WANNA GIVE YOU THE
FLEXIBILITY REALIZE EVERY
COUNTY HAS DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES SO FORTH BUT ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION TO HELP INFORM
FUTURE DECISION MAKING SO CAN
YOU SPEAK TO- WHAT WOULD YOU
SUGGEST THAT WE DO IN THAT
REGARD. YEAH THANK YOU A DOCTOR
PAM FOR THAT QUESTION- BECAUSE
IT'S ONE CERTAINLY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN CONTEMPLATING AS WELL AND
HAVE NOT BEEN SPECIFIC IN TERMS
OF OUR PROPOSAL- WE WEREN'T
BEEN TALKING ALREADY TO THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT REPORTING JUST
IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THOSE MEASURES- AND
INFORMATION. THAT ARE REALLY
THE MOST USEFUL- TO ASSESSING
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROGRAMS ARE
SUCCESSFUL AND I THINK THERE
ARE SOMEBLOCKS THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF SOME OF
THAT. I THINK A CHALLENGE FOR
US IS I MEAN IDEALLY WE WOULD
FOLLOW FOLKS LOGIC
LONGITUDINALLY- THOSE ARE
EXPENSIVE- STUDIES- IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE NECESSARILY
CONTEMPLATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL
BUT WE'RE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTIVE
OF GATHERING- DATE ON HOW WE
USE THAT THE FUNDS HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE SERVE WITH THE FUNDS
WHAT KINDS OF OUTCOMES IN TERMS
OF PLACEMENTS OR PREVENTIVE
MEASURES- WE- WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH- AND REALLY OPEN TO
TALKING ABOUT WHAT KINDS OF
INFORMATION WE COULD GATHER.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN- IN CONTINUING
THIS FLEXIBILITY. AND THEY JUST
THE ONE FOLLOW UP THE- WE
STARTED THIS WHOLE HEARING
TALKING ABOUT THE NEW
INFORMATION SYSTEM CALC I THINK
ACT WAS CALLED CARES OR.
SOMETHING- V. YES HE W. S.
CARES- D. AND AGAIN THAT HAS A
VERY DIFFERENT PURPOSE BUT-
WHAT CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO
THE KIND OF DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HAVE OR DON'T HAVE TO
HELP US. TRY TO TRACK THE
BENEFITS OF OUR VARIOUS EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS AS IS AS COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTOR- JUST AS A
DISSOCIATION IN THE IN TERMS OF
THE KIND OF. IT INFRASRUCTURE
WE NEED TO HELP TRY TO TRACK
RESULTS. THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
WE DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF A- A
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE WE DO IN ORANGE
UNDER TRYING TO BUILD IN CHILD
WELFARE- IT REALLY IS- VERY-
KIND OF PROGRAM SPECIFIC
REPORTING THAT WE DO COUNTY BY
COUNTY THAT HAS BEEN GATHERED-
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT LEVEL.
AND I DON'T THINK NECESSARILY
THAT WE NEED TO BUILD A NEW
SYSTEM TO GATHER DATA- BUT- I
DO THINK THAT- HAVING SOME-
CONSOLIDATION MAY BE OF THE
DATA THAT WE'RE GATHERING SO WE
GOT TO CONSISTENCY IN THE
INFORMATION WE'RE GETTING FOR
ALL THESE PROGRAMS COULD BE IT
COULD BE HELPFUL- AND WOULD BE-
HAPPY TO TALK TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND WORK WITH THEM MORE TO
MAYBE FIGURE OUT WHAT. KINDS OF
ON THINGS WE WOULD NEED TO
SUPPORT ON GOOD DATA REPORTING-
AND GATHERING OKAY SO THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT SUGGESTING THAT
IN THIS PROPOSAL WE THEN ADD A
WHOLE YOU KNOW I. T. STRUCTURE
TO THIS BUT I DO THINK THE
RECEIPT THAT. SOME THOUGHT
ABOUT- BASICALLY EVALUATION AND
HOW HOPEFULLY GET SOME
INFORMATION TO HELP SYSTEM FOR
FUTURE INVESTMENTS. THAT I
GUESS THE OTHER PART IS YOU
KNOW IT'S PART IS ALSO THIS
UNIT IN YOUR OWN TESTIMONY AS
WELL AS WE HEAR FROM OTHER
PEOPLE. YEAH WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT- OF NICE YOUNG PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE JUST ONE ISSUE RIGHT
SO HOUSING THEN LEADS TO OTHER
ISSUES OR OTHER ISSUES MAY LEAD
TO POOR YOU KNOW. I HAVE ACCESS
TO HOUSING. AND SO AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WE PROVIDE AT THE
STATE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND
SO FORTH- TRYING TO IDENTIFY
LIKE HOW HOW THEY EITHER
INTERSECTED DON'T INTERSECT
GREAT SO WHERE WHERE PEOPLE
GETTING HELP FROM WHERE DAY NOT
GETTING HELP FROM. YELL AT HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING SERVED BY
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS OR NOT WHERE
THE GAPS ARE. AND- JUST TRYING
TO THINK A BIT ABOUT- THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW. HOW WE DID A
FIGHT. THAT SO WE CAN YOU KNOW
BASICALLY DO BETTER INVESTMENTS
A POLICY RIGHT. AND SO BE ABLE
TO COLLECTIVELY SOME DATA NOT
JUST ON THE PROGRAM'S LEVEL BUT
KNOWING THAT ARE YOU KNOW THE
SAME PERSONALLY SERVE THIS
PROGRAM IS ALSO HELPING THAT
PROGRAM ARE NOT. WOULD WOULD BE
USEFUL. ANYWAY APPRECIATE DATA
THAT THE THOUGHTS OF YOUR
ASSOCIATION ON THAT AS WE
CONTINUE FORWARD. THANKS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY BUT THE IS
IT A NEXT ITEMS BACK TO DATA
OUR NEXT ITEMS BACK TO DATA
THAT'S RIGHT US WERE NEXT ITEMS
ISSUE EIGHT- S. WHOLE TRIAL
INTEGRATION AND DATA
DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AND
SALIM CHAU CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND I'LL BE
GIVING AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST FOR THIS
PROPOSAL. WE ARE REQUESTING
NINE POSITIONS. FIVE IN OUR
LICENSING DIVISION ONE AND
RESEARCH AND THREE POSITIONS IN
OUR LEGAL DIVISION OR TOTAL ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE POSITIONS BUT SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH TRANSFERS
SOCCER PROGRAMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THESE CONDITIONS ALSO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE'S
MASTER CLEAR ON EARLY LEARNING
CARE WHICH PROVIDES A RESEARCH
BASED ROADMAP FOR BUILDING A
COMPREHENSIVE AND EQUITABLE.
SYSTEM OVER THE NEXT DECADE-
THE LATEST AND RESEARCH
POSITION FOR BECAUSE- WITH
STATE TO DESIGN DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A SHARED VISION.
QUALITY AND EQUITY AND
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD BE
PROVIDING TARGETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO BUILD CAPACITY AN
EXPANSIVE HI EARLY LEARNING AND
CHILD CARE TO SUPPORT A GLOBAL
ACCESS. THE RESEARCH DIVISION
DIVISION CONDITION WOULD
PROVIDE A DEDICATED RESOURCE
FOR DATA MANAGEMENT NINETY
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION IN
COORDINATION. IMPLEMENTATION
OVERSIGHT AND SOME LONG TERM
PLANNING AS WELL. AND FINALLY
THE AND POSITIONS WOULD PROVIDE
LEGAL SUPPORT BETWEEN THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS AND LICENSING AS
WELL AS INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
AND DATA CONTRACTS WORKS. I
THINK THE ANY QUESTIONS- HELLO.
ENGINEERING THANK. JUST A BRIEF
COMMENT AND THIS APPLIES TO THE
NEXT ITEM AS WELL- THIS IS JUST
SAID NOTE THAT THIS- BUDGET
REQUEST IS CONTINGENT ON THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTING- SEVERAL
OTHER GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
RELATED TO SHIFTING THE
ADMINISTRATION- PROGRAMS TO
DSS- AS THE LEGISLATURE HASN'T
TAKEN ACTION ON THOSE OTHER
PROPOSALS WE CAN CARE WHAT THE
STAFF. RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN FOR NOW AND WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONFORMANCE STAFFING LEVELS
WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL AND IN THE
NEXT WITH OTHER TRANSITION
RELATED DECISIONS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK WE
APPRECIATE THAT MISTER ANDERSON
THE DIFFERENT FINANCE. HELLO
SAY LET OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS MOMENT. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELCOME YOU GOT ASKING FOR DATA
POSITIONS ON SOMETHING WE'RE
NOT QUITE SURE ABOUT YET BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION DR
PAN HAVE SOUGHT IT'S JUST A
QUICK QUESTION RELATES ABOUT
THIS AND I GUESS THE NEXT ONE
TO USE- BUT IT SO CERTAINLY
SKID SEE THE NEED FOR THESE
POSITIONS IF WE MOVED OUT THERE
ALL OVER TO CDSS AND- SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT SINCE
EDUCATION SALE BY DIFFERENT SUB
COMMITTEE IS THERE THEN IF WE
DO DO THAT IS- A REDUCTION
POSITIONS OVER IN C. E. R. SO
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW WHAT THE
NET IS OUR DUTY OF THE
TRANSFERRING PEOPLE OVER SIGNED
I REALIZE YOUR POSITIONS. OR
TRANSFERRING PEOPLE OVER FROM
C. D. E. WHO USED TO BE DOING
THAT WORKERS CAN SOMEONE MAYBE
PERHAPS SPEAK TO- SO I WOULD
JUST SEEM TO ONE SIDE OF IT SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THE OTHER SIDE WE SAVING
MONEY ON THE OTHER SIDE ARE
THESE THE SAME PEOPLE. WHO ARE
JUST COMING OVER THESE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE. I THINK ISSUE
MR. SURE SO THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL REQUEST- IT IS IN
OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WE HAD WHAT WE REFERTO AS OUR
RETENTION PROPOSAL THAT WOULD-
JEANS FOR A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE POINT SEVEN TRANSITIONS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SOCIAL SERVICES SO
THIS WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS THAT WERE NOT A PART
OF THAT INITIAL TRANSFER AND
WHEN I.STOP. TO SUPPORT THIS
ADDITIONAL EFFORT. INTEL DO YOU
SEE YOU SEE THAT IT WITH IT
MOVING OVER TO CDS IT'S S. THE
PARCEL SERVICES THAT- THAT YOU
WOULD NEED MORE CAPACITY- ON
THE SOCIAL SERVICE SIDE OR IS
THIS PART OF A LARGER EFFORT TO
CHANGE TO IMPROVE OUR CHANGER-
CHILD CARE. AS WE MOVE IT OVER
TO SOCIAL SERVICES. THIS IS-
POSITIONS THAT DO SUPPORT
CAPACITY- IN IN THE NEXT ISSUE
WE WILL BE TALKING A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT AS WELL. IN
ADDITION WE DO HAVE SOME LONG
TERM PLANNING THAT WE HAVE FOR.
THE DATA. ROAD MAP AS MENTIONED
WITH THE MASTER PLAN SO THESE
ARE ALL EFFORTS THAT CURRENTLY
DO NOT EXIST- WITH THAT
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PROGRAMS TODAY. BUT WOULD
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION AND
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAMS IN THE
FUTURE. I GUESS I WOULD JUST
KIND THAT IT WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE TREES RIGHT NOW
WILL BE GOOD IDEA TO GET A
BETTER LOOK AT THE FOREST AT
SOME POINT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ONE- CHILD CARE.
AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM SUPPORT.
YOU'RE BACK WITH A MYSTERY YES
HELLO AGAIN TERRY MEMBERS ADAM
SO A LOT OF THE DISCUSSION THAT
YOU JUST HAD MAY APPLY HERE AS
WELL- THIS IS ALSO ABOUT A
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT AND
IS RELATED TO THE TRANSITION OF
PROGRAMS FROM. FEED TO CDSS
EFFECTIVE BACK ALLY ONE- AND
AGAIN THAT THAT TRANSITION WAS
ENACTED- LAST YEAR AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CD E. ALL YEAR
THIS YEAR TO BE READYTO GO ON
JULY ONE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE THAT TRANSFER. SO AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS IN JANUARY
AS YOU WERE JUST DISCUSSING-
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE POSITIONS THAT ARE MOVING
FROM CD TO CDSS. THAT INITIAL
B. C. P. DID NOT IDENTIFY ALL
OF THE LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT
POSITIONS. THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
CDSS TO IMPLEMENT THE TRANSFER
WHILE ALSO ALLOWING CDP TO
CONTINUE IN ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
OPERATIONS OF STATE PRESCHOOL
SO THIS IS THE- REMAINING
POSITIONS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
AS NECESSARY FOR CDSS TO ENSURE
BOTH NO DISRUPTION OF SERVICES
DUE TO THE TRANSFER. AND TODAY-
SUCCESSFUL OPERATION OF THE
PROGRAMS AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD TOWARD FUTURE SUCCESS- AS
WE IMPROVE THEIR OPERATIONS SO
THIS- THIS REQUEST INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY POSITIONS THAT
ARE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THEY'RE INTENDED TO CREATE SOME
BALANCE STAFFING RATIOS AND
MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT WE HAVE NO
DISRUPTIONS IN THE SYSTEM SO
EIGHTEEN OF THE POSITIONS-
WOULD BE LOCATED IN OUR NEW.
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION. THREE WOULD BE AN
ARCH HIGH IN A DAY CARE FOOD
PROGRAM BRANCH WITHIN THE
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND
EMPOWERMENT DIVISION. EIGHT
WILL BE IT SUPPORTING THE
PROGRAM THROUGH OUR LEGAL
DIVISION FIVE WOULD BE IN OUR
RESEARCH AUTOMATION AND
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION- NINE ARE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION DIVISION
AND SEVEN ARE ARE HEALTH SAFETY
AND SECURITY. TEAM FOR OF THE
OVERALL WORK FORCE. I SO THAT.
TOTAL CA THAT FIFTY POSITION
THERE'S A- FINDING THAT
INCLUDED TWENTY. WITHOUT THE-
VISIT A STORY SO THOSE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY. ALREADY
REQUEST ARE IN TO THIS-
pTHE TRANSFER OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BEYOND THE
ONES THAT WERE ALREADY
DISCUSSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HELLO. HI RYAN ANDERSON AGAIN
NO ORIGINAL COMMENTS ON THIS
JUST TO REITERATE THE- YES
POINT THAT- THE LEGISLATURE
STILL WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THE BROADER ISSUES HERE A LOT
OF THE WORK BEING DONE AS A
SENATOR AND NOTED IN A AND
ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE- SO SEEMS
PRUDENT TO HOLD THIS ISSUE UP
AND THEN CONFORM. YOUR DECISION
TO THOSE BROADER ACTIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE PROCESS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH M. I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS DOCTRINE
DENNIS. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND NOW I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT AND I BELIEVE I SEE-
MISPERCEIVED BARCY- THAT IT
BORROWS YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
WITH THEIR HAND UP AND READY TO
GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE
WERE ASKED TO READ PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS THE SUB
COMMITTEE HAS RECEIVED FROM
STAKEHOLDERS- WELL WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO ANSWER SPECIFIC
DETAILED QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY
HAVE WERE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND GET
RESPONSES AS NEEDED. SO JUST
START- WITH NUMBER ONE THE
CALIFORNIA RULE INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD INC REQUEST THREE POINT
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE SERVICES AT
INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT-
COMES FROM THE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT CALIFORNIA- WHICH
REQUEST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO
ESTABLISH AND FUND IN EQUITY
CORE. THE THIRD PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT IS FROM THE-CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
GUARDIANS ANDPUBLIC
CONSERVATIVES. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA- WHO
REQUEST A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT HE
APPG PC PROGRAMS. THE FOURTH
PROPOSAL IS FROM SUPPLY BANK
DOT ORG WHICH REQUEST TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
TO EXPAND THE DIAPER BANK
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE TO SERVE
FIFTY COUNTIES NOT CURRENTLY
SERVED BY THE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- PART
OF FINANCE EVERYTHING ON THESE.
30% REMITTED ANY COMMONALITIES
OKAY JUST GREATEST BERMAN OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION IN THIS PROPOSAL WE
KIND OF POSITION ON ANY- AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND I WOULD JUST SAY ON
THE ON THE TOPIC THAT WE'RE
SPEAKING UP BEFORE WE WILL BE
HAVING A HEARING THIS THURSDAY
WITH THE- EDUCATION SO WE CAN
WE CAN TALK. MORE DEEPLY ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. OKAY I
THINK THIS IS. IT FOR THIS
SECTION AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NOW TO HEALTH. AND I SEE
OUR NEXT OF CONSULTANT COMING
UP HERE. SO WE THINK THAT
DECORATED POKED FOR HER WORK.
IN. DO WE NEED TO DO ANY. WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE JUST ONE MINUTE
PLEASE.
WE'LL BEGIN ALL RIGHT
JUST ONE MOMENT MISTER RIGHT
ONE ONE MOMENT. OKAY NOW WE'RE
READY TO BEGIN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE VERY WELCOME WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE EGGMAN
SOMEWHERE MULLIN DISCLOSURE PAN.
CORRECT HEALTH SORT. AND I AND
J. C. COOPER OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WILL BE- TAKING TURNS
DOING THE LEADER ON THE ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. I WILL
START WITH THE FIRST ONE WHICH
IS. MEDIKAL PROGRAM INTEGRITY
ANALYTICS. THIS IS A REQUEST
FOR A ONE YEAR EXTENSION- FOR A
CONTRACTOR THE EXPENDITURE OF
PARTY OF SIX POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH ONE POINT ONE
THREE MILLION YEARS GENERAL
FUND. THIS WILL SPEND OUR
CURRENT. ON CORRECT FOR YEAR-
ONE OF THE FOCUSING BE ON THE-
LOAN. SHE TRANSITIONS OR WILL
UNDER WAY LATER IN THE YEAR. AS
WELL. THE GENERAL SUPPORT HELLO
ALL. PROGRAM INTEGRITY
FUNCTIONS MMHM WE ARE EXPECTING
TO ONLY EXTEND THIS FOR EUROPE
AND I WANT TO BRING THE
CAPACITY IN THE HOUSE. COPY TO
ANSWERING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WOULD
SCURRY FINANCE NO COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME LMAO. I'VE BEEN JONES
WITH THE LA- WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS OKAY. I'M I'M OK WITH
THE START MENU OKAY HOUSE EASY
ONE MICHELIN FOR. WELL WE'LL GO
TO CHANGE ME. IN TROUBLE. BILL
CLOSE ALL. IT'S A THIS THIS WAS
A BIG AMONG THE- CONTACT.
TWENTY NOT TO AND WHICH WAS A
LOT SECOND DISASTER. WAS
INITIATED AS PART OF THE ALL
HIGH TECH OR REQUIREMENTS FOR
DEVELOPING. INTRACTABILITY
SYSTEMS AND STANDARDS FOR-
PATIENT ACTIONS ARE AND DATA
AGGREGATION- WE BACKED FUNDING
EXPIRES THIS SEPTEMBER SO THIS
IS A REQUEST FOR- CONTINUED
FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT OF TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION- WHICH
HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND IS
GENERAL FUND- IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE ALL WHO BRING OUT THE
PROCESS AND WE EXPECT. THE
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION- OF WILL
ADDRESSED IN. OF THE STATE
BUDGET- PROPOSALS. ANY
QUESTIONS- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. I THINK AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU LMAO. BEN JOHNSON
WITH THE L. A. R. NO CONCERNS
ON THE SIDE AND I DON'T IN THE
DOCTOR PAN. THE I NO NO REAL
CONCERNS I GUESS I'LL JUST MAKE
NOTE OF THAT- D. GREAT TOO
THERE WAS A REPORT AND PERHAPS-
AND OF TO COMMUNICATE THE- L.
A. L. IN TERMS OF- EXACTLY
WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. OF THESE
EFFORTS SO YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
DOING THE BUDGET THE POSITIONS
BUT JUST SORT OF LIKE WHERE ARE
WE WITH THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION FOR WHICH WE'RE
HIRING THESE PEOPLE. AND
ACTUALLY IN TERMS INTER
OPERABILITY WELL THINGS I DID
WANT TO RAISESIS THAT- SAMPLE
WE'VE HEARD THAT ONE CODE WAS
STARTING THAT HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- WE'RE NOT ABLE TO.
INTERACT WITH THE PRACTICES AND
THEY WERE GETTING FAXES OF
INFORMATION WHICH THEN HAD TO
BE MENTALLY MANUALLY ENTERED.
SO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT INTER
OPERABILITY AND I DON'T KNOW
THEY'RE JUST PART THE
PROFESSIONAL PROVISION OR NOT
WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT.
INTER OPERABILITY IN TERMS OF
ALSO INTERFACING WITH A PUBLIC
HEALTH- STRUCTURES AND SO I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER ANY OF.
THESE FOLKS WILL HAVE ANY
INVOLVEMENT IN THAT OR NOT BUT
I JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE- TO. SEE WHAT
IT CAN PROMOTE INTER
OPERABILITY NOT ONLY OF COURSE
BETWEEN VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
HEALTHCARE SECTOR IN ALL THE
DOCTORS AND CLINICS WITH THE
HOSPITALS ETCETERA BUT ALSO
WITH OUR- PUBLIC HEALTH
ENTITIES AS WELL SO THAT WE CAN
BE TRANSFERRING INFORMATION AND
A MORE SEAMLESS MANNER. THAN.
BY SAXON MANUAL RE ENTRY. SO I
NOBODY AT ANY KIND OF BRIEF. ON
THE ARE PROGRESS NOT ABSOLUTELY.
IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE. HELLO
SURE THAT THE TEAM WAS
DISTRACTED. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO A
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. MANAGED
CARE PLANS STATEWIDE
PROCUREMENT. HELLO J. C. COOPER
HERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- SO FOR
THIS ITEM THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING ELEVEN AND ELEVEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND SEVEN
OF FOUR YEAR LIMITED TEM
POSITIONS UP FOR A TOTAL OF TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION TOTAL FUND
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND- THE MANAGED CARE
PLAN PROCUREMENT OFFERS DO YOU
SEE AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESTRUCTURE OUR CONTRACT. AS
WELL AS DO AS STATEWIDE
PROCUREMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN OVER FIFTEEN YEARS WHAT WE
HAVE DONE THIS TYPE OF
PROCUREMENT SO A VERY CRITICAL-
ACTION ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE WILL BE INCLUDING
A NUMBER OF ENHANCED MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS IN REGARDS TO THE
PROCUREMENT WE WILL BE LOOKING
TO CLOSE CRITICAL QUALITY AND
EQUITY GAPS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT STRATEGY AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS WITHIN THE KALYAN
PROPOSAL THAT FALL WITHIN THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS CONTRACTS. I
WILL BE VERY FOCUSED ON
OVERSIGHT OF NUMBER ACCESS AS
WELL AS THE MANAGED CARE PLAN
DELEGATION- ENTITIES IN THEIR
OVERSIGHT OF THOSE ENTITIES
THERE WILL BE A NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS AROUND ADDRESSING
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
EMPHASIZING AT CHILDREN'S
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES INCLUDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ACCESS. AND
REALLY UNDERSCORING THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL LOCAL AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THE
DROPPED ARE IF YOU WILL IS A
PLAN TO BE POSTED- AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF JUNE I'M CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED FOR JUNE FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WILL HAVE
A THIRTY DAY PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD OF IN WHICH WE WILL TAKE
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC WILL
TAKE THOSE AT THAT BE BACK BACK
UPDATE THE R. P. AND PLAN TO
RELEASE RELEASED THE FINAL R.
P. BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I PROPOSALS WILL BE OUT WE
WOULD ALLOW SIXTY DAYTIME
PERIOD TO RECEIVE ALL APPROVED
AT PROPOSALS AND THEN ENGAGE IN
OPERATIONAL READINESS FROM
ABOUT MAY TWENTY TWO AT THE END
OF TWENTY THREE WITH ALL NEW
MANAGED CARE PLANS GOING LIVE.
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. I'M SO WOULD BE HAPPY
ANSWER ANY. YOU HAVE.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NOT ONLY
FROM THE FINANCE NO COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. LMAO HI BEN JOHNSON
AGAIN THE L. A. L. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
UNDERTAKING OF THE DEPARTMENT
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD GRACE
THANK YOU. THIRTY PRINT JUST A
BRIEF COMMENT- THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANT- ACTION
TO BE TAKEN FOR THE FUTURE OF
MEDIC CAL IMPROVEMENT MEDIKAL
CERTAINLY I PERSONALLY THINK WE
NEED TO BE SURE DETAILS HAS TO
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY MOVING ON.
WARRANT THE PROVIDER
APPLICATION VERIFICATION FOR
ENROLLMENT. WHAT WE ARE SEEKING
IS ONE YEAR LIMITED TERM
CONTRACT FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT
OF SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION. ALL
OF WHICH ONE POINT ALMOST EIGHT
MILLION IS GENERAL FUND TO
CONTINUE EXPANDING THE BUSINESS
VALUE OF THE PROVIDER
APPLICATION. WILL ONLY. GOAL IS
TO EXPAND INTO INCLUDES ALL
TIMELY PLANNING ACCESS CARE AND
TREATMENT. PROGRAM PROVIDERS
AND THOSE THAT ARE PART OF THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM-
SO. LOST THE SHELF FROM
SOFTWARE AS A SERVICE PLATFORM
MANAGED BY THE VENDOR. BECAUSE
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL. AND WILL
PROVIDE A- SPECTRUM. GRADES WE
HAVE CONTAINERS RATED VERY
WINDS FOR ON BARGE. SO WITH
LONG ONE HUNDRED ANSWERING. AND
THAT'S THE CLIENTS OF IT. IT IS
WHAT WE USED TO IN WHERE THE
TWO HUNDRED WITH FIVE DOLLARS.
MMHM ACTUALS WHOSE PEOPLE IN
NEED MEDICAID SYSTEM. CLICK TO
PARTNER FINE. I WAS GONNA
FINANCING CONCERNS LOL. I'VE
BEEN JOHNSON WITH THE L. A. R.
NO CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL
OKAY. OKAY WE'RE GOOD ON THAT
ONE TOO. ALL RIGHT WE WOULD
ALONG TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
MEDICAL BILLING OPTION PROGRAM
EXPANSION. LOW JC COOPER AGAIN
I'M SO THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING EIGHT PERMANENT
POSITIONS INTO LIMITED TERM
CONTRACT. WITH YOUR TOTAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
POINT TWO MILLION A TOTAL FUND
ONE POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND I'M IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND FORWARD- THE
RESOURCES ARE REALLY TO HELP
SUPPORT THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES MEDICARE BILLING
OPTION PROGRAM OR WHAT'S KNOWN
AS ELLIE A BOB. I'M DEAD THE
STAFF WILL SPECIFICALLY BE
DOING OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO NOT
PARTICIPATING ELEAZAR ARE
WORKING WITH A VENDOR TO BE TO
DEVELOP A TRANSITION PLAN FOR
THE LONG TERM OUR REGION AND-
TRAINING ACTIVITIES TO DO THAT
REALLY WORKING TO BRING ON
ADDITIONAL ELEAZAR INTO THE L.
A. BACH PROGRAMS- BY THE OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX OF REALLY TRYING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ELEAZAR
PROGRAMS. REACHING MORE
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ADDITIONALLY- WE
WOULD A LOOKS YOU PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTS- THE STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT FIFTEEN ZERO TWO ONE-
WHICH ESSENTIALLY EXPANDED
BENEFITS FOR ANY MEDIC HELP
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS BUT THE CARE
PLAN IT EXPANDED TO DIFFERENT
ALLOW FOR PROVIDER TYPES AND SO
THE STAFF WOULD ALSO BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ELEAZAR OTHERS IN
REGARDS TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
ABOUT LARGE. CHANGE FOR THE
PROGRAM. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. FILAYO
OR IS M. L. A. O. L. NO NO
COMMON REYES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHO ARE YOUR TO BRING
A FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. CAN I SEE LAURIE
ALLEN WAS MY STUDENT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TEN LARA WHEN WERE YOU
GOING TO MAKE A GOOD CHANCE
POLICY CLASS HELLO. TWENTY
ELEVEN NICE TO SEE YOU. I THINK
YOU JUST AGE FOR ME HUGS SORRY
IT'S WRONG IT'S WRONG I WE WENT
OVER AGING EARLIER. BUT YOU
LOOK FANTASTIC. OKAY- ALSO BE A
VERY IMPORTANT WE GET MORE AND
MORE- HELP OUT TO HAVE- OUR
MOST NEEDY KIDS IN SCHOOLS AND
I THINK WE'RE WORKING ON I A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS ON THIS
WILL BE REALLY INTERESTED TO
SEE HOW ALL OF THESE ARE GOING
TO WORK TOGETHER AND NOT BE IN
COMPETITION OR MAKE THINGS MORE
CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE PROJECT.
THAT'S AGES ON BRIEFLY SAY THIS
IS REALLY APPRECIATE THIS. I
REMEMBER LAST YEAR OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE TALK
ABOUT DATING. MYSELF AND
ACTUALLY I DON'T KNOW THAT'S
WHEN YOU'RE TEACHING- WHEN Y. I
REMEMBER CALLING OVER TO THE L.
A. FOLKS AND THE ATS AND
THEY'RE LIKE OH YOU EVEN KNOW
WE EXIST SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS WEEK'S CALIFORNIA BY THE
WAY IS WE WANT STATES WITH THE
LOWEST RATE OF. ONLY A BILLING
GIVEN OUR CITY- IN TERMS OF
BRINGING OUT FEDERAL MATCHING
MONEY TO OUR STATE SO HOPEFULLY
WE WILL AT LEAST TRY TO GET UP
TO WHERE OTHER STATES ARE AND
OUR SCHOOLS COULD TEST AND-
GUESS WHAT THAT'S REALLY USE
THIS THESE HEALTHCARE DOLLARS
THAT THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE WHICH LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH AND OTHER THINGS. IT IN
THE SCHOOL SO I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THIS YOU KNOW BUDGET
WHERE LOOKS LIKE SCHOOL BUT
WE'VE WE'VE OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN RUNNING AT THE- END
OF THINGS- COMPARED OTHER
STATES AND INCLUDING ON OUR
MEDICARE AND ARE SEVERAL MATCH
FOR OUR DAILY A MONEY THROUGH
OUR MEDICAID PROGRAM. SO
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL TURN THIS
AROUND. AND REALLY APPRECIATES
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. I THINK THE
IS A POPULAR ONE EVERYBODY.
OKAY ALRIGHT. HELLO SIX OUR
OFFICE OF MEDICARE IN THE
NATION AND INTEGRATION PROPOSAL.
WE'RE REQUESTING FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS ON SIX HUNDRED IN TWO
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND. TWO
THOUSAND TOTAL FUNDS. FOUR DHC
OX S. OFFICE OF MEDICARE IN THE
NATION INTEGRATION. THE FOCUS
OF THE OFFICES ON PROGRAM AND
BENEFIT IMPROVEMENTS AND MORE
INTEGRATED CARE FOR JULIE HELLO
JIM MEDICARE CAL AND MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES FOR MOST DOOR
WILL WILL BENEFIT. OF THE TWO
SYSTEMS. SEPARATELY AND WITH
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS
SYSTEMS AND- TO PROVIDE ALL.
PERSONS SERVICES WELL. OUR GOAL
IS PART OF GOVERNOR MASTER AND
HE IS- WORK TO MAXIMIZE THE UP.
TO ALSO INTEGRATE SERVICES FOR
DUAL ELIGIBLE AS WELL AS WELL
IMPRECISE CORPORATE UNITIES FOR
ONLY CONSUMERS. THERE WERE
COUPLE OF COURSE ASKED.
TOTALING SUGGESTIONS IN THE
MASTER PLAN. AND IT WILL BE
SHOCKED OVER THE NEXT YEAR AT
LEAST. ALSO COVER TUNES WE'RE
GOING TO FOCUS ON OR BUILDING A
THE CALENDAR WILL CALL FOR
INTEGRATED. HELLO GIGGLES-
EXPANDING THE L. FOR. BENEFITS
IN MEDICARE PLAN. THESE ARE A
LOT OF ON OR- ON. CHANGES BUT I
DON'T REALLY ON. EMPHASIZED VIA
COME IN CALIFORNIA SPACE AND
THESE THE SORTS OF. WE EXPECT
IS HE- REALLY SYMPATHETIC
NATIONAL. IS TO EXPLORE COSTS
FOR- SHARED. WERE WERE ABLE TO
MAKE ALL IMPROVEMENTS IN KEY.
ALL AND THE CHIEFS. LIKE BE IN
A POSITION. SURE SURE RELATION
WITH FEDERAL GARDENS SO- JUDGE
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THIS AND
WE ARE SIX POINT SIX MILLION.
MEDICAL BENEFICIARY ON THIS.
ARAMBULA TO HAVE MILLION. ALSO
MADE A PART OF FINANCE WE HAVE
LOW ALSO THE BALLOT. LMAO BY
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE L. A. WE
RECOGNIZE THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FOR TWO
MEDIC CAL MEDICARE ELIGIBLES-
AND SO I THINK THAT'S ORT OF
INTERESTING RIGHT FRAGMENTATION
IS A WORTHY GOAL WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE HAVE NO SPECIFIC
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. OKAY YEAH
IT IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
WILL WE- AS YOU GO FORWARD MR-
MISTER I BORN MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE STILL KEEPING OUR OF THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING ON THE
FRONT OF OUR MIND TO AS WE LOOK
AT ALL OF THESE THINGS HOW THAT
THEY'VE- HOW THEY FIT. YES WE
CAN JUST KEEP MAKE SURE WE KEEP
OUR FOCUS. HELLO I MEAN I
THINK. LONG THE BOSTON GLOBE
AND- STAKEHOLDERS WILL SORT OF
BE THERE ARE KEY ADVISERS.
GOING FOR. THE YOU DISMISS
COOPER YOU WANTED TO SEVEN THAT
I SAW YOU NODDING YOUR HEAD- NO
I JUST AGREE WITH WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THEM SENSE THE MASTER PLAN AN
AGING HAS BEEN BOTH DEVELOPED
AN OUT AND I KNOW THAT THEY
WERE ALL YOU ENGAGE WITH THEM
HEAVILY IN REGARDS TO ENSURING
THE- OBJECTIVES OF THE MASTER
PLAN OF- ON AGING. WONDERFUL
WONDERFUL OKAY VETERANS. OKAY
MOVING ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN BE
ABLE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EQUITY
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
YES SO THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING NINE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS UP FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY GENERAL FUND-
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND-
AND THEN SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THE
EQUIVALENT OF THREE POSITIONS
AND CONTRACT RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM OR
WHAT'S KNOWN AS B. H. Q. I. P.
AND ESSENTIALLY THE REQUEST IS
TO- HELP BE MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
AND OUNTY DRUG MEDI CAL
PROGRAMS PREPARE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH TELLING. AND
THE FUNDS WILL HELP INCENTIVIZE
PAYMENTS FOR BOTH SYSTEM AND I.
T. CHANGES ARMS OF THIS WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO UPDATE THEIR
CODING SYSTEMS WITHIN THE
COUNTY LEVEL- CLEANING SYSTEMS
AS WELL AS PREPARE FOR ANY
CHANGES AROUND- MEDIC MEDICAL
NECESSITY AND OTHER AT
CRITERIA. AS WELL SUBMITTING
QUALITY DATA TO THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT WE CAN- BUILD OUT OUR
ROBUST BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. BERMAN
ASSEMBLY TELL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME MR SHOOTER. I
THANK YOU COREY C. L. A. L.
WEEK WE RECOGNIZE THAT COUNTIES
ARE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE IN
ORDER TO BRING YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR PRACTICES UP TO SPEED AND
GET READY FOR CALLIN SO WE
HAVE. NO CONCERNS TO RAISE AT
THIS. ALL RIGHT AT. THE MISTER
LABRINTH AND RIBBONS COOPER
WOULD YOU SAY YOU'RE MORE
EXCITED OR MORE FRIGHTENED WITH
THIS BIG THIS BIG CALLIN COMING
YOUR WAY. AND WITH ALL THESE
ALL THESE ENDS THAT HAVE TO BE
TIED UP. PROBABLY THIS IS THE
MOST THRILLING CHANGE. HEALTH
DELIVERY CAMANCHE. YEAH I AGREE
I MEAN IT IT IS VERY COMPLEX
AND IT IS VERY LARGE BUT- I
AGREE IT'S BEEN SOME OF THE
MOST EXCITING WORK I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK ON IN A LONG TIME
AND IT MAKES IT EASY TO DO THIS
JOB. BUT I'D SAY. WE THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK AND WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND. I KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP GETTING WHAT WE'RE
GETTING THAT'S- AND THAT'S
NOBODY'S GIRL. EGGMAN GIPSON
OKAY. NOW ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
ON THEN. SO ISSUE EIGHT- THIS
IS A REQUEST FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING TWO
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
JUST FOR YOUR TWENTY TWO I'M
SORRY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWO POINT ONE FIVE FIVE IN JUST
THE YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. OR THE EQUIVALENT OF FOUR
POSITIONS IN CONTRACT RESOURCES
TO ADMINISTER THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS THE
FUNDING I WOULD BE SHIFTED FROM
THE SEVEN HUNDRED MISSED THAT
BIT SORRY THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND- AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE TO
COVER THE STATE OPERATIONS DO
YOU TO DO THIS- THE STAFF WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
COMMUNICATIONS REGARDING THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL. AS
WELL AS MONITORING THE
EXPENDITURES IN OVERSEEING AND
THE VARIOUS GRANTS WE CURRENTLY
REST MAYBE COULD RECEIVE
ANYWHERE FROM A HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED COUNTY I TRIED
WILL GRANTEES THAT WOULD NEED
TO BE OVERSEEN. WOULD ALSO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY OF THE R.
PHASE- OR TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
CONTRACT THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
BROUGHT ON TO DO THIS WORK AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU WOULD HAVE. ON THE COURT
SHOULD ANYTHING HELLO. THANK
YOU CORPS UCLA- WE COMPLETED
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE BROADER
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTINUE
PROPOSAL A FEW MONTHS AGO AND
ARE NOW ASISTING WE STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES GIVEN THEIR RELATIVE
INEXPERIENCE WITH- YOU KNOW
SORT OF REAL ESTATE
ACQUISITION- ACTIVITIES AND SO
THEREFORE WE DON'T NEED WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONSPECIFIC
CONCERNS. BARTON FINANCED WITH
THE NUMBER TELL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTATIONAL COMMENTS
THINKING. THE DEFENSE. THREE
QUESTION. THREE QUESTION
PERHAPS ONLY OWNERS THE ANSWER
NOT TO THIS- SO CERTAINLY I
MEAN I THINK THIS LOOKS
REASONABLE IT'S TWO POINT TWO
MILLION- THE SEVEN OR FIFTEEN
MILLION BUT IS THERE AN
ASSESSMENT FOR LIKE THE TOTAL
OVERHEAD FOR IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM SO THE SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION HOW MUCH IS THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING FOR THE GRANTS
AND HOW MUCH OF IT'S GOING FOR
THE OVERSIGHT- PORTION. SO WE
HAVEN'T DONE A SPECIFIC
ASSESSMENT OF OVERHEAD PERHAPS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SORT OF
THAT FIGURE. BIG IN FINANCE DO
YOU HAVE A- OVERHEAD IT FIGURE
FOR THE SENATE FIFTY MILLION.
THE CINEMAS HOW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I THINK WHAT I'D SAY
IS THAT WE HAVE CARVED OUT AS
MR PREVENTION SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS
PROVIDE A TCS WITH THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO OVERSEE
THE PROGRAM. AND THEN THE
REMAINING FUNDING WHICH YOU
PROVIDED THE GRASS AT LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO COUNTIES
IF I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR OKAY SO THE TWO POINT
TWO MILLION FOR OVER THREE
YEARS SAYS THAT THIS IS THAT
THE SIX AND A HALF MILLION OR
IS THAT SIX HALF MILLION A
SEPARATE AMOUNT IN ADDITION.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO. OUR THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO THAT SIX AND
A HALF MILLION. LET ME BE A
LITTLE MORE CLEAR SO IT'S SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION THAT IS
CARVED OUT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT AND
THAT IS. SPLITUP OVER THREE
YEARS SO THE FIRST PORTION IS A
TWO POINT TWO MILLION. OKAY
RIGHT SO THE ODDS OF THIS
REQUEST OF THIS REQUEST IS THE
ONLY OVERHEAD FOR THE SIX
HUNDRED FOR THE S. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY ALL RIGHT. THAT SO
THAT'S A VERY LOW OVERHEAD RATE
OKAY. THANK YOU. I JUST DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THIS WAS ON TOP OF
SOMETHING ELSE- SYSTEM. OKAY
OKAY. THANK YOU. OKAY MOVING ON
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. EIGHT SO
WHAT I WILL PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON- SOME OF THE JOINT AS BEING
FINANCED OF LETTERS AND THEN
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
CORRECTIONS- SO FOR THE
STATEWIDE VERIFICATION HUB
STAFF AND TECHNICAL RESOURCES.
I'M DH CS IS REQUESTING
APPROVAL FOR RESOURCES FOR I'M
CONVERTING ONE LIMITED TERM-
HEALTH PROGRAM SPECIALIST
POSITION. TO A PERMANENT
POSITION- THAT BE EXPENDITURE
REQUEST IS APPROX ME SEVENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND A HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND TOTAL
FUNDS- WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT WE ALSO REQUESTING A ONE
YEAR CONTRACT FUNDING FOR FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND. UP EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND TOTAL FUN I'M
WITHIN OUR ENTERPRISE
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES AREA. OF
THE ONE YEAR CONTRACT FUNDING
WILL BE USED TO SECURE
CONSULTANT SERVICES TO PROVIDE
PROJECT MANAGEMENT FOR DH CS
RELATED TO THE STATE
VERIFICATION HUB. THE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WILL
IMPROVE NECESSARY ALTERNATIVES-
ANALYSIS FOR FUTURE CONNECTION
TO WORK- RELATED IN THIS AREA.
ADDITIONALLY WE JUST MAKE SURE.
OF ALL THE PIECES I'M UNDER THE
ANNUAL HEALTHCARE SERVICES
HEALTH PLAN- EQUITY AND QUALITY
REVIEWS OF DCS IS REQUESTING TO
POSITIONS IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS- THAT WITH
WHICH OF THE HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND IS GENERAL FUND-
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND A TOTAL FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER- DCS
BZP REQUESTED ADDITIONAL-
STAFFING IN ORDER TO. MAKE SURE
WE ARE WORKING ON ALL OF THE
EQUITY WORK WITH THEIR DNA C.
PARTNERS- WE WOULD BE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN REGARDS
TO THE QUALITY METRICS AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES ALSO
ENSURING THAT IS NOT
DUPLICATIVE OR CONTRADICTORY IN
REGARDS TO THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. WE WOULD BE PROVIDING
AND VARIOUS INFORMATION THROUGH
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
QUALITY COMMITTEES THAT WE
WOULD BE PARTICIPATING ON WE
ALSO WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING AND DEVELOPMENT AND
DOCUMENTS FOR DH CS REPORTS
TEMPLATES. EVALUATION PLANS ON
THE SPECIALLY FOR THE COALS
PLANTS WERE NOT CURRENTLY
COVERED. BY D. MHC IN REGARDS
TO LICENSING TO MAKE SURE WE
LINK UP A MANAGER THAT WE ARE
IN LOCKSTEP WITH THEIR PROPOSAL
WE ALSO WOULD BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR EACH YOU ARE
AU OVERSIGHT TEAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE NOT DOING DIFFERENT.
DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS ON THAT
FRONT. IN REGARDS TO- THAT THE
TECHNICAL- CORRECTIONS. IT DOWN
THAT PIECES WALL FOR EQUITY
DASHBOARD DH YES IS REQUESTING
A REDUCTION IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN- THOUSAND DOLLARS AS
THE FIFTY NINE THOUSAND WHICH
IS GENERAL FUND ON IT IF THE
EIGHT FEDERAL FUNDS TO ALIGN
WORKLOAD FUNDING WITH THE
POSITIONS IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ANIMATION ADMINISTRATIONS
EQUITY DASHBOARD PROPOSAL THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS WERE
REQUIRED TO TRUE A LOT OF THE
INCLUDED SALARIES TO REFLECT
THOSE DESCRIBED IN THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WAS
RELEASED IN. JANUARY
ADDITIONALLY UNDER THE MEDICAID
ENTERPRISE SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
A DH YES REQUEST A REDUCTION IN
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THE
WORTHY OF ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION I'M IN AN INCREASE IN
FEDERAL FUNDING EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION TO UPDATE THE FUNDING
SPLIT IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
MEDIKAL IN A PRIZE SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL AT THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT WAS
REQUIRED DUE TO THE TIMING
RELATED TO WIN THE BCP WAS
SUBMITTED. AND THE SPECIAL
PROJECT REPORT FOR THE FEDERAL
DRIVE WAS COMPLETED AS A WE
HAVE A CENTURIES SWITCHED FROM
A SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FEDERAL FIND GENERAL FUND TO A
NINETY- PERCENT FEDERAL FUND
10% GENERAL FUND- HENCE IS WHY
WE ARE INCREASING OUR FEDERAL
PARTICIPATION IN THIS REQUEST
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. HEARD THE PUBLIC
FINANCE. HER SPEND A FINANCED
THAT. OKAY ILIO. A BEEN WITH
THE L. A. IN THAT PUBLICATION
ARE THIS YEAR SPECIFICALLY
REALLY RELATE TO CALAMP- WE
WERE IN SUPPORT OF A QUALITY
MEASUREMENT AND MEDICARE AND
STRATIFIED THESE MEASURE BY
VARIOUS CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS
RACE AGEN AND OTHER FACTORS AND
SO WE DO- WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GENERAL
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE EQUITY IN
QUALITY REPORTING AS AS THEY'RE
DOING TO THROUGH TWO OF THE
ITEMS UNDER THIS THIS ISSUE AND
WOULD JUST RECOMMEND CONTINUED
MONITORING OF THOSE PROCESS
SEES AS THIS SPECIFIC QUALITY
MEASURES ARE ARE- DEVELOPED AND
DISORDER AND REPORTED. OVER
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK GOD. THANK YOU I
JUST APPRECIATE THAT THE PART
OF THIS IS ACTUALLY THE WORK
WITH DO YOU NEED C. AROUND-
THEIR EQUITY MEASURES I WOULD
CRY JUST- CENTER DIFFERENT
AGENCY JUST PERHAPS A- BRIEFLY
SAY THAT- ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DO WHEN WE TALK TO TEAMMATES
SEE ABOUT IT IS BEING SURE THAT
WE'RE COLLECTING THE KIND OF
DEMOGRAPHIC BASELINE DATA SO WE
CAN IDENTIFY DISPARITIES SO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE ISSUE
ABOUT TRYING TO COLLECT. DATA
ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY DISPARITIES
FOR LGBT Q. CLIENT-
BENEFICIARIES- ALSO- CERTAINLY
FOR THE API CAUCUS HAVING
DISAGGREGATED DATA IS GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T HE CAN'T STUDY SOMETHING
YOU CAN'T SEE SO WE DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF FORMATION AND THEN
ALSO APPRECIATE THE MEAT C.
SAID THEY WANT TO USE A LOT OF
EXISTING. DATA COLLECTION WHICH
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND BUT-
THAT WE STEP BACK AND DO LOOK
AT FROM AN EQUITY STANDPOINT IF
THERE ARE BASICALLY GAPS IN
EXISTING DATA COLLECTION THAT
WOULD NOT ALLOW US TO SEE
ISSUES THAT WOULD AFFECT EQUITY
SO- SO I GUESS I'LL MAKE THE
SAME APPEAL TO. THE HC ESSES
YOU'RE A LINING UP WITH THE
INMATES SEE AND LOOKING AT
THESE EQUITY ISSUES- BUT- AND
THE HOPE THAT- YOU TO YOU CAN
PARTNER ON THAT AND CERTAINLY I
KNOW THAT US RUNNING THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM- EQUITY ISSUES
AND SPERRY'S OR EVEN. EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT- FOR A PROGRAM THAT
SERVICES ARE. THE MISSISSIPPI
H. IN OUR STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. WE THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON ALL THESE
PROPOSALS. IT IS A COMPLICATED
THING WE'RE ALL TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER HERE AND- GLAD TO HAVE
YOU AS PARTNERS IN DOING THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU- WE GONNA DO PUBLIC
COMMENTS FIRST RIGHT OKAY. SO
NOW WE ARE GOING TO- WE ARE
HOPING WE HAVE A MODERATOR ON
THE LINE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS NOW BEFORE WE
MOVED TO A SERIES OF VOTES. ON
TO CONCLUDE OUR DAY- MODERATOR
YOU ON THERE. YES I'M HERE
THANK YOU OKAY CAN YOU TELL US
HOW MANY COLORS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWENTY
THREE CALLERS IN Q. TWENTY
FIVE. OKAY AND THERE THEY COME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
LET'S PROCEED. OKAY AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
ACTIVE TIME. WE'LL START WITH
MY NUMBER ONE SIXTY NINE POINT
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO. HELLO. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY-
GOOD AFTERNOON STATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
COLONEL MARK I AM A MEMBER OF
BUTTE COUNTY I CAN'T SAID THAT
BADGER COMMITTEE WESTERN
SERVICE BROKERS ASSOCIATION
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS AND THE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
BRIDENSTINE'S PROVIDED CAN BE
COUNTY I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BUTTE BARGAINING TEAM. I
WANT TO BRING CLARIFICATION THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE SEGMENTS
REPRESENTED OUR BARGAINING
EFFORTS IN BUTTE COUNTY WE HAVE
NOT HAD A CONTRACT FOR EIGHT
YEARS THE COUNTY HAS OFFERED TO
GIVE US A PAY INCREASE OF
TWENTY FIVE SPENT BUT IF WE IF
WE ACCEPTED THAT THEY WOULD CUT
THE BUN THE FUNDING FROM
HEALTHCARE TO COVER THE
INCREASE SO THEY OFFERED TO
ELIMINATE HEALTHCARE FOR FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY COULD
COVER THAT. 25% PAY INCREASE.
HE SAID. DOESN'T HAVE AN ANSWER
WE ARE AT THE MERCY OF THE
COUNTY- FOR THE LAST TWO WEEKS
HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF NUMEROUS
OTHER VIOLATIONS BY NUMEROUS
RESIDENTS OF THE COUNTY THE
STATE NEEDS TO HOLD THESE BAD
ACTORS ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE. IT'S
BEEN NINE YEARS SINCE WE HAVE
HAD A PAY INCREASE BESIDES THE
MINIMUM WAGE GOING UP BUT THE
COUNTY PAYS NOTHING TOWARDS
THAT. WE ARE WHAT WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO GET THE COUNTY
SIMPLY STATES NO NO FOR NINE
YEARS YES NO WAY TO TREAT CARE
GIVERS AND CLIENT. I JUST THAT
PROVIDERS ROUTINELY SENT TO
WORKERS DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
ARE HE SENT TO WORK AS WE WERE
EXTENSION WORKERS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND WILL REMAINYOU
SENT TO WORK WITH AFTER THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE WEEK STAND AND
THINK OF THE LIVES OF THE- MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. I CHECKED THAT
PROVIDERS ARE MAKING MINIMUM
WAGE FOR THE CARE THEY PROVIDE
FOR THEIR CLIENTS. BUTTE COUNTY
WHERE A LIVING WAGE IS OVER
TWENTY DOLLARS WE HAVE NOT SEEN
A WAGE INCREASE FOR MORE THAN
SIX YEARS I AM IN SUPPORT OF
IMPOSING THAT 10% PENALTY ON
TOWNS LIKE YOU THAT BOB THAT BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE. IN GOOD
FAITH WITH THAT. THE LAST TIME
YOU WHICH ACCORDING AGREEMENT
WITH I CHECKED THAT WAS INTO.
AND FOURTEEN. THE STATE AUTO
WRITTEN BY THAT OVER FOR
HUNDRED I. SAYS BUT- WHICH DID
YEARS AGO WITH CARE EACH MY
THANK YOU COUNTY. HI BECAUSE I
AS PER AS WE JUST LOW. I WOULD
LIKE TO DO WHAT ONLY TO RE
OFFERING AND BENEFIT INCREASE
SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
TEMPEST. FISCAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GONNA MOVE REMOVE ON OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL WE
DON'T DEFINITELY KNOW THAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
I'LL BE HAPPY AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DESMOND PRESCOTT I AM AND I
JUST AS PROVIDERS FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY- I HSS
PROVIDERS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PAID JUST OVER MINIMUM WAGE
UNLESS WE IMPOSE A TEN PERCENT.
PENALTY ON COUNTIES WHO REFUSE
TO BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. A
RECENT REPORT BY THE STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT I AGENTS AS
CARE GIVERS MAKE ONLY FIFTY
EIGHT PERCENT. OF THE LIVING
WAGE STATE WHY FOR THAT REASON
I SUPPORT THE 10% PENALTY ON
COUNTIES WHO FELL TO BARGAIN
WITH US THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE SEVENTY NINE-
LIGHTED. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS I'M KELLY BROOKS AND I
BE COMMENTING ON GENERAL
SEVERAL ITEMS THANK YOU FOR THE
FINANCE INVESTMENT AND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAM
FIRST URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF RETAINING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TOOL THE
CURRENT LAW. BOTH THE 10% OVER
THREE YEARS TOOL AND THAT YOU
THIS THING 35% COUNTY 65% STATE
SHARING RATIOS HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL LOCAL
BARGAINING ADDITIONALLY I WOULD
NOTE FOR THIS CAN MADE UP ON
THE INTERCONNECTOR I AGES OF
WAGES AND BENEFITS NINETEEN
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT WHICH
ALSO FUNDS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES SHARING
RATIOS WERE TO FLIP 265% COUNTY
35% STATE WOULD HAVE HUGE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING JUST OF
THOSE PROGRAMS BASED INCREASED
DEMAND AS THEY RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC. UTC OPPOSES IMPOSING
A FISCAL PENALTY TEN TIMES
HIGHER THAN THE ONE I'M IN LAW
PREVIOUSLY UNCOUNTED RELATED
TIED TO SUCH BARGAINING AS
OUTLINED BY ME. SECOND ON THE
FAMILIES FIRST PRESERVATION
SERVICES ACT THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SUPPORT HELLO TO INVEST FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS IN THAT IN. TWENTY
TO ONE TWENTY TWO. AND A
HUNDRED MILLION AND THAT YEARS
TO STRENGTHEN FAMILIES. TOLD
FROM ABUSE NEGLECT AND PREVENT
AND TREAT IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. THIRD IN THE URBAN
COUNTY OF ADVENTURE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORT
FLEXIBLE FUNDING POOL O BE
USED FOR COUNTY ADMINISTER
HOUSING PROGRAM. AS PROPOSED BY
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. FOR THE URBAN
COUNTY SUPPORT THAT FUNDING
REQUEST FOR THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
OF PUBLIC CONSPIRATORS. FINALLY
URBAN COUNTIES THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
PRINTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR. INVESTMENT AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS CAPTAIN
MUST WORK ON THE HELP OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER- OF THE YEAR TO SPEAK
QUICKLY ON ISSUE FIVE BE PART
OF. OUR AGE AND ON TWO FOR ALL
ARE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT
ONE IN TEN WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL AID. TO THE
ASSISTANCE THESE INDIVIDUALS
OVER REPRESENTED IN AGRICULTURE
MEAT DAIRY PRODUCTION FOOD
SERVICE AND GROCERY RETAIL JOBS
PUT FOOD ON THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA TABLE. ENDING THE
UNNECESSARY EXCLUSION IN THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD ACCESS PROGRAM
WHICH IS A PROGRAM BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS URGENTLY
NEEDED STEP TOWARD A MORE
EQUITABLE SAFETY NET AND WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL FAMILIES WHO
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME HAVE BEEN
NUTRITION THEY NEED TO BE
HEALTHY AND THRIVE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAFF TO THIS
ISSUE WITH. BUDGET PROCESS WAS
FORCED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COURT PLEASE. ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE OPEN. WHAT
CAN YOU DO MY NAME IS JOHN
PRATT I'M AFRAID REFERENCE AND
GREAT CLASSICAL. THE CITY OF
WILMINGTON. I'M NOT AND- A
COMIC BACK HERE BUT WE TO SEE
ME. I CONTENT TO PROVIDE QUOTE
FROM IT OR AND FIVE ALL I COULD
DYING POINT B. YOUR BILL
LANGUAGE ELIMINATE ALL SESSION
THANK ALL THREAD THE BY THE ACT.
MY OWN BROTHER NOT ARE BOTH OF
YOU THINK YOU FOR CENTER FIVE.
AND NOT IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES. WHAT DO YOU. IT WILL
NOT BE ENOUGH FOR MY FAMILY.
WHEN MANY FAMILIES I'VE BEEN
DOING ABOUT THE PUBLIC THE LONG
AFTER. THE FIRST. WORK HAPPY.
OF MY COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE JUST LIKE
TO MADE TO THE FORMER BERMAN
WHAT MANY NOW AND. INTO THE
FUTURE. I DO NOT THINK A THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR NOT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON ITEM
FIVE ANNIE AND CHRIS BURNS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BOYS AND
GIRLS REPUBLIC SERVING OVER
HUNDREDS OF THIS YEAR TO TWO
YEARS FROM A DOZEN COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THAT'S
YOUR GP'S ARE THE I. C. U. OF
THE CCR CONTINUUM PROVIDING
CRITICAL THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
NEEDING THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CARE THAT ADDRESSES THEIR
TRAUMA AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
IN A TEMPORARY RESIDENTIAL
SETTING. MUCH LIKE ICU NURSES
AND DOCTORS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC USE NEEDS WERE
EXTRAORDINARY AND HINGED ON THE
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT OF THIS
YEAR TO BE STAFF COME INTO WORK
EACH DAY IN FEAR FOR THEIR OWN
HEALTH TO PROVIDE THE CARE
NECESSARY TO ASSIST THESE
TRAUMATIZED GIVE. THAT DAILY
COMMITMENT CAME UNDER
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL EXPENSE
THAT POSES.
A THREAT TO OUR
OPERATIONS WHEN TREATMENT MADE.
PERSIST HERE TO FACE FOR OVER
NINETEEN RELATED COSTS AND
ENSURE THE ONGOING STABILITY
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF YOUTH
FAMILIES AND STAFF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
AN APPLICATION ON BEHALF OF THE
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP WE
WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
ON PARK EIGHT HUNDRED YES
THAT'S UNDER ISSUE FIVE EIGHT
TO PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTERED CHILD
WELFARE PREVENTION SERVICES. BY
INVESTING ONGOING GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS CALIFORNIA BOTH LOCAL
LEADER CONSERVATIVE REPORT
WHICH WILL BRING YOU CAN
DOWNLOAD THAT WILL PREVENT THE
NEED FOR FOSTER CARE ENTRIES
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. THE BILL TO
LEAVE EIGHTY DSS ISSUE FOR
WHERE WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
THE CANADIAN FROM THE PREVENT
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS LIKE AN F. P. WHICH
HAS BEEN RANKED AS WELCOME
COURTED BY THE TITLE COREY
PREVENTION CERTAIN CLEARING
HOUSE. THE ONLY WELCOME PART OF
PROGRAM IN THE CLEARING HOUSE
BEGIN PRENATALLY IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE UPSTREAM OUTCOME TO
KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER AND OUT
OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND IF HE IS
CURRENTLY NOT IN THE DROP
OPPOSE ON THE PREVENTION PLAN
WE HOPE TO GAIN SUPPORT FOR
SERVICES LIKE OURS NOT PLAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE THREE
YEAR LINE NOW OPEN. ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DANIELLE CONNOR AND I'M
MAGIC BUS PROVIDER FROM KERN
COUNTY AND TWENTY NINETEEN THE
COST OF LIVING IN KERN COUNTY
WAS EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AND EIGHTY
FOUR CENTS AN HOUR BUT I JUST
THAT'S PROVIDERS MAY JUST
TWELVE. WE ENCOURAGE COUNTY
HAVE BEEN MAKING THE STATE'S
MINIMUM WAGE FOR THREE AND A
HALF YEARS NOW. THAT'S HOW LONG
WE'VE BEEN WITHOUT A CONTRACT.
I SUPPORT GETTING A 10% THE
COMPOUND TEACH COUNTY BUT KERN
WHO BILL THE BARGAIN WITH US.
AND ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT THE
SPEAKER FROM CSAC I THINK HIS
NAME WAS GERMAN WHO SPOKE
EARLIER AND REFERENCE KERN
COUNTY. NEGOTIATIONS HAD IT
WRONG. I AM AND I CHáVEZ
WORKER FROM KERN COUNTY AND A
MEMBER OF THE BARGAINING TEAM.
AND I'M NOT SURE IF HE WAS
THERE BUT- OUR TEAM HAS BEEN
THERE FOR TWO YEARS ASKING FOR
A MODEST INCREASE OUR WAGES.
KERN COUNTY HAS NOT NEGOTIATED
IN GOOD FAITH. HOW CAN THEY
CLAIM THAT THEY PUT A
REASONABLE OFFER ON WAGES. ON
THE TABLE WHEN OPERATE THEIR
OWN FOR YEARS NEVER TO GO SHE
ATION. AND WHEN THEY MADE AN
OFFER OF TWENTY FIVE CENTS
APPARENTLY JUST THEY COULD
CLAIM BARGAINING IN GOOD FAITH.
THEY QUICKLY RESCINDED THE
OFFER INCLUDING THOSE ON
BECAUSE IT. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THAT WE NEEDED HELP
THE MOST. WE STILL NEEDED TO GO
TO WORK AND RESTORE LIVES TO
TAKE CARE OF. OUR CLIENTS FOR
MINIMUM WAGE. AND NO BENEFITS-
BECAUSE KERN COUNTY CLAIM TO
HAVE THE ARAB FUND. FOR US TO
YEAH NUMBER YEAH AND ON IT. YET
THEY GOT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
KOBE RELEASED AND YET. THEY
KEEP FINDING MONEY THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC UNDER OTHER THINGS.
THEY WANT TO FIND LIKE A SHARPS
BUDGET AND JAIL. HOW CAN PART
HOUSE BARGAINING IN GOOD FAITH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MALONATE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK TO A COUPLE OF
ITEMS- I DON'T ORDER TO SIX
ZERO IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AT ISSUE
THREE. WE SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND HOPE THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERS EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR AGES TWENTY.
BEFORE AND ALSO WANTED TO TOUCH
ON ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
ISSUE NUMBER THREE- WE SUPPORT.
THE DIFFICULT PENALTY FOR I'D
COUNTY FAMILY BARGAIN IN GOOD
FAITH AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT FIFTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT- SHARE
COSTS- AND ALSO TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. WE SUPPORT THE
RESTORATION OF I. H. AT AT OUR
SERVICE HOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. ONE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LED THE SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA HEY. THE
FIRST TWO ITEMS ARE ITEMS TWO
AND THREE UNDER FORTY TO SIXTY
ELIGIBILITY RESTORATION FOR
IMMIGRATION- REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND DELAY OF
REPEAL OF BENEFITS- IN ITEM
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ELIMINATION
OF PROGRAM SUSPENSION FOR ALL
PROGRAMS INCLUDING FIRST AND
THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THEN UNDER
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY DISCUSSION
ITEMS I'D LIKE TO REGISTER OUR
SUPPORT. FOR BE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SPRING B. C. P. STATEWIDE
VERIFICATION HAVE NUMBER FOUR
THE C. W. D. A PROPOSAL FOR
BUDGET AUGMENTATION. FOR AFFECT
PSA. FIVE A TRIAL WELL AND- AND
NUMBER FIVE FEET STRENGTHENING
THE SAFETY NET FOR CAO WORK AND
NUMBER SEVEN- DIE HOUSING
PROPOSAL ALSO- PROPOSED BY
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTOR SAYS
THE ASIAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. IT'S AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS CALL MORTAL MEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN THE DRAFTING A
FEW ITEMS DISCUSSED TODAY I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONTINUED IMPORTANCE OF EQUITY
CENTER TO HELP WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND INNOVATIVE IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS MOST MARGINALIZED
CHILDREN. ONE ENGINE THAT ANY
ISSUE THREE WILL SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF. MEDICAID HOW
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ON MENTAL HEALTH WE ARE
PROUD TO PROPOSE INVESTMENTS
THAT SUPPORT THE WHOLE CHILD
APPROACH IS TO THEIR HEALTH
WELLBEING AND EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS. SO THERE IS MORE TO BE
DONE PARTICULARLY TO ENSURE
THAT INVESTMENTS IN MENTAL
HEALTH BEGAN IN THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND THAT LOCAL
SCHOOLS IN ADDITION TO COUNTY
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL CAPACITY NECESSARY TO
PARTNER WITH LOCAL HEALTH PLAN.
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
LONG TERM. FULLY IMPLEMENTED
SCHOOL BASED MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARINO MONTENEGRO I AM
A FOURTEEN YEAR I JUST PROVIDER
FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AND I
URGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT
IMPOSING A 10% PENALTY ON
COUNTIES WHO REFUSED TO COME TO
A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT BUT I JUST PROVIDERS.
THE LEGISLATION ENACTING AN
ANNUAL 10% PENALTY IT ENSURES
FULL COMPLIANCE AND A
FOUNDATION OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN REACHING BEAR I HSS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
WITHIN A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME. CONTRA WORKERS NEED TO BE
RECOGNIZED AND TREATED
ESSENTIAL MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY. THAT
ENABLE DISABLE CHILDREN IN
OLDER ADULTS TO REMAIN AT HOME.
AT THE SAME WORKERS ARE
INDIRECTLY PROTECTING OUR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
HOSPITALS FROM BECOMING
OVERWHELMED DURING THIS
ENDEMIC. BECAUSE NO MATTER
WHICH SIDE OF THE BARGAIN TABLE
YOU'RE ON COGNITIVE AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES ALONG
WITH SECONDARY ILLNESSES LEAVES
NO ROOM FOR NEGOTIATION. AND
CAN STRIKE ANYONE AT ANY TIME.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- IN
REFERENCE TO PART EIGHT UNDER
ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY- THE CARD
REGARDING NUMBER FOUR FIVE A
AND FIVE BE REGARDING NUMBER
FOUR. ON ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR SUPERVISORS SUPPORT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION BUDGET AUGMENTATION
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ADDITION WE
HAVE APPLIED OUR RESPONSE TO
THE PLAN FOR THE FEDERAL FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROACTIVE AND PREVENTIVE IN
PROTECTING CHILDREN- THE
INTERNSHIP WITH THE- I
REGARDING FIVE EIGHT WE ARE
SUPPOSE OF THE COUNTY WORKER
DIRECTORS. RECOMMENDATION IN
ADDITION TO ITEM FIVE B. WE
SUPPORT S. B. FOUR SIX FOUR AND
FUNDS FOR THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING CARE OF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MONICA CALLED PUBLIC POLICY
OFFICER WITH CONSPECIFIC
OFFENDERS CHILDREN FAMILY
LOOKING AT THE VENTURA AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. I'M
CALLING IN THIS AFTERNOON TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL PUT FORTH TODAY BY
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. ITEM
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY ISSUE FRIDAY
DISCUSSED EARLIER ON URGING
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
PROTECT THE STABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST NEEDS
FOSTER YOUTH AND THE STAFF AT
THE POINT THEM IN PROVIDING
DESPERATELY NEEDED COVERED
COMPLETELY. FOR SHORT TERM
THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM. AT YOUR CONVENIENCE ON
INTERSCOPE CONTENT OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM COULD
FOSTER YOUTH REQUIRING A HIGH
LEVEL OF CARE THAT ADDRESSES
BOTH THEIR TRAUMA AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. WITH THE GOAL OF
STABILIZING AND GOING BACK TO
TRANSITION TO HOME CARE WE ARE
ASKING THAT YOU PRIORITIZE THE
NEED TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND STABILITY OF THE
HIGHER THE FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
SOUTHWEST SUPPORT THEM BY
PROVIDING DESPERATELY NEEDED
OKAY COOLEY CORRECT YOU HAVE TO
KEEP. WE ALSO. REQUEST THAT THE
COURT THE FUNDING. HE DID
DURING CREATURE CARE AGE
STRUCTURE WORKER. AND THE RATE
SO THAT WE CAN REDUCE FACT. AND
HELP YOU THE CHIEF. LOSING A
CLOSE OF ONE DESCRIBED INSTRUCT.
WELL UP. INCREASES THE COMICS.
BY FEDERAL THEM BACK TO CLOSELY
CONTINUITY IN CULTURE WHERE
CREATE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP. I
THINK WE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
FROM UNIFICATION IN ADOPTION.
OUR WE LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ON COURT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIX COLOR
PLEASE. TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE THEREMIN
THINKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO
THREE ISSUES ALL OF THE
UNIVERSAL- BROWN THE FIRST
STRONG SUPPORT IN PART EIGHT OF
THE AGENDA FOR STAKEHOLDER
ISSUE. NUMBER THREE THE IN
PROPOSED INVESTMENT FOR PUBLIC
GUARDIAN PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS
AND PUBLIC CONCERN WORKERS WE
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THAT IN
THE AGENDA IN PART BE- WE HAVE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE EMERALD
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. STAFFING
REQUESTS FROM DHS TO IMPLEMENT
THE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
OF COURSE WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR- THE- LITTLE OVER
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT FUNDING
BUT- IT IS HAVING ADEQUATE
STAFF TO OVERSEE THE DISPERSION
OF THE FUNDING AND OVERSIGHT IS
VERY IMPORTANT WITH THE COURT
THAT. WE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE DHS REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
CONTINUE ON THE PROJECT WHILE
THE ITSELF IS NOT THE FIRST
CHOICE IN- OUR- MINISTRY IN A
REAL. ESTATE DATE PROGRAM HAS.
ENGINE I THINK THE WE THINK
THAT HAVE- ADDITIONAL AND TECH
GROUP WILL MAKE THIS WORK
pTHANK YOU. I DON'T THINK YOU
VERY MUCH NO COLOR. TWO FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
THE CHILD'S FAMILY SERVICES
THANK YOU SENATORS WILL STAR
FOR YOUR HARD WORK TODAY WE
URGE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT CODE RELIEF FOR
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS AS
DISCUSSED IN ISSUE FIVE EIGHT
PART AB A GENDER. UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
S. C. R. T. P. AS ARTISTS
CENTRAL COMPONENT OF THE
CONTINUOUS PROVIDING A CRITICAL
INTERVENTION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WHO NEED A HIGH LEVEL OF CARE
THAT ADDRESSES BOTH THEIR
TRAUMA AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. IS YOUR TEEPEES HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO MANAGE IT THE BILL
WOULD BE AN UNCERTAINTY THAT
THE CO THAT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
CREATED FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND
THE YOUTH THEY SERVE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN LOST
REVENUES AND COSTS. ARE PUTTING
THEIR OPERATIONS ADDRESS. WE
ARE URGE MEMBERS SUPPORT. THE
LANG IT IS NUMBERS. I PAR A AND
TO SUPPORT. IN THE RATES FOR
FOSTER AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE SOCIAL WORKERS CARE 41100%
OF USED IN INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE. AND STUDIES SHOW
THAT FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOU
ACHIEVE PERMANENCY SEVENTY
FIVE. PERCENT OF THE TIME WITH
ONE SOCIAL WORKER I'M NOT DROPS
23% WITH MORE THAN THREE. WELL
ACTUALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER EACH. IN PART B. OF THE
AGENDA UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THIS
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT IN OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON
AS A SPECIAL TO BUILD OUT
COMMUNITY BASED CARE AND
SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY
THIS INVESTMENT WILL HELP
COUNTIES IN THEIR COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDERS DEVELOP CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL UNITS WELLNESS
CENTERS HERE RESIDENTS IN OTHER
LONGER TERM. TREATMENT AND
REHABILITATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CHILDREN AND ADULTS WHO
NEED THESE SERVICES. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT OUR
COMMUNITY BASED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. TO MEET THE
INCREASED NEEDS FOR CHILDREN
AND ADULTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TWO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WENDY ****
REPRESENTING HATHAWAY SYCAMORES
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE OERATE BOTH THAT SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
AND AN ACT OF FAITH THE GARDEN
PARTY AGENDA ISSUE. ITEM FIVE
AS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR CRITICAL COLLUDED EARLY FOR
ASK YOUR GP SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND STABILITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT HIGHS. AFTER
YEARS AND OUR STAFF WHO ARE
SERVING AND CARING. FOR THEM
DURING THE SEASON. SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWO OR AT R. T. P. ALLOW
OF WE HAVE A CREW CLASS. ONE
DOLLAR IN RELATED X. NOTABLY
PERHAPS JUST PAY PPVS TEMPORARY
LODGING AN ADDITIONAL CLEANING
AND SANITATION SUPPLIES. OUR
ORGANIZATION IS ALSO ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER
RATE TO REDUCE TURNOVER AND
INCREASE PERMANENCY FOSTER. AND
LASTLY WE WANT TO CONVEY OUR
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM TO
ADDRESS THE GAP. JUMPER BOTH
ADULTS AND CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA DRAFTING DRAFTING A
FEW ITEMS FROM TODAY FIRST RULE
COUNTY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
PRESERVE AYE H. AYE FEDERAL
AGENTS CENTERS. INCLUDING A 10%
OVER A THREE YEAR TOOL IN
KEEPING THE SHERRY SHARING
RATIO FOR AYE H. AYE FAST WAGES
THAT 5% STATE 35% COUNTY.
SECOND REAL COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSED ANY DIFFICULT PENALTY
IN STATUTE RELATED TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND I
EACH OTHER BACK THIRD IT WILL
CARRY SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. FOR
COUNTY ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION OF REALISTIC
AFTER TO EXPAND THE COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTINUUM
INCLUDING B. H. VEHICLES ARE
PARKED FOR AN INCREDIBLE
TREATMENT. PLANTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE.
TWO OH EIGHT YOUR MIND NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
WENT AWAY WITH THE WESTERNS ON
LAW AND POVERTY RELATED TO VOTE
ONLY ITEMS WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE LEADERSHIP EXAMPLE
KALPETTA CAL SENIOR GUARD WITH
THE IMMIGRATION STATUS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO EXPAND TO ALL REGARDLESS OF
AGE WE OFFER SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE ON
THAT ACCOUNT PROP FIFTY SIX
SUSPENSION. UNDER DISCUSSION
ITEMS WITH SUPPORT RESOURCES
FOR THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
WE PROCUREMENT AND ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE BEST
PRACTICE. YES THAT ARE
REGULARLY PROCUREMENT PROCESS
AN ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT QUALITY
AND ACT IT'S QUITE YEAR GET
CLIENTS MUST MEET WE APPRECIATE
THE DEPARTMENT COMMITMENT TO
HAVE A BLAST A COLD ACOSTA
NOBODY HAS. EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO. AFTER MANAGED CARE
MODEL ANYTHING VERY
DESTRUCTIBLE PLANNED AND LARGE.
PLEASED TO PROPOSAL TO GO DOWN.
MANY AT DEMOCRATIC SAN DIEGO TO
TWO PLANT WILL REQUIRE YOU TO
GET TO. PLANNING PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING. WE SET THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
MEDICARE IN. AND INTEGRATION
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
BUILDING OFF LESSONS LEARNED
FROM. I FOR THE CALENDAR ALSO
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF THE
ON BUTTON AND TO MY FAMILY
INVOLUNTARY ENROLLMENT PROCESS
THE CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
ONLINE NETWORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
JOHNSON JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF A COALITION OF MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ORGANIZATION
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH TO EXTEND THE INFANT
SACRAMENTO- TO THE SEVENTH
EIGHTH AND NINTH MONTH OF THE-
FOSTER YOUTH- PREGNANCY I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DANIELLE ONE DRAW WITH CHILDREN
NOW COLLEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR CWD A PROPOSAL FOR
PREVENTION SERVICES LISTED IN
ISSUE FIVE EIGHT- WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE ELIMINATION OF ALL
PROGRAM SUSPENSIONS INCLUDING
FOR THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM AND OTHER PROGRAMS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS PATRICIA LOWE ERA AND
INVENTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CYCLING
COUNTY OF THE NORTH STATE- I
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND TO
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS AND
ATTENDEES I APPRECIATE THE TIME
FOR. LIMITATION OF WHY I'M HERE.
WE WANTED FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE A SMALL COUNTY
OF 2800035% OF OUR FAMILIES
THAT HAVE CHILDREN NEWBORN TO
TWO YEARS OLD ALL WITHIN BAKER
AND PULL AT. AND DIAPER WHITE.
IN FACT. ADDITIONAL CHILDREN GO
UNDER OUR CARE ARE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN THAT ARE ALSO
AT OLDER AGES BUT ALSO IN
DIAPERS AND PULL UP. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE KNOW THAT
SIX THOUSAND DIAPERS ARE USED
PER CHILD IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS AT THE BODY TRAINING AGE.
ONE INTO PARENTS HAVE REPORTED
IN OUR LOCAL AND NOW IT SAYS
THAT THEY GIVE UP FOOD AND
OTHER NECESSITIES. AND
DESPERATION TO PROVIDE DIAPERS
AND ENOUGH DIAPERS TO KEEP SKIN
INTEGRITY AT THAT MOMENT. AND
THIRD. REPORTER NINETEEN FIRES
LEFT OUR AREA AND DEVASTATION
AND THEN WE HAVE THE PANDEMIC.
THIS WEATHER SEVERE NEED IN OUR
COUNTY PRIOR. HE THE PANDEMIC.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF PARTNERING
WITH SUPPLY BANK .ORG. AND WITH
THEIR COOPERATION. EFFICIENCY
AND MAINTAINING.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE OUR FAMILIES WITH
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DIAPERS. L. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND WHITE SO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IN NEED THIS IS THE NO
WAY OF PREVENTION OF SKIN
INTEGRITY AND SECTIONS OF WHICH
WE HAD PERCENTAGES OF CHILDREN
IN OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS. DIAPERS
AND WIPES CONTINUE TO BE A
TOUGH HERE NEED IN OUR COUNTY
AS I AM SURE THE REST OF THE
STATE. AND THIS CRITICAL
FUNDING OF THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE THE SERVICE
WHAT THE FIVE ORG ENABLES US TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING THE BASIC
NEEDS. FOR CHILDREN ENSURING
LOGISTICS CHANNELS ARE IN PLACE
TO PROVIDE TO OUR FAMILY IN THE
EVENT OF FUTURE AMERICAN SCENE.
PLEASE HELP US KEEP OUR
CHILDREN SAFE I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TO TURN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI KAREN
KEEPER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES JUST ON A
COUPLE ITEMS ON PART HEY I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
VOTE THAT YOU- WILL BE TAKING
TO ELIMINATE THE FUNDING FOR
PREVENTION ACROSS THE BOARD AND
SPECIFICALLY REPEALING THAT
AGENTS THAT SEVEN. PERCENT CUT
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT- AND
ALSO GRATEFUL. THAT IN YOUR-
FOR ITEM NUMBER THREE UNDER
DISCUSSION WHEN YOU WERE
DEALING WITH THE AGENTS OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING- I TOOK
NOTES AT THE END OF BILLS BACK
BOLDLY SENATE DEMOCRATIC
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD- WHY DID
ONE OF YOUR PRIORITIES AND ARE
GRATEFUL THAT THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WANT TO ADDRESS. WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
BARGAINING THE LAST FEW YEARS
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO KEEP
THE CURRENT FISCAL STRUCTURE IN
PLACE WITH THE STATE'S PAYING
SIXTY FIVE IN THE COUNTY PAYING
35% OF THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
ALONG WITH THAT 10% OVER THREE
WORLD THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO
FUTURE SUCCESS. AND APPRECIATE
ARE YOU PUTTING FORWARD AS A
PRIORITY COLLECTIVE BARGAINING-
JUST COLLISION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- ONE YEAR IS NOW WILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS EVERYBODY WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RECORDS ASSOCIATION AND- SUMMER
ITEMS HEARD BY THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ON THE HUMAN SERVICES
FIVE REPORTER BY THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
OPERATING PROPERTIES WITH ALL
PRESIDENTIAL. AND RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
INDIVIDUALS. WITH EATING APPLE
PIE. WHAT ABOUT THAT HUNDRED
TWENTY DOLLARS I HELP ON
ASSOCIATION UP MINISTRY PUBLIC
PARTY AND THE PUBLIC CONSERVE
THEIR- FAMILIES WORKING FOR
PUBLIC GUARDIAN PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE. I DON'T KNOW HOW
FIVE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING FOR THAT. WELCOME PLACE
PROGRAM AND THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR. ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WHEN
COMBINED WITH CALTRAIN WILL
HELP WITH THAT TRANSFORMATION
FOR THE PUBLIC PAPER HOPE THAT
THAT BETTER SERVE INDIVIDUALS
WITH THE MEETING WITH.
POPULATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TO- TO YOUR LINE IS NOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS I MEAN TO BE
ATHLETIC WALKER DIRECTORS
FIFTY. WE DON'T KNOW THEY COULD
NOT OF THE PROP BEING
CONSIDERED AND ON THE ONLY IN
THE STATE ISSUE ON THE HAVE ALL
REQUIRE. THE FEDERALLY MANDATED
MIGRATION OF OUR SYSTEM INTO A
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WHICH BEGINS THE FALL OF THE ON
GOING FOR A COUPLE YEARS
REDUCES THE ABILITY TO MAKE A
LOT OF MAJOR CHANGE AS- WE
STATED EARLIER INPUT COMMITTEE
HEARING PROCESSES THAT CBA
URGES ARE INCLUSION IN
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THESE
PROPOSALS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT PRIORITIZATION REASONABLE
TIMELINE SOME POTENTIAL
OPTIONS. TO MAKE A PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL MORE LESS COMPLEX TO
AUTOMATE OR UNDERSTOOD AT THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION WORK
TOWARD THE FINAL BUDGET
PACKAGE. THERE'S LOTS IN THE
SENATE AGENDA TODAY- THAT WE
SUPPORT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT WE
HAVEN'T YET WEIGHED IN ON-
REGARDING THE COW WORKS GRANT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT-
INCREASING THEM- TO LIFT
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY AND
REGARDING THE REQUEST FOR
INCREASED RESOURCES TO PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
AND PUBLIC CONCERTS WERE ALSO
SUPPORTED THAT BACK. ON THE ICE
AT THE SITE AND WE SUPPORT
MAINTENANCE OF THE CURRENT BY
EACH OF THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING MECHANISM BUT WE
OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL TO IMPOSE A
FISCAL PENITENT PENALTY ON
COUNTIES TO COMPEL THEM TO
REACH A PARTICULAR OUTCOME AND
I JUST. COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR. IT
WILL PROTECT YOUR IS NOW UP.
BROKEBACK IN STYLE WITH A
NATIONALIST OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER HERE TO
COMMENT ON A FEW ISSUES- WE
SUPPORT REMOVING THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE FROM THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER RATE AND
ISSUES AFFECT UNDER PART A AND
PART AN INCREASE IN THE RATE
FOR FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO CARE 4100% IN
HOUSTON AND TEMPLE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE. AND PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED STABILITY STUDIES SHOW
THAT FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH
THAT SHE PERMANENTLY 75% OF THE
TIME WITH ONE SOCIAL WORKER AND
AFTER UP TO JUST 3% WITH MORE
THAN THREE I ALSO WANT TO THE
COURT- ITEM FIVE FEET AND-
EIGHT WHICH WOULD RESTORE THE
COST OF LIVING AND PERHAPS HAD
TO THE S. S. B. S. THAT HE
PROGRAM THIS. PROGRAM HAS NEVER
RECOVERED FROM RECESSIONARY%
HAD- AS I THINK WE ALL WILD OUT
AND I ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT
INCREASES TO ASK HOW WORKS
BRAND- BRIEFLY JUST WE ALSO
SUPPORT HEALTH CARE FOR ALL AND
HOPE THAT I CAN BE- EXTENDED TO
ALL UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS-
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT AND- SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO IS THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE.WHEN TWENTY NINE
RELATED AT. I'M SURE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN STUFF MY NAME IS
SHARON TO CHANCE I'M IN A YOU
JUST AS PROVIDE IN THE BOSTON
COUNTY IN SOCCER COUNTY THANK
YOU MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THREE ITEMS YOUR
TODAY ONE IS WERE THE FOR PER
CUTS- I KNOW OF NO. EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE WHERE YOU'RE EXPECTED
TO DO A CERTAIN JOB AND GET GET
PAID 7% LAST AND HAVING THAT
OVERHEAD YEAR AFTER YEAR IS
STRESSFUL IN STRESSFUL IN
STRESSFUL JOB SO I WOULD LIKE
TO. SEE IF WE CAN GET BACK
BECAUSE COUNTRY RETURNED
PERMANENTLY ALSO I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE FI YOU TURNING
INTO A PENALTY- FOR ME THIS
MEANS THE PROVIDER THIS MEANS
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO DO IS DELAY
TACTICS ARE LIKE A SEALABLE
LET'S SEE WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
HERE WHAT'S GOING TO SEE WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN HERE. WHICH ALSO
TIES INTO THE COST I'M SURE IF
YOU LIFT IF YOU FLIP THE
PERCENTAGE OF OUR SHARE OF THE
COST BETWEEN THE STATEMENT
COUNTY WHERE AS OF RIGHT NOW
THE COUNTY HAS 35% IN THE STATE
SPAIN SIXTY. 65% THIS WILL ALSO
BECAUSE THE COUNTY IS NOT TO
WANT TO BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO SAY
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT ANYMORE-
PAGE. I APOLOGIZE I'M VERY
FIRST RIGHT NOW- ARE YOU TO WE
HAS. AND INCREASE BY 30% IN I'M
SORRY NO THAT'S WRONG. THAT'S
OKAY OKAY. WE'RE GONNA BE FINE.
OKAY I HEAR YOU YOU THINK THE
6530% SLIPPED BECAUSE AFFECT
THE SHERIFF BECAUSE WEIGHED
GOING TO INCREASE BY 30% AND WE
DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN AND
ALSO- ACCORDING A RECENT REPORT
BY THE STATE ALL FOUND THAT ARE
YOU SURE TO ONLY MAKES IT EIGHT
PER OF A LITTLE WE GAINS STATE
WHY. AND THOSE ARE THE REASON
WHY I HAVE THOSE THREE CONCERN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. IN NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. OKAY.
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE ON THEN IF.
FOLLOWING UP. BUT INSTEAD OF
THIS THING YODA BUT IT DOES
INSTEAD OF THAT COULD MEET THEM.
ME NO IS UNDER SO NOT PRO LOT
OF THE- PROJECT THERE DEBATE
SPILL CALIF. YOUR SOFTWARE.
INPUT IN MEMOS OF THE- THOUGHT
I LOOK ON BOTH OF THE NEW AND I
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT AND MAKE TO
DO THE- GOALLESS PRO. A JUSTICE.
YEAH THE. THIS IS DINNER THANK
PLEASE. WHEN I NINE YEAR IS NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON OUT CHAIR AND
NOW. MY NAME IS REINA TO CALL.
AND OH SORRY I PROVIDED TOOK TO
BE PAID JOB MINIMUM WAGE AND
THERE WE IMPOSE THAT PERCENT
PENALTY AND CAL. WE USED TO IN
GOOD FAITH EVERYTHING RECORD BY
THE STATE AUDITOR THAT HIGHER
CHANCES CHARACTER. MAKE ONLY 8%
OF THE NAMING WAGE STATE LINE
FOR THAT REASON I SUPPORT THE
10% PENALTY ON COUNTY BELT
BARGAIN WITH BATH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE
BUT GOING FORWARD AND THANK
CALLER'S GOING FORWARD IF
YOU'RE CALLING ABOUT THE AYE
EDGE AYE HSS ISSUE THE SENATE
IS A- SUPPORTING THAT SO IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE I. H. S.
CHANGES THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. MY NAME WHITE OFF I
LINE IS NOW OPEN. TWENTY TWO OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
MIND IS NEEDED RIGHT ARE YOU.
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CALL YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON. ONE
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BENITO TO ABOUT OLD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SUPPLY BANK .ORG
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE INVESTMENT FOR STATEWIDE
DIAPER IN WHITE DISTRIBUTION
THROUGH THE FIFTY COUNTY DIAPER
BANK PROGRAM. THIS PROPOSAL IN
LINE WITH THE SENATE BILL BACK
WILL BE PLAN WHICH CALLS FOR
INCREASED SUPPORT FOR DIAPER
BANKS TO STRENGTHEN THE SAFETY
NET. FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
ORGANIZATIONS PARTNERED WITH
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONS CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. AND OTHERS TO
DISTRIBUTE CRITICAL SUPPLIES TO
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING POVERTY
OR IN CRISIS FROM DISASTERS
SUCH AS WILDFIRES OVER THE
PANDEMIC. THIS PROGRAM
INITIALLY BEGAN IN SIX COUNTIES
INCLUDING SAN JOAQUIN AND
SACRAMENTO AND QUICKLY EXPANDED
TO SIXTEEN OTHERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THE ONSET OF THE- TO
PRESENT DAY SUPPLY LINK OUT OR
UTILIZE THIS PROGRAM
FRAMEWORKS. FOR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY EMERGENCY SUPPLY
PROGRAMS FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS SERVING THE KIDS OF
THE CENTRAL PERSONNEL. IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS OUR
STATE. PROGRAMS INCLUDING MORE
THAN THIRTEEN MILLION DIAPERS
AND WIPES. AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION WIPES EXCUSE ME AND-
I'M GOING. R. FIFTY EIGHT FIRST
FIVE NEED TO. COMPLETED THIS
LAST FEBRUARY DURING THE PEAK
OF THE SURGE CHAU TO THE DIAPER
NEED AND WIPED NEED WITH THAT
RECORD LEVELS OFTEN SURPASSING
PP. ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTLESS
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NO OTHER
OUTLET FOR THIS RESOURCE WE ASK
YOU TO APPROVE THIS FUNDING
REQUEST THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND HEARING ABOUT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIX BEDS
THAT EACH IT TO THE
DISASSOCIATION RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED- HOME
LIKE SETTING THE EXPENSE OR
FEWER. WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF TWO
MEASURES- THE FIRST ONE IS
INVOLVING SSI RECIPIENTS IT'S
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
MAINTAIN A LICENSE A FELONY
WITH CURRENT SS PI GRANT
SELIGMAN DURING FEWER AND FEWER
SSI RECIPIENTS OR EVEN CLOSING
DOWN ALTOGETHER. SO THE
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT PROVIDED
BY SB SIX FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE UNDER THE
PILOT PROGRAM WITH AND OUT OF
THE NEED MORE SERVICE PRESS I
WAS AT THE END AND PREVENT THE
CLOSURE OF MANY RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE
ELDERLY. ON THE SECOND ITEM IS
pSUPPORT. FUNDS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE REFURBISHING WHILE
NEEDED THEY DON'T ADDRESS THE
MAIN CAUSES ITS OWN CLOSURES
WHICH IS INADEQUACY OF. GRANT
PARK HERE IN RCMP SO JENNIFER
PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THAT
PROMOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLOR PLEASE. ONE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LORRAINE F.
THE TALLY HERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD- WE REPRESENT A FIFTY
NINE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES. AND THIS IS ABOUT ITEM
NUMBER ONE IN YOUR PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS PART OF RICH
AND A- CAL WORKS INDIAN HEALTH
CLINIC PROGRAM FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ERVICES BEGAN IN FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND ONE OH TWO.
AND CONTINUES WITH THIRTY SIX
INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS STATEWIDE
THROUGH A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE I. EIGHT SEATS
PROVIDE- CAL WORKS CLIENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ALCOHOL AND OTHER
DRUG PREVENTION TREATMENT PLANS
AND REFERRAL SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT THE CLIENT'S ABILITY.
TO REMAIN ENGAGED IN JOB
TRAINING AND TO PUSH PURSUE
STABLE EMPLOYMENT. TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES. AND IN. WE HAVE
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND A
LOT AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN
NATIVE ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
CENSUS AND THERE ARE A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED NINE TRIED. IN THE
STATE AND THIS IS MORE NATIVE
AMERICANS THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE HUMANA. AND THE- THE
URGENCY OF THE- CAL WORK IN
HEALTH CLINIC PROGRAM. GOES TO
THE NEEDS FOR- FOR MENTAL
HEALTH FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION
FOR- SUBSTANCE DISORDER AND THE
CORPORATE NINETEEN EFFECTS ON
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES-
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL AREAS.
AND SO THE CAL WERE TREATED
HEALTH CLINIC BUDGET WAS CUT
SIGNIFICANTLY DURING THE
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
OH NINE AND TO DATE THE FUNDING
HAS NOT BEEN RESTORED. POSSIBLE
ONLY REASON IN THE PAST
THIRTEEN YEARS INCLUDING COST
OF LIVING IN URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS. THIS IS RESULTED IN THE
AND INABILITY OF SOME INDIAN
HEALTH CLINICS TO CONTINUE.
SERVICES WITH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
FOR EACH CLINICOF ONLY
530-009-0050 AND THAT THAT'S IT
TOTAL. DSS SAYS BUT NOT ALL THE
DOLLARS ARE SPENT HOWEVER SOME
PROGRAMS HAVE JUST HAD TO GIVE
UP. ON NOT BEING ABLE TO
SURVIVE ON ON SUCH A LITTLE
AMOUNT. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
STATE THAT THE MO YOU REQUIRED-
ACTIVITIES THAT- THAT INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION AND- TO
GEOGRAPHICALLY REMOTE AREAS OF
THE STATE REQUIRED SEVERAL
HOURS OF TRAVEL. MO YOU DOES
NOT CONTEMPLATE THE WAIT TIMES
AND COMPLICATIONS THAT MAY
ARISE DURING THE PERFORMANCE OF
THIS DUTY. AND SO- ARE AT THE
REQUEST INCLUDES THAT DSS
SHOULD EITHER PROVIDE A
VEHICLE. OR FUNDS FOR THE LEAST
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE OF
THE VEHICLE FOR EACH ENGINE
HEALTH CLINIC. AND OR THE-
REIMBURSEMENT AT FIFTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE CENTS. PER MILE IF
BEEN INDIVIDUAL USES THEIR
PHONE- VEHICLE OKAY I'M AN
ASSET I REMEMBER HIM ASKING TO
WRAP UP AND IF YOU HAVE MORE.
COMMENT YOU CAN ALWAYS
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE. YES
OKAY SO IN FOR THE MO YOU NEEDS
TO INCLUDING ANNUAL
REIMBURSEMENT OF 460-005-0040
ONE WHICH WOULD TAKE EACH
CLINIC TO A TOTAL AMOUNT OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY ONE AND THAT'S WHAT-
REFLECTED IN THAT- IN THAT ITEM
ON YOUR AGENDA AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AT YOUR
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
THE MONTEREY COOLEY AND I'M
CALLING FROM JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU I'M CALLING
ABOUT A GENDER ANY RELATED TO
T. AT THAT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR. PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS PURPLE PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING DURING THE PANDEMIC
PANDEMIC RECOVERY PERIOD FOR
HELPING SUPPORT FOR CURRENT
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. MINISTER
THURSDAY IN MARCH TO UNDERSTAND
THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE POPULATION MORE
THAN ONE IN FIVE YEARS RECORDED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AT
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC. SO
YOU CAN EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
WERE BOTH MORE LIKELY TO DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL. AND LESS LIKELY
TO BE EMPLOYED. WHAT I HOUSING
AND HOME RISK. THE TRAINING FOR
SOCIAL WORK BECAUSE NOT. AND
ESTABLISH FUNDING FOR COUNTY HI.
COSTS SACRAMENTO FUNDING FOR
THE FUTURE PEOPLE UP. BUT
PROVIDES TWENTY MONTHS
AFFORDABLE AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THE FORMER COFFEE AT
AGE TWENTY FOUR. ELEVEN ELEVEN
COUNTIES WITH THE HIGHEST
HOUSING COSTS IN THE STATE-
HAVE EXPERIENCE AT ONE HUNDRED
AND 17% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR TWO YEARS PEOPLE JUST
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TO. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN EIGHTY
THOUSAND TWENTY. COMPARED 230%
FOR THE LOWER COST COUNTY. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS REGIONAL
INEQUITY WE URGE YOUR INCLUSION
UNDER INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE
AFTER YEARS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR IS NOW OPEN- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANNY TO
STRONG GRIN AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
FOR A RP CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR THREE POINT THREE
MILLION A. A. R. P. MEMBERS AND
ALL OLDER CALIFORNIA'S. FIRST
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE BILL
THE BACK BOLDLY PLAN THERE'S
MUCH TO CELEBRATE IN THE PLAN
THEN YOU'RE THINKING ON HOW TO
BEST UTILIZE FORTHCOMING
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN MONIES-
AND WE SUPPORT THE AGING
PACKAGES WELL THAT INCLUDES
SEVERAL OF THE A RP PRIORITIES
WITH REGARDS TO THE VOTE ONLY
AGENDA WE SUPPORT ISSUE ONE-
AND WE SUPPORT ISSUE FIVE BUT
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD
JUST ADDRESS. SPECIFICALLY THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS OF ISSUE
NUMBER SIX ON THE AGENDA A. L.
A. R. P. SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO
PURCHASE AND REHABILITATE ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY TO INCREASE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. WE
ALSO HOPE TO SEE MORE INCLUDED
IN THE FINAL BUDGET RELATED TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING THEY WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT SOME
OF THOSE ITEMS WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE- SENATE- B. B.
B. PLAN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
AGAIN COLORS WE STILL HAVE
ABOUT FORTY PEOPLE ON THE LINE
AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
BE VERY BRIEF IN YOUR COMMENTS
PLEASE AND AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING FURTHER TO ADD. YOU
CAN ALWAYS CONTACT THE
COMMITTEE. TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATALIN COOPER I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF END CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM FIVE ONE EIGHT OH ISSUE
FIVE EIGHT THE UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME FOR TRANSITION AGE
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ACT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT'S KIND OF HOW WE'RE
LOOKING FOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. BATUM SHARE DANNY OFFER
WITH THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS
NOBBY CALIFORNIA. WORK OF ITEM
EIGHT ON AGENDA B. FOR THE
PAPER HEALTH CONTINUUM AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. YOUR MY TIME TO
THIRTY SEVEN OTHER CALLERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DANNY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MA'AM SHARON MEMBERS
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA CALLING
IT THE PART OF THE INVESTMENT
PRISTINE WHITE PAPER AND MY
DISTRIBUTION. THE PROGRAM
PERCENT CALIFORNIA HAS
PARTNERED WITH THE WIDENING
.ORG TO DISTRIBUTE DIAPERS AND
WIPES THANK YOU THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. TWO THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
OMMITTEE MEMBERS KRISTOFF
MAYOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMON WITH THOSE F. UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF
HFS. ISSUES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH CRUZ I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH CALLING
FROM VENTURA CALIFORNIA. USED
TO COURT THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE INFANT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME FOR PERSON ON THE U. D. W.
MEMBER AND I HIT THE PROVIDER
FOR MERCED COUNTY I SUPPORT IT
CAN PRESENT THE FULL COUNTY ON
COUNTY THINKING NOT DIG OKAY
THANK YOU EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SABRINA
FORTE AND I'M FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THAT UNDER TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR DOCTOR YOU PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND THE INCOMPATIBLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO FORTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YEAH
THANK YOU SENATORS AND STAFF
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY NAME IS
SANDRA GENOVA I'M A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WITH THE SPIRIT NOT IN
OUR FOSTER CARE PROGRAM I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF REMOVING
PROFESSIONALLY WHICH FOR THE
FFA SOCIAL WORKER RATE AND ALSO
SUPPORTING THE INCREASE OF THE
FSA SOCIAL WORKER WAIT TO
REDUCE TURNOVER AND INCREASING
PERMANENCY FOR FOSTER YOUTH
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. TWO THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ANYONE WITH A CREATIVE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT OF ITEMS
ON PART. UNDER THE
ACCESSIBILITY TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE MAKING LIGHT OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING MECHANISM
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE RELATED TO
AGE BECAUSE OF OURS AND I'M
DIFFICULT FOR INVESTMENT IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWO
BILLS THAT WAS NOT ON THE
EQUITY CORE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE OF OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JANE SCHROEDER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF FIRST PLACE FOR
YOU IN REGARDS TO PART OF THE
HEARING HUNDRED PSI FOR CALLING
TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PREVENTING AND REDUCING
PROCTOR YOU HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL- AND ALSO FOR THAT-
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH OPPOSE ALL
TRICKS THAT YOU CAN PRINT
DOCUMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOLLOWING
FRIDAY'S- ME NUMBER AND
STANDING IN THE MOMENT WHEN I
THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND THEN THE
MOMENT. THANK. THANK YOU. YOU
SUPPORT HSS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. TWO FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUCKINGHAM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALEXIS A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I MEAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE HEALTHY FUTURE FOR
PROFITS PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAMS CHAIR AND STAFF HI MY
NAME IS SHERRY JOHNSON I'M A
QUEENIE FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
FOSTER CARE INVOLVED WITHOUT
AGENCY I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF REMOVING THIS PENSION
LANGUAGE FROM THE EFFORT THEY
SOCIAL WORK RATE AND INCREASING
THE FOSTER FAMILY SOCIAL WORK
RATE TO REDUCE TURNOVER
INCREASE PERMANENTLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBERS MANAGERS JOHNSON
AND I AM FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY
AND THE CORPORATE SPONSOR USED
INTERFERE ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATION TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE- SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR COST YOU THE PROPOSAL. TO
EXTEND THE INFANT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
REPRESENTING THE COMPANY
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND COOK AT
THE DS AT THE LAY OF THE REPEAL
OF FUNDING FOR VERY AT
CHILDREN'S PROGRAMS ISSUE
NUMBER SIX AS WELL AS ISSUE
FIVE AGENTS RANKING THE
THINKING THAT PARTICULARLY THE
KIND OF PROGRAMS ABOUT PROVIDE
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME FOR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH AND FUNDS
TO PROVIDE. RELIEF FOR A SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER CANCEL OKAY WITH
CHILDREN OFTEN OF CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN FONTANA REPRESENTS ALL
THE CHILDREN ALL OF SANTA
SACRAMENTO AFTER COUNTY AFTER
CARE SYSTEM I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLAR HELP THE
FUTURE FIVE G. PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND AND CONTRACT. THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ASIAN NEED THEM UP ON THE
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD AMONG
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I'M CALLING
REGARDING PART EIGHT OF THE
HEARING UNDER DSS I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION PREVENTING
AND REDUCING FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BUDGET PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ELAINE QUEEN I'M AND
I JUST AS PROVIDER MERCED
COUNTY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE 10% FISCAL PENTAGRAM COUNTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE. TWO
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUSTICE
JULIE SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT- IN PART
EIGHTY FOR ITEMS NUMBER THREE
AND SIX RELATING TO SUPPORTING
PEOPLE ON AFTER FINALLY BEING
IN OURS AND RCSD WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT BOTH OF THE APPROACH IS
CONTEMPLATED THE DIRECT MONTHLY
SUBSIDIES AND THE ACQUISITION.
AND PUBLIC OWNERSHIP APPROACH
IN ORDER TO GET COUNTIES THE
OPTION TO CHOOSE THE APPROACH
THAT BEST MEETS THEIR CLIENTS
ME. ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT A. N. FOR ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IN PART BE- THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA TORRES AND I'M TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD AND A FORMER
QUESTIONS I'M CALLING REGARDING
PART EIGHT OF THE HEARING UNDER
DIAZ AT. I'M GOING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE EIGHTEEN POINT
TWO. MILLION PREVENTING AND
REDUCING PARTIALLY COMMON
BUDGET PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M HERE MY NAME IS MEGAN
MEDINA I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT SURE LAUGHS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF TWO IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS. INDICATE THE FIRST
ITEM. IT HI HE- EIGHTY MY
ATTITUDE IS GOOD THANK THE- WHO
ARE BACKING. THREE ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. TWO FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR EGGMAN ARE
REPRESENTING THE STAMFORD CARE
YOUTH AND FAMILIES WE SUPPORT
REMOVING THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE FROM THE AFFECT A
SOCIAL WORKER RATE AND
INCREASING THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TWO
STUDENTS WHO MONDAY THANKS
JERRY THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TWO
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS OVERLY YEAR
FROM COMMERCIAL CONTROLLER FOR
LUNCHES HUNDREDS OF YOUR VOICE
HOME WE ARE WITH YOUR COMPUTER
AFTER THREE. BUT THE PROGRAM
NINETEEN. AND WE ARE. THE
APPROVAL OF DON'T BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA LAWYER ONE COLDER
NINETEEN WE CAN BURKE EXPECTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. ONE FIFTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TERESA
PASQUINI I AM AN ARMY MEMBER
AND THE PROUD MOM AT ALL NINE
WHO IS DIRECTLY WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. I'M ALSO THE AUTHOR CO
AUTHOR OF THE WHITE PAPER
CALLED COUNTY NEED TO HEAL AND
WAS A PROUD COSIGNER AT THE
LETTER DATED TO EIGHTEEN IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
DEVELOPED INFRASTRUCTURE BUDGET
ITEM. I AM CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
ON AGENDA B. AND ADDITIONALLY I
HOPE THAT ARE HELPING TO FUEL
EFFICIENT WILL BE CONSIDERED
AS- A WHOLE PROPOSAL MOVES
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT MOMS
LIKE ME AND FAMILIES LIKE MINE
WILL NOT BE FORGOTTEN IN ALL OF
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND HOW THE
DEPRESSION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IT WAS NICE
TALKING WITH YOU ON FRIDAY.
AFTERNOON NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WILL NOW. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA WILLIAMS I'M A HOME
CARE PROVIDER- OF ORANGE COUNTY
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF U. D. W.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
THE 10% PENALTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
THERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOURTEEN
COMMISSION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF- AGAIN DAY ANY ISSUES SIX
THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM AND ALSO A GET ANY-
ISSUING EIGHT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUE IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS ARE INSTITUTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JORDAN SAYS A FORMER FOX YOU
THINK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
PROPOSAL ISSUE FIVE EIGHT TO
FUND A PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
A UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME FOR
TRANSITION EACH YEAR WE ARE
ALSO CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND. HEALTHY FUTURES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND THE EFFORT ON THAT SHOW
AND LAST WEEK MARKET MONEY TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF PREVENTING AND
REDUCING FOSSE'S HOMELESSNESS
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES I
DID. WALDRON FAMILY SERVICES
I'M THANK YOU MADAM CHAD I'M
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ARE A
THOUGHT THE FAMILY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AGENCY AND
I'M HERE. SHARES STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE
FROM THE FFA SOCIAL WORK GREAT.
REDUCE TURNOVER AND INCREASED
PERMANENCY IN ADDITION I'M ALSO
HERE THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROVIDED. ON THE CALL AB AT THE
HEARING ON THE DSS. THE COURT
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
PREVENTING AND REDUCING COSTS
THAT HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL
WHICH IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
PROVIDE MORE HOUSING FOR OPTOMA
FOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JAN
WRECKED RENDON WENT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS. I AM A
FORMER FOSTER PARENTS AND I. AM
CALLING IN TO EXPRESS
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT THERE
HASN'T BEEN A THREAT DISCUSSION
ON- SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND FAMILY HOME SETTING
AND FOSTER CARE- THE ONE GROUP
COULD NOT RECEIVE ANY SUPPORT-
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND THE
FAMILY HAVE GIVEN OUT- OUR
STATE GIVEN THAT JOB EACH
STUDENT AT TEACH THEIR YOUTH AT
HOME DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND
IT IS- IT IS PUTTING THE
ABILITY TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
PROCTOR PARENT AT GREAT RISK
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SIXTY TWO YEAR LINE IT'LL FIVE.
NOT SURE MEMBERS AND SHANE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA OF FOOD BANKS I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS GRATITUDE
AND SUPPORT FOR- ITEMS BY TNC
ON PUTTING CASH ASSISTANCE FOR
ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
AND YOUR- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU SENATORS AND
STAFF MY NAME IS TIED TO MY
FIANCE AND THE DIRECTOR AT. JOB
AND FAMILY SERVICES FOSTER AND
ADOPTION IN SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OUR FAMILY
BOTH PLANET. GOOD FOR YOU TO
STEP. REMOVING THE SUSPENSE
LAMP. FROM THE OTHER THREE
SOCIAL WORKER RATE ALSO
SUPPORTING INCREASING THE FACE
SOCIAL WORKERS RATE- THAT WILL
ABSOLUTELY REDUCE TURNOVER AND
INCREASED PENALTY AND LASTLY.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF INCREASING.
FUNDS FOR HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH
IN OUR PHD PLUS PROGRAMS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SARAH FOX
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK CALLING
ABOUT PART B. FOR ISSUE THREE
EVEN WITH LIKE A FEW POSITIONS
IN THE MANAGED CARE PLANS
STATEWIDE PROCUREMENT TO BE
FOCUSED ON EQUITY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPECIFICALLY.
AND THEN FOR ITEM SEVEN WE
SUPPORT THE BABY OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PAYMENT REFORM AND
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS
AND WILL BE SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO YOU CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY CALLAHAN
IN PARTICULAR THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROPOSAL TO
INTEGRATE CULTURAL COMPETENCE
STANDARDS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS EVENING
AND MY NAME IS LAURA RICHARDSON
CALLING FROM QUEEN ANNE OF
FAMILY SERVICES THAT STATEWIDE
FOSTER CARE AGENCY AND I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR REMOVING THE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE FROM THE FSA SOCIAL
WORKER RATE. AND MY SUPPORT OF
INCREASING THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKER RATE TO
REDUCE TURNOVER AND INCREASE
PERMANENTLY FOR FOSTER YOUTH
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. DO NOT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TRENT SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
CONSERVATISM PUBLIC GUARDIANS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS STATE
FUNDING FOR THESE SERVICES
WHICH WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY THE STATE OF THAT
WERE PROVIDED. TONY SUPPORT FOR
THESE SERVICES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MARTY A MOTO FAMILY
MEMBER OF A SISTER WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
WITH CITY CAN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SINGER COMING ACTION
NETWORK AND A MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICES TASK
FORCE- JUST STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ALL OF THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND PRIORITIES REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE SENATE
ADVANCING THOSE ESPECIALLY
THOSE- RELATED TO REMOVING THE
SENSE THAT. ESPECIALLY TO THE
RATE INCREASES TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ALSO REMOVING- THE 10%
ACROSS THE BOARD REDUCTION DIET
SHISHA I JUST SAYS AMONG OTHER
THINGS SO THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T
REMEMBER THIS CHRISTMAS OPTIONS.
AND I'M ON POVERTY WOMEN IN
YOUR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WHO CALLED IN THE
BODY A. YOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY SAY THAT
IF YOU DIDN'T GET TO CALL IT IF
YOU DIDN'T GET THE CALL IN THAT
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU STILL
CONTACT THE COMMITTEE. YOUR
INPUT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US-
I WOULD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OUR VOTING PART OF OUR
AGENDA NOW SO I WOULD ASK
DOCTORS AT PAN AND CENTER
MELENDEZ TO- TO BE STANDING BY.
AND WE WILL TAKE A THREE MINUTE
RECESS.
THE VOTING PROCESS OF
OUR OF OUR AGENDA. NEEDED ITEMS
WE HEARD TODAY WILL BE HELD
OPEN BUT SOME ARE FOR- ACTION
TODAY AND SO I'M GONNA ASK THE
CONSULTANT IF THEY CAN VERIFY
AND WHAT WE'LL DO SO WE'LL TAKE
TWO DIFFERENT VOTES WERE GONNA
VOTE. ON BERNARD SEPARATE ITEM
THREE OUT AND THAT'S THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE NOW WE'RE
GONNA PULL THAT ONE OUT AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON THE
OTHER THROUGHOUT- EVERYTHING
ELSE FIRST AND THE CONSULTANT
WILL READ EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON AFTER WE GET A
MOTION. I WILL MOVE. WELL YOU
SHOULD BE READING THEN I MOVED-
THE CONSULTANT WILL READ. THE
MOTION IS. UP TO THREE
EXPANSION MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THE MOTION WOULD BE TO
ADOPT THE EAST AFRICAN NATION.
MOVED THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE
ANY COMMENTS OR DISCUSSION. AND
I WOULD JUST SAY FOR THE RECORD
THIS IS A BEEN A LONG GOAL FOR
THAT- FOR THE SENATE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN TO EXPAND
HEALTH CARE TO AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE THIS IS FOR MOST
VULNERABLE ELDERS- TOOK THE
EXPANSION OF- OF MEDICO- THAT.
CAN CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EGGMAN HI MELENDEZ. MY
VERY WE WILL OFFER TO WORK
EVERY. SHOULD COMPLETE THE
RAWNESS HOLDEN DIVIDEND HOLD
HOLD THE- OF AND GREAT ANSWER I.
OKAY THAT IS AT TWO TWO ZERO
AND WE WILL HOLD RULED OPEN ON
THAT FOR US ADDED MEMBERS OKAY
THE NEXT MOTION IS. EXCEPTIONS
OF THE BUDGET OF. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL. CONSULTANT THE
MOTION WOULD BE FOR ADOPTION OF
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ISSUE ONE UNDER ITEM FORTY ONE
SEVENTY TO PREVENT AGING DELAY
REPEAL OF FUNDING FOR AGING
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTIONS
AND SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
ISSUE TO UNDER FORTY TO SIXTY
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
DELAY REPEAL OF PROGRAM AND
BENEFITS EXPANSIONS ISSUE FOR
UNDER ITEM FORTY THREE HUNDRED
APARTMENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DELAY REPEAL OF
FUNDING FOR SPACE BY PROVIDER
RATE INCREASES IN THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE- ISSUES FIVE
UNDER. FIFTY ONE EIGHTY
PROBLEMS OR SERVICES DELAY OF
REPEAL FUNDING FOR RESTORATION
OF THE 7% CONTAGIOUS A SERVICE
HOURS AND ISSUE SIX UNDER ITEM
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY DELAY OF
REPEAL FUNDING FOR VARIOUS
CHILDREN'S PROGRAMS. THE MOVED.
ALL RIGHT CONSULTANT PLEASE THE
ROLL EGGMAN HI MELENDEZ. M. HI.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT'S SANTA TWO
ZERO THAT WILL GET OUT BUT WE
WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN AND
SEE IF WE CAN'T TRACK DOWN.
CENTER MELENDEZ.
OKAY THERE'S A
CENTER MELENDEZ SO- CENTER
MELENDEZ WE'RE HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN WE VOTED ON. EVERYTHING SO
FAR BUT WE ARE NOW WOULDN'T GO
BACK- AT THE FIRST VOTE WE TOOK
WAS ON ITEM NUMBER THREE THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE L.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABOUT PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS MELINDA'S RIGHT NOW.
ONE IS THAT OKAY THE SECOND BUT
WE TOOK WAS ON ALL THE OTHER
ITEMS WHICH THE CONSULTANT
BREAD AT THAT TIME CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ I. WANT
IS I. YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR. ALL RIGHT
AND THAT WAS ORDERED ON THEM
FOR YOU DON'T YOU NEED TO CALL
OUT THAT THAT'S BEEN PASSED
STRUCTURE. THOSE TWO BILLS
PASSED OUT THE- THE FIRST ONE
TO TWO. ZERO THE SECOND ONE TWO
THREE TWO ONE THE SECOND ONE IS
THREE TWO ZERO. BOTH THOSE
BILLS BOTH BOTH THOSE BUDGET
ITEMS PASSED THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THIS MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED.